Aber du wolltest nicht.
Ich wollte nicht. Ich war in München, hatte dort einen Vortrag bei den Jusos zu halten. Aber für mich ist ja das Biertrinken schon gar nichts.
Und in ein Festzelt reinzugehen ist eigentlich auch nicht so meine Sache.
Insofern habe ich dann nur am Bahnhof ein bisschen Oktoberfest Stimmung verspürt.
Wenn da die Leute aus Nicht Bayern irgendwo mit Lederhosen ankommen und dann sich früh anstellen müssen, um da hinzukommen, also mitunter schon um 8:00.
Also es ist doch erstaunlich, diese eigenartige Bier Trinkkultur.
Aber ich bin natürlich froh, dass es stattfindet, dass gefeiert wird, auch wenn es nicht meine Sache ist. Aber ich finde das gut.
Ich finde nicht gut, dass wir Politiker haben, die erst noch eine Verschärfung der Corona Regeln abstimmen, dafür stimmen und dann aber selbst aufs Oktoberfest fahren.
Und das ist auch nicht mehr ja, wir sind ja alle Menschen, sondern nein, da versucht man einfach mit zweierlei Maß zu messen bzw nimmt sich selbst immer völlig aus der Gleichung raus, als hätte das alles mit einem selbst nichts zu tun.
Und das ist für mich so ein symptomatischer Fall von Politik, wie wir sie die ganze Zeit erleben, dass etwas.
Verabschiedet wird, aber das natürlich für einen selbst jetzt nicht gilt und dass da auch gar nicht der Widerspruch mehr erkannt wird.
Und na ja, das hat mich wiederum sehr geärgert. Was mich gefreut hat, war Das passt ein bisschen zu deiner alten Republik.
Ich hatte einen Vortrag in einem Seniorenheim oder ich muss viel mehr sagen In einer Seniorenresidenz war es und ich habe es angenommen, weil es so ein,
weil es so eine kuriose Anfrage war, ein Vortrag über Filme in einer Seniorenresidenz zu halten, weil ich so was noch nie gemacht habe, dachte ich.
Vielleicht geht man dahin und lernt noch etwas. Und so war es dann auch tatsächlich.
Zunächst habe ich gelernt, dass man auch da.
Und jetzt müssen sich alle ganz festhalten.
Risikogruppe. Und so weiter. Dass man dort dann im Saal bei einem Vortrag sitzt und die Maske abzieht.
Wow.
Ja, das gehört dazu.
Also waren auch viele Senioren da Oder war es nur die Location? Eine Seniorin nur.
Nein, nein, es waren nur Senioren da. Das hat man leider noch nicht öffnen können, sagte man mir mit Bedauern.
Noch nicht öffnen können, sagte man mir mit Bedauern. Sonst lässt man nämlich auch Gäste von außerhalb, also Vorträge und Veranstaltungen, ein.
Sonst lässt man nämlich auch Gäste von außerhalb bei solchen Vorträgen und Veranstaltungen rein.
Aber das sei immer noch ein bisschen schwierig. Alles. Aber es ist auch sehr schwierig, wieder Menschen dazu zu bewegen, ihre Zimmer zu verlassen und wieder an der Gesellschaft teilzunehmen.
Und was ich aber eigentlich gelernt habe, und das fand ich ganz bemerkenswert.
Ich fragte dann so ganz vorsichtig unter Machen Sie jeden Monat so eine Veranstaltung. Und dann sahen die beiden Damen, die das organisieren, sich an und sagten Nee, nee, mehrmals die Woche machen wir hier, was wir machen Filmabende, hier sind Konzerte, sind Vorträge und und und.
Ich fragte dann so ganz vorsichtig Und machen Sie jeden Monat so eine Veranstaltung.
Und dann sagen die beiden Damen, die das organisieren, sich an und sagten ihnen mehrmals. Eine.
Urlaub bis zum Lebensende, wirklich Urlaub bis zum Lebensende. Und man darf sich das aber jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass da die große Nostalgie Show aufgefahren wird.
Es ist wirklich Urlaub bis zum Lebensende und man darf sich das aber jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass da die große Nostalgie Show aufgefahren wird.
Also es gibt da nicht von morgens bis abends Heimatfilme oder so etwas, ganz im Gegenteil, es wird auch die Feuerzangenbowle partout nicht gezeigt.
Es gibt da nicht von morgens bis abends Heimatfilme oder so etwas.
Ganz im Gegenteil, es wird auch die Feuerzangenbowle partout nicht gezeigt. Also sagte dann die eine namens mir Da weigert sie sich beharrlich.
Also sagte dann die eine Dame zu mir Da weigert sie sich beharrlich. Das wird gewünscht, aber es wird nicht gemacht.
Wird gewünscht. Aber genau, es wird nämlich gewünscht.
Es wird gewünscht, aber es wird nicht gemacht. Und warum? Und das fand ich sehr gut.
Wir müssen aufpassen, gerade wenn wir es mit alten Leuten zu tun haben, dass wir aus ihnen keine Zeitzeugen machen.
Die sollen an der Gegenwart, die sollen mit der Gegenwart leben.
Und wenn nicht, nämlich Besuch bekommen von ihren Enkeln und von ihren Kindern, dann sollen die sich über einen aktuellen Film unterhalten können und sagen Ja, den habe ich auch gesehen oder ein aktuelles Buch.
Und dann sollen die nicht sagen, Das war damals schön mit dem Heinz Rühmann vor 100 Jahren. Nein, die sollen in der Gegenwart sein, die sollen keine Zeitzeugen werden. Das fand ich wirklich einen sehr, sehr guten Satz.
Ja, das ist wahnsinnig gut. Ich hör das zum Ersten Mal so, denn sonst ist immer die Gefahr.
Gerade wenn man jemanden wie dich zum Thema Film unter alte Leute schickt, dass da eine große Einigkeit herrscht, dass natürlich der beste Film aller Zeiten einer aus der Schwarz Weiß Zeit ist.
Und ich vielleicht doch noch mal eine kleine Yuppie Heesters Imitation hinlege. Ja.
Genau. Genau. Dass du die dann auch noch mal zurückkatapultiert und das Standardprogramm wie Netflix machst. Und alle noch mal in den Sechzigern, wo bei Netflix sich die 80er ausgesucht hat, verwickelt.
Die Standardprogramm wie Netflix und alle noch mal in den Sechzigern, wobei Netflix sich die 80er ausgesucht hat.
Verwickelt. Sehr gut. Das ist ein sehr starker Satz. Wir wollen sie hier auf der Höhe des Moments haben. Ja, gerade in Kontakt mit den Jungen.
Sehr gut. Ja, das ist ein sehr starker Satz. Wir wollen sie hier auf der Höhe des Moments haben.
Ja, gerade im Kontakt mit den Jungen.
Denn nichts bringt die Generation weiter auseinander als das Medienverhalten.
Denn nichts bringt die Generation weiter auseinander als das Medienverhalten. Genau. Nicht nur über unterschiedliche Themen, sondern man konsumiert auch komplett unterschiedlich.
Man redet nicht nur über unterschiedliche Themen, sondern man konsumiert auch komplett unterschiedlich.
Ich habe das jetzt an mir wieder gemerkt. Ich habe eine Zeit abonniert, ich hatte ja davon gesprochen, dieses 9 € Ticket 9,9 Wochen.
Ich habe es jetzt an mir wieder gemerkt. Ich habe eine Zeit abonniert.
Ich hatte ja davon gesprochen, wie dieses 9 € Ticket 9,9 Wochen. Ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe es natürlich vergessen zu kündigen. Und dann kam die Rechnung über 300 € für ein Jahr Zeit Und ich habe mir genau und ich habe mir gedacht, warum nicht bei sich in den sauren Apfel.
1.600 € für ein Jahr. So funktioniert es nicht.
Weil sie in den sauren Apfel. Problem ist allerdings, wie ich feststellte.
Das Problem ist allerdings, wie ich feststellte, ich bin ein Zeit Print Abonnent.
Ich bin ein Zeit Print Abonnent. Wenn ich also auf zeit.de irgendwelche Texte hinter der Paywall finde, kann ich mich gar nicht als Abonnent irgendwo.
Wenn ich also auf Zeit.de irgendwelche Texte hinter der Paywall finde, kann ich mich gar nicht als Abonnent irgendwo zu erkennen geben.
Dann brauchst du wahrscheinlich ein Kombi Abo.
Irgend so was. Genau, ich bin jetzt wirklich nur ein Papier Abonnent. Also ich bin gefesselt ans Papier und die Website nützt mir so gar nichts. Das heißt, ich bin auch mal so richtig zurückgeworfen auf.
Heute ist Donnerstag, heute war sie wieder und es hat nicht geregnet.
Letzte Woche war sie komplett pitschnass, als ich sie dann Freitag rausholte.
Heute habe ich sie noch mal geschützt vor Wetter Einflüssen. Was man so alles macht. Die Medien noch mal vor Wetter Einflüssen schützen.
Gut, wir sind heute hier versammelt, um einen vollgepackten September zu besprechen.
Viele Sachen reißen wir tatsächlich nur an und wir haben uns am Anfang gedacht. Wir greifen mal diesen Running Gag auf, dass wir nämlich hier immer wieder subtil oder explizit aufrufen.
Das Buch über das Erbe Merkels muss mal geschrieben werden.
Wir sorgen gerne für Materialsammlung, aber es muss dann jemand mit Format mal schreiben. Wir haben ja auch diesen Monat ein Buch mit Leuten von Format, die uns ein Thema, das uns sehr am Herzen liegt, uns für den Salon hingelegt haben.
Und heute Morgen, just auf dem Weg aus dem Bett. An diesen Schreibtisch, habe ich Deutschlandfunk gehört.
Beziehungsweise es tauchte schon in den entsprechenden Chat Gruppen auf. Und dann habe ich es selber noch mal im Original gehört und habe gedacht Ja, jawoll, so, genauso muss man es machen.
Also wir hören Andreas Jung im Deutschlandfunk. Er ist der energiepolitische Sprecher der CDU Fraktion.
Was man so hat heute, um für Klamauk zu sorgen?
Genau. Es ist ja, man hat noch eine kleine Rollenverteilung. Genau.
Und man hat nicht nur alles auf Jens Spahn usw dazu gemünzt und wir hören einfach in dieses Gespräch rein, und zwar relativ früh.
Der Deutschlandfunk Journalist hat sich das gleich als erste Frage nach der Gesprächsführung rausgesucht und er fand das Angebot, was ihm gemacht wurde von Andreas Jung durch die erste,
Pseudo Antwort gut und hat deswegen gesagt okay, dann gehe ich jetzt all in und reagiere auf eine vorbereitete Antwort. Kennt man ja.
Politiker wollen erst mal ihren Talking Point unterbringen mit einer sehr vorbereiteten, sehr richtigen und durch Glück dann auch passenden Frage.
Das ist nun wirklich eine Posse, Herr Jung, da müssen wir jetzt mal einen Schritt zurückgehen. CDU und CSU und auch die SPD haben die völlig verfehlte Energiepolitik der vergangenen Jahrzehnte zu verantworten. Sie haben auch dafür gesorgt, dass die Bundeswehr nur bedingt einsatzbereit ist.
Wie viel Zeit räumen Sie der Ampel ein, um 16 Jahre Merkel zu reparieren?
Das ist zu schwarzweiß dargestellt, wie Sie es bitte.
Wie bitte? Gleich noch mal nachgehakt. Genau das ist auch nicht so schwarz weiß, sondern das ist einfach ganz schwarz dargestellt, so wie es sich gehört.
Wie bitte? Ja, genau so muss man es machen. Nein.
Ja. Ja. Wie soll es denn auch in Graubereiche gehen? Denn tatsächlich haben die ja regiert.
Man kann da nicht sagen. Nein, es war aber eigentlich ganz anders.
Aber das ist genau die richtige Art, wie man mit ihnen umgehen soll. Und sofort auch noch mal nachfragen und sich nichts bieten lassen.
Also ich kann das sehr empfehlen. Ich, ich meine, wir können uns wahr machen mit dem Gegenteil, wenn du möchtest.
Also wir können. Also das war jetzt vorbildlicher Journalismus.
Wir können. Ich habe es eigentlich für den Schluss aufgehoben, aber wir können uns schon ein bisschen in ein bisschen Bluthochdruck produzieren.
Es passt zum Thema Wie stellt man keine Fragen?
Ja, dann gehen wir Klotz in diesen Exkurs und folgen dann noch mal diesem Grunde zu den Clips. Nämlich Es gibt eine Sendung bei Funk, die heißt Kreuzverhör und Kreuzverhör.
Und zwar gehen wir da mal runter zu den Clips. Nämlich es gibt eine Sendung bei Funk, die heißt Kreuzverhör und Kreuzverhör.
Das klingt ja so, dass man da sich wirklich als Politiker ein bisschen fürchten muss.
Das klingt ja so, dass man da sich wirklich als Politiker ein bisschen fürchten muss. Was haben die jungen Journalisten davor?
Was haben diese jungen Journalisten davor?
Also eine Moderatorin, ein Moderator sitzen gegenüber.
Also ein Moderator. Da kommen wir dann noch zwei Journalisten gegenüber.
Es ist nur ein Politiker da. In diesem Falle Christian Lindner.
Ist es nur ein Politiker da, in diesem Falle Christian Lindner.
Und ich erspare uns einfach die Antworten von Christian Lindner, denn die können wir uns selbst auch im Kopf zusammen denken.
Oder ich erspare uns einfach die Antworten von Christian Lindner, denn die können wir uns selbst auch im Kopf zusammen denken. Und jetzt heißt diese Sendung Kreuzverhör. Und Funk ist ja ein Quell ewiger Inspiration und Freude für mich, wie alle wissen.
Und jetzt heißt diese Sendung Kreuzverhör. Und Funk ist ja ein Quell ewiger Inspiration und Freude für mich, wie alle wissen.
Und nun schauen wir mal an, wie die Sendung beginnt.
Und nun schauen wir mal, wie diese Sendung beginnt.
Hallo, Herr Lindner. Hallo. Herzlich willkommen. Hi. Ich freue mich. Vielen Dank. Wir freuen uns auch. Willkommen im Kreuzverhör.
Würde man so jemanden, den man ins Kreuzverhör nehmen möchte, begrüßen?
Würde man so,
das klingt so ganz gar nicht nach Kreuzfeuer. Aber gut.
Gar nicht. Ich habe jetzt einfach mal vier Fragen rausgenommen. Es gibt erst so zwei, drei kurze Fragen und dann noch mal eine etwas längere Frage Was sind denn jetzt diese Fragen, mit denen man Lindner mal so richtig bekommen kann?
Wie viele Stunden schlafen Sie gerade im Schnitt?
Oder auch.
In welchem Jahr wird denn jetzt wirklich der erste legale Joint verkauft?
Oder Stefan. Was uns alle umtreibt.
Wer wird dieses Jahr deutscher Fußballmeister?
Man muss der Fairness halber sagen, es ging dann auch noch um Inhaltliches, aber nie um Inhaltliches im Sinne von.
Was für eine Rolle spielt eigentlich gerade Christian Lindner in der EU als Austeritätspolitik Vertreter?
Und was bedeutet das für den europäischen Zusammenhalt? Nichts davon.
Es wurde zwar mal vom neuen Euro Tick. Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Und wie könnte das aussehen? Aber das sind alles Fragen, die so offen gestellt werden, dass natürlich ein Lindner darin nur baden kann und sagen kann Ich kann ihn versprechen, es wird und wir sind dabei. Und so weiter.
Es gab nicht eine einzige Frage, die ihn nur annähernd in die Bredouille brachte.
Und selbstverständlich lernen hier die Jungen auch schon von den Älteren.
Man will ja vielleicht auch irgendwann mal Anne Will beerben. Dann gibt es selbstverständlich auch diese Frage hier.
Thema Ukraine. Einfach. Wirklich? Kurze Antwort. Sollten wir jetzt direkt Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine liefern, wie auch Ihre Kollegin Marie Agnieszka Zimmermann fordert?
Das ist eine Frage, die man einem Finanzminister natürlich sofort stellen müsste.
Vor allem sollten wir jetzt nur mal kurz gefragt direkt Kampfpanzer schicken oder indirekt Drohnen oder was? Wie ist wie ist das gemeint? Diese Frage ist ja wirklich.
Sollten wir jetzt noch mal kurz gefragt direkt Kampfpanzer schicken oder indirekt drohen?
Ja. Ja.
Entsprechend fiel dann die Verabschiedung aus.
Herr Lindner, wir sind schon am Schluss angekommen. Ich hoffe, es ist alles okay. Bei mir ist alles okay. Das heute.
Da muss dann selbst Christian Lindner lachen. Alles okay? Also sag mal nein, wir haben dir wirklich nicht weh.
Da muss man selbst hin. Also, sag mal, nee, wir haben dir wirklich nicht weh getan. Ist übrigens meine Erfahrung.
Ist übrigens meine Erfahrung. Ich will da niemandem zu nahe treten, aber wenn man mit Fernseh Redaktionen zu tun hat und vorher telefoniert, bekommt man immer so Sachen gesagt wie Ja, wir wollen auch, dass du okay damit bist, dass du gefilmt wirst.
Ich werde niemandem zu nahe treten, aber wenn man mit ganze Redaktionen zu tun hat und vorher telefoniert.
Bekommt man immer so Sachen gesagt wie Ja, wir wollen auch, dass du okay damit bist, dass du gefilmt wirst. Und ich denke mir genau deswegen ich ja ins Fernsehen um nicht gefilmt.
Und ich denke mir, genau deswegen gehe ich ja wahrscheinlich ins Fernsehen, um nicht gefilmt zu werden.
Ja, ist auch ein sehr guter Monat, wo wir jetzt und wir reden später drüber feststellt, dass in Italien jetzt doch anders gewählt wurde. Und so weiter. Und auch für die Italiener so ein bisschen überraschend erste Mal so ein Ergebnis.
Und wir wissen ja eigentlich, das ist auch deutsche Finanzpolitik gewesen, die diese Achse Draghi Macron zerschlagen hat.
Wir hören nachher Ursula von der Leyen, wie sie das versucht, noch mal ein bisschen zu retten. Neue Verschuldung regeln, wirklich auch Maastricht in Frage stellt, alle EU Verträge neu schreiben möchte und zwar immer als Generation Verträge. Also völlig überraschendes Zeug.
Aber nichts davon schlägt sich hier nieder und Hauptsache Christian Lindner geht es noch gut. Er hat ja auch eine anstrengende Hochzeit hinter sich in der in Sicht. Das wirkt ja alles nach.
Wenig Schlaf. Donnerkeil!
Genau. Sehr guter Exkurs. Kommen wir zurück zu da, wo keine Journalisten hingeschaut haben, nämlich Freies for Future hat ja einen kleinen Aufschlag gemacht. Vor zwei Wochen in der Bundespressekonferenz. Natürlich nicht im großen Saal. Wo kämen wir da hin, wenn das noch eine Fernsehkamera anwesend wäre.
Und Sie haben sich Hilfe geholt bei Marcel Fratzscher, Um, finde ich im richtigen Moment mal die Frage zu stellen 100 Milliarden für Krieg? Warum nicht 100 Milliarden fürs Klima?
Und Fratzscher hat eine kleine Anmerkung gemacht, die wir auch noch mal unter diesem Tenor 16 Jahre Merkel Erbe Wer schreibt es auf?
Abheften in die Materialsammlung.
Denn er hat sich sehr bedankt für die Gelegenheit und auch die Freude, nicht nur als Wissenschaftler, sondern auch als Familien irgendwas und auch normaler Bürger und Mensch hier beisteuern zu können.
Also im Sinne von Scientists for Future. Das Engagement geht ja immer über die eigene Profession und Aufgabenstellung hinaus.
Und dann kam er aber gleich zurück auf seine volkswirtschaftlichen Analysen, die hier gefragt wurden, und hat sie politisch zurückgebunden.
Aber zweitens, und das glaube ich, realisieren viele nicht wir haben einen großen Fehler begangen, was den Klimaschutz betrifft.
Denn wenn wir vor zehn Jahren in Deutschland den Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien im Klimaschutz und andere Maßnahmen, energetische Gebäudesanierung,
schneller vorangebracht hätten, so wie es auch anfänglich geplant wäre, dann hätten wir heute bei weitem nicht eine so große soziale und wirtschaftliche Krise, wie wir haben.
Also sprich wenn heute Menschen in Schieflage sind, Probleme haben, nicht wissen, wie sie ihre Rechnung zahlen sollen,
weil Energiepreise durch die Decke schießen, weil 9 % Inflation da ist, weil Nahrungsmittel teurer werden, dann lässt sich das direkt auf die Fehler im Klimaschutz in den vergangenen 10 bis 20 Jahren zurückführen.
Und das gilt es erst einmal einzugestehen, dass man nicht nur geopolitisch den Fehler gemacht hat, sondern eben auch beim Klimaschutz. Und es gilt jetzt, diese Fehler zu korrigieren.
Wir haben heute nicht nur für die Menschen, für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger eine dramatische Situation, sondern auch für die Wirtschaft.
Viele Unternehmen können mit den hohen Energiepreisen über fossile Energieträger nicht umgehen, sind von Insolvenz und Überschuldung bedroht.
Und wir in Deutschland riskieren, dass wir, dass unser Wirtschaftsmodell wegbricht.
So sehr hat er Abschluss in diesem Ausschnitt, wie es uns droht, das Wirtschaftssystem wegzubrechen, was er heißt.
Wie es uns droht, das Wirtschaftssystem wegzubrechen, was er heißt.
Okay, da muss man wirklich noch mal die Grundzüge neu überdenken. Und so weiter. Und er hat diese Klammer aufgemacht.
Wir stehen heute schlecht da, was das zivilgesellschaftliche und private Leben in Deutschland betrifft.
Was die Unternehmer und das Unternehmertum betrifft und was unsere Erwartungen an Kann uns die Natur eigentlich noch länger versorgen oder haben wir da auch künftig?
Was die Unternehmer und das Unternehmertum betrifft und was unsere Erwartungen an das kann uns die Natur eigentlich noch länger versorgen? Oder haben wir da auch künftig? Laufen wir da eine Wende hinein und alles drei?
Laufen wir da ein Wende hinein und alles drei hätte man mit einer guten Klimapolitik auffangen können, weil man dann gleichzeitig so eine ökonomische Resilienz eben nicht mehr diese Abhängigkeit usw gehabt hätte.
Hätte man mit einer guten Klimapolitik aufhören können, weil man dann gleichzeitig so eine ökonomische Resilienz eben nicht mehr diese Abhängigkeit usw gehabt hätte, geopolitisch wie aber auch wirtschaftlich dann?
Auch richtig in allen Dimensionen. Genau. Und es ist im Grunde eine Win Win win Situation, die wir damals ausgeschlagen haben aufgrund partikulare Interessen, weil irgendwer meinte Nein, ich hab ein Atomkraftwerk und es bringt mir 300 Millionen im Monat.
Das habe ich. Ich habe keine Lust, das auszuschalten. So, und dann hat man da natürlich entsprechend einen Einfluss. Und dann bleibt das eben auch an, obwohl schon die politischen Entscheidungen eigentlich alle anders laufen. Und wir sehen ja, das zieht sich bis jetzt. Also Habeck hat wieder entschieden.
Wir haben im letzten Monat noch drüber gescherzt, dass er, also Habeck, die zwei Atom Betreiber da in diese Lage rein zwingt, ihr Atomkraftwerk in Betrieb zu halten, aber keine Gewinne mehr abzuschöpfen.
Und jetzt kriegen sie trotzdem ihre Gewinne weiter. Zumindest die zwei in Süddeutschland.
Auch weil die CSU da eine Energiepolitik gemacht hat, die halt einfach kein Weg dran vorbei führt. Aber und er sagte ja, jetzt müssen wir es machen. Fratzscher hat gesagt, jetzt sollten wir mal!
Der Zeitpunkt ist jetzt und wir haben ja häufiger diskutiert, Ja, es mangele ja nicht an Geld, wir könnten es ja einfach machen. Wir brauchen nur eine Neujustierung des Grundgesetzes in Sachen Schuldenbremse.
Kommen wir also zurück zu diesem Gespräch von heute Morgen.
Da war nämlich nicht nur der Knaller drin mit, dass der Deutschlandfunk Andreas Jung fragt Weil, Sie sind jetzt mit 16 Jahre Merkel.
Und wie viel Zeit räumen Sie denn der Regierung ein, ihre Fehler wettzumachen?
Sondern es ist auch ein endloses Gestammel zur Schuldenbremse. Mittlerweile ja. Also die Ideologie zerbröselt da auf allen Ecken. Deswegen hören wir uns uns gar nicht länger an, sondern nur dieses kleine Finale, was da noch stattfand.
Wir steigen also mit der Frage ein, wo der Journalist noch mal klugerweise drauf reagiert, zugehört hat, was gerade gesagt wurde und dann versucht, noch mal so ein bisschen Rest Intelligenz heraus zu schürfen aus Andreas Jungs Parteilinie.
Den ganzen Sommer drüber diskutieren. Das heißt für mich, dass sich, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ganz kurz, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe Die Union stellt jetzt vorsichtig die Schuldenbremse in Frage.
Nein, wir stellen nicht die Schuldenbremse in Frage.
Nein, ich habe darauf hingewiesen, dass die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz ist, ohne dass die Ausnahmeregelung der Schuldenbremse gezogen werden muss, so wie sie konzipiert ist, eine Konjunktur Komponente hat.
Wenn die Konjunktur gut ist, erlaubt sie keine oder wenig Schuldenaufnahme. Und wenn sie schwächelt, dann erlaubt sie ohne Ausnahme Modus.
Etwas mehr Schuldenaufnahme. Das könnten im nächsten Jahr 30 Milliarden € sein, ohne an die Schuldenbremse heranzugehen. Das kommt gar nicht in Frage, dass da irgendwas im Grundgesetz geändert wird, ohne dass die Ausnahmeregelung gezogen wird.
Die Einschätzung des Bundesfinanzministers, dass das nicht erforderlich ist, das zeigt sie ist klug konzipiert, So wie man sie gemeinsam ins Grundgesetz geschrieben hat. Ist nur die Frage, ob das dann auch hinhaut.
Soweit kommt es noch, dass wir da noch mal eingreifen ins Gesetz. Aber das wird ja noch. Und man, man sieht hier wirklich, dass sie noch mit aller Gewalt daran festhalten. Und ich bin gespannt.
Ich würde sagen, das ist auch noch nicht ausgemacht. Also nur weil eine Ideologie völlig hohl geworden ist, kann sie ja trotzdem noch wirksam sein.
Also wir haben jetzt die Situation, dass die Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau pro Jahr 60000000000 über Kredite locker macht.
Also wir haben jetzt die Situation, dass die Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau.
Pro Jahr 60000000000 über Kredite locker macht.
Die zum Ziele hat, Subventionen abzustützen und abzusichern oder direkt zu bezahlen.
Die im Bundestag als Politik entschieden worden, ohne dass das dann in die Schuldenbremse eingerechnet wird. Die machen ganz klare politische Programmatik im Bundestag entschieden, ohne dass in die Schuldenbremse Rechnung eingeht.
Die im Bundestag als Politik entschieden wurden, ohne dass das dann in die Schuldenbremse eingerechnet wird. Die machen ja ganz klare politische Programmatik im Bundestag entschieden, ohne dass in die Schuldenbremse recht reingeht.
Dann steht Scholz da und verkündet einfach 100 Milliarden, überrascht seine eigenen Regierungsparteien.
Dann steht Scholz da und verkündet ein paar 100 Milliarden, überrascht seine eigenen Regierungsparteien.
Wird alles in irgendwelche Schattenhaushalte versteckt? Schuldenbremse bleibt aber, wie gesagt, ja darum herum Sonderfonds.
Wird alles in irgendwelche Schattenhaushalte versteckt? Schuldenbremse bleibt.
Und weiter so! Future kommt und sagt Ja, dann können wir auch ein Sondervermögen 100 Milliarden machen fürs Klima.
Genau, die sagen dann auch den Weg. Also wenn ihr euch darauf geeinigt hat, dass das strukturell möglich ist, dann fordern wir nicht einfach nur Haltet mal Paris ein, was ja gar nicht unsere Forderung ist. Es ist ja eurer Völkerrechtlicher als Einverständnis, dass das nötig ist.
Und wir einigen uns sogar darauf, dass wir euren Weg gehen, über Sondervermögen und Schattenhaushalte so weiter ist zu organisieren.
Also eigentlich ein ganz großes Zugeständnis an die Regierenden, wenigstens deren Quatsch dann einfach im eigenen Anliegen mitzumachen.
Und dann haben wir hier.
Mit Christian Lindner. Der sagt Ja aber nichts, Halten wir die Schuldenbremse wieder ein. Dass selbst die CDU als Opposition.
Die für den ganzen Quatsch verantwortlich ist, dann noch mal dieses Zugeständnis macht.
Ja, wir bleiben bei der Schuldenbremse. Aber selbst wir gehen über Schattenhaushalt Konstruktion hinaus und argumentieren direkt mit der Schuldenbremsen Formulierung im Grundgesetz und finden da noch Lücken.
Aber die Schuldenbremse bleibt und das ist ein Gestammel um den heißen Brei herum, um statt einfach mal zu sagen Wir haben uns geirrt.
Es war ein großer historischer Fehler. Eigentlich bräuchten wir ein Fukushima Moment, das wir einfach feststellen.
Ist ja auch nicht von der. Es wird ja auch nicht von den Grünen gesagt.
Das ist ja schon interessant. Man wird es irgendwo in der Basis finden.
Aber eigentlich müsste Habeck sagen Die Schuldenbremse war der größte Fehler.
Wir müssen die Schuldenbremse jetzt loswerden, sonst können wir das vergessen mit unserem Wohlstand, mit dem, was uns im Winter droht, mit allem, was uns in den kommenden man muss es ja schon sagen Jahrzehnten droht.
Diese Akkumulation von Krisen. Es kommt ja noch weiteres sicherlich hinzu in all den Jahren.
Und eigentlich müsste es so formulieren Er tut es aber auch nicht, weshalb ich glaube, dass es auch bei den Grünen und ich habe es ja auch schon auf Podien erlebt mit Grünen, so wie mit mit Rebecca Harms oder so,
Es gibt tatsächlich auch da dieses schwäbische Hausfrau Denken.
Die Grünen sind sehr stark in Baden Württemberg und wir sehen das bei.
Der Staat Baden Württemberg. Ja, das ist ja der schlimmste von allen.
Ja, genau. Es ist ja nicht nur die schwäbische Hausfrau im Sinne von, sondern es ist ja tatsächlich diese Ideologie da, wo die Industrie so stark ist, wo man sagt Nein, man muss erst mal leisten und schaffen und so, und dann organisiert man das schon irgendwie.
Schwäbische Hausfrau im Sinne von sondern es ist ja tatsächlich diese Ideologie, die so stark ist. Man sagt, man muss erst mal leisten und schaffen und brauchte.
Dann sieht man es schon irgendwie. Der wollte doch hieß es nicht, dass der dann irgendwann aus dem Amt ausscheidet, Dass er nicht noch eine ganze Amtszeit macht? Ja.
Ist es nicht, dass der.
Kretschmann Ja, Cem Özdemir steht bereit, aber der ist jetzt auch erst mal Bauern Minister geworden.
Aber der will wahrscheinlich jetzt noch weitermachen. Also es gibt ja auch keine Rebellion gegen den.
Also es gibt ja auch keine Rebellion gegen den. Also, sagen wir es mal so ich.
Also ich es mal so ich. Es gibt sehr viele junge Menschen, die nach Baden Württemberg eingewandert sind, weil sie da tolle ökonomische Möglichkeiten finden, dies unmöglich können regiert werden.
Es gibt sehr viele junge Menschen, die nach Baden Württemberg eingewandert sind, weil sie da tolle ökonomische Möglichkeiten finden, die es unmöglich finden, wie sie dort regiert werden, gerade durch Corona hindurch und so, es war ja alles ganz schlimm. Und Winfried Kretschmann ist ja einer der allerersten, der immer gleich kommt mit Nein.
Gerade durch Corona hindurch. Also es war ja alles ganz schlimm. Und Winfried Kretschmann ist ja einer der allerersten, der immer gleich kommt. Mit Nein. Also.
Also bei Corona kein Eingeständnis.
Wir arbeiten hier gegen das Virus. Und so weiter. Genau dann diese ganze Waschlappen Sache. Also das. Wir individualisieren hier jedes Problem.
Vor allem die Kinder sollen jetzt mal ja die ganze Waschlappen Sache, dass wir individualisieren für jedes Problem Setzt die Maske auf und ist ein Waschlappen. Geh nicht duschen.
Setzt die Maske auf. Nutzt ein Waschlappen. Geh nicht duschen und so!
Also, da wird ja alles auf die Spitze getrieben.
So, da wird ja alles auf die Spitze getrieben. Die Grünen, Ich glaube, Habeck. Und so weiter.
Die Grünen. Ich glaube, Habeck. Und so weiter.
Die haben auch zu viel Eisen im Feuer. Und da sind zu viele Gespräche, die nach hinten losgehen, gerade vor Publikum.
Wir haben auch Eisen im Feuer und da sind zu viele Gespräche, die nach hinten losgehen, gerade vor Publikum.
Die hoffen vielleicht so ein bisschen drauf, dass die Moritz Höfken Und so weiter dieser Welt das alles noch ein bisschen torpedieren, Dass sie in so ein.
Die hoffen vielleicht ein bisschen darauf, dass die Morris Hopkins Und so weiter dieser Welt das alles noch ein bisschen torpedieren, dass sie in so einem.
Gemachtes fällt sozusagen einsteigen, um dann. Sie müssten mutig sein und es eigentlich machen.
Nein, aber ich glaube, das kann nicht funktionieren. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Das ist. Das ist viel zu spät. Und das machen Sie nicht. Und, na ja, Kretschmer ist ja wirklich.
Auf den darf man nicht hoffen.
Nein, da darf man überhaupt. Nein, das der überhaupt noch da ist, ist da eigentlich das große Wunder.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja. Es gibt aber auch alte Leute, die natürlich noch.
Es gibt aber auch alte Leute, die natürlich noch voll da sind bis zum Schluss nämlich Leute wie die Queen, die noch zwei Tage vor ihrem Tode des Petrus empfängt.
Voll da sind bis zum Schluss nämlich Leute wie die Queen.
Ja zwei Tage vor ihrem Tode etwas empfängt.
Dort stand mit Stock. Aber es ist erstaunlich, dass sie noch stand, also wie das alles noch möglich ist.
Dort stand mit Stock. Aber es ist erstaunlich, dass sie noch stand. Wie das alles noch möglich ist, ist wohl diese fiese.
Es ist wohl diese eiserne Disziplin, dass man auch sagt Ich bin nun mal die Königin und muss noch mal raus und mach es dann auch.
Und da schieben wir kurz ein. Die eiserne Disziplin also. Es ist jetzt Wolfgang Wolfgangs Bewunderung und Begeisterung, die dieses Thema hier noch mal rein hebt. Ich ich bin nicht schuld.
Die eiserne Disziplin. Also es ist jetzt Wolfgang Wolfgangs Bewunderung und Begeisterung.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nee, nee, nee, nee, so kommst du jetzt nicht raus, denn man muss den Leuten sagen, du hast im Fernseh Podcast über drei Stunden nur über die Queen geredet und ich dachte was ist da los?
Ich freue mich aber, dass wir über die ganze Zeit über drei Stunden nur über die Queen geredet.
Ja, ich dachte, was ist da los? Und deswegen. Die erste Frage geht an dich.
Und deswegen die erste Frage geht an dich, du Systemtheoretiker Stefan, bist du etwa ein Royalist?
Du Systemtheoretiker.
Bist du etwa ein Royalist? Also es gibt natürlich funktionale Argumentationen.
Denn alle? Ja.
Ich habe auch gleich eine vorbereitet.
Ja. Ja.
Wir müssen uns allerdings erst warm reden bei dem Thema. Ich habe gesehen, du hast viele Clips dabei.
Ich wollte nur kurz markieren, weil wir, als wir am Sonntag über die Queen sprachen, auch uns die Scherze erlaubt haben.
Als der Chat dann anfing zu fragen Wann hört denn das Queen Thema auf? Wann redet ihr denn über die richtigen Sachen im Fernsehen? Und dann sagten wir reden nur über die Queen und zwar aus vollem Herzen und völlig zu Recht.
Und war für mich im Grunde abgehakt. Aber nachdem du mir angekündigt, dass wir reden auch über die Queen, habe ich mir noch mal einen Punkt für nachher bereitgelegt. Eine Argumentation, die noch mal gemacht werden muss.
Aber ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was du jetzt von noch mal zum Thema mitbringst.
Wir steigen lustig ein mit einer Anekdote, die vor einer Weile schon der Leibwächter der Queen erzählte.
Normales Picknick. No, but I want to come to waltz the queen with Sue.
Hello anne used to Americans on a working holiday and I was clear from the moment, we for stop that,
the queen which is fine and the American gentleman and the queen where I come from going to next and the brain to Britain.
She come on where do you live,
live in London a holiday home just the other side of the hills and you be coming out here,
I b coming out of this little girls so over vaters and I see the clock thinking is a wall of you become up with where fighters you must to meet the queen.
Alles Cookies. A flash Jetzt will I have.
A coin watch you like and because I as with a long time and I can be very contact casual times, but you got a lovely sense of humor the next thing on you.
This is my shoulder und before the cat.
She is Cameron, give it the queen und just can you take a picture of you,
and you are we short places is not a picture with the queen of we never late on and we wave go boy and then I love to be a fly in the world when they shows as photograph to friends in America and hope fully some.
Wunderbar, oder? Und zeigt sehr schön, wie die Queen so tickte.
Ja, es sind wie die in So tickte also dann auch amerikanische Touristen.
Dann auf amerikanische Touristen zu treffen, die sie nicht erkennen. Sie eine große Freude dabei hat. Und dann.
Für gewöhnlich erkennen sie eine große Freude dabei. Und dann?
Entspinnt sich dieses wunderbare Schauspiel. Es sind. Unendlich viele Geschichten, die jetzt nicht mehr erzählt werden können von ihr. Sir Churchill, verabschiedet mit John F.
Entspinnt sich dieses wunderbare Schauspiel. Unendlich viele Geschichten, die erzählt werden können von ihr.
Der Churchill, verabschiedet mit John F. Kennedy gefeiert und.
Kennedy gefeiert und danach auch noch 50, 60 oder 70 Jahre weitergemacht.
Danach auch noch 506070 Arbeiten macht. Ja, und sie hat nie in ihrem Leben ein Interview gegeben.
Und sie hat nie in ihrem Leben ein Interview gegeben, keine Bücher geschrieben, nichts.
Keine Bücher geschrieben. Nichts. Das heißt, wir leben jetzt.
Das heißt, wir leben jetzt von solchen Geschichten und müssen einfach sagen Sie waren also das ist einfach eine ganz besondere Konstellation von Amt und Person. Und so weiter.
Von solchen Geschichten und müssen dazu sagen, wie sie waren.
Das ist einfach eine ganz besondere Konstellation von Amt und Person. Und so weiter.
Und es ist ein unendlicher Fundus, sich hier auch noch einfach zu amüsieren über solche Sachen.
Und es ist ein unendlicher Fundus, sich hier auch noch einfach zu amüsieren.
Ja, es ist auch schön, welche Videos man dann so bei YouTube sehen kann.
Ich habe mich ja dann auch dabei ertappt, dass ich dann noch mal schaue, wie war das, als Papst Benedikt zu Besuch bei der Queen war und sie dann sagt Oh that was a tiny car?
Weil sie dann doch etwas verwundert ist, mit welchem Auto er dann da ankommt.
Also es ist einfach wunderbar, sich das anzusehen.
Und ja, es ist aber auch das große Mysterium, dass man über sie nicht in dem Sinne etwas weiß, dass man sagt Ach ja, genau, jetzt haben wir ja jetzt was Privates mal wirklich erfahren. Und das hat mich natürlich immer so fasziniert an der Queen.
Das ist ja ähnlich wie bei Lagerfeld. Also man kann, glaube ich, diese beiden Personen sehr gut parallel betrachten.
Das ist übrigens das auch, was dieser wunderbare Film mit Helen Mirren in der Hauptrolle, der einfach nur die Queen heißt, so wunderbar eingefangen hat.
Denn es ist ein Film, der von den schwierigen Jahren handelt.
Bzw. Von den schwierigen Wochen. Dann ganz speziell mit,
Dianas Tod, wo die Queen in irgendeiner Weise reagieren muss, sich menschlich zeigen muss, zugleich aber auch das Protokoll nicht verletzen darf und wie man da versucht einen Weg zu finden.
Und ich bin ja nun alles andere als ein Monarchist, sondern bin natürlich als Linker dafür, dass so etwas abgeschafft wird und dass auch Menschen so was nicht brauchen sollten.
Wir kommen aber dazu gleich noch, was man braucht und nicht so, aber man kann ja auch einfach es als Phänomen zunächst einmal wahrnehmen, schätzen.
Und diese Form Strenge, die sie in all das reingebracht hat, ist etwas, was mich zutiefst beeindruckt.
Schon deshalb, weil man hier sehen kann, dass sich jemand ganz zurücknimmt.
Und du hast da einen Clip gehabt im Podcast, den wir noch mal abspielen müssen, nämlich von Christopher Clark, der sagte, dass das eigentlich das Besondere war, dass die Queen sich nicht in den Mittelpunkt gerückt hat.
Darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem Historiker Christopher Clark, Professor an der Universität Cambridge und auch hier in Deutschland bestens bekannt unter anderem durch sein Buch Die Schlafwandler über den Beginn des Ersten Weltkriegs. Guten Abend, Herr Clark.
Guten Abend. Elisabeth wurde ja 1926 in der Zwischenkriegszeit geboren und war insofern eine Königin, die von Kindheit an in einer erschütterten Welt lebt. Aber sie selbst wirkte immer vollkommen unerschütterlich.
Ist es das, womit diese Monarchin der Nation immer Halt gab?
Absolut. Also Sie, die die Königin, hat mit einer unglaublichen Stetigkeit regiert.
Überall um sie herum gab es Menschen, die wie eben Menschen so sind, sich Verfehlungen zu leisten meinten.
Es gab Ehe, Trennungen, es gab Skandale und was weiß ich. Das Normale halt, was, was Menschen, was auch auf die Menschen zukommt.
Aber sie blieb immer stets ganz, ganz fest in ihrer Rolle.
Und spielte sie noch mit einer unglaublichen Treue. Es ist interessant, wenn man sich.
Wenn man. Man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass Großbritannien keine geschriebene Verfassung hat. Das ist eine konstitutionelle Monarchie ohne Constitution.
Und in dieser Situation war sie sozusagen die Verkörperung dieser an sich nicht existenten Konstitution.
Und diese Rolle hat sie mit einer mit einem exquisiten Gefühl für die Grenzen der Rolle gespielt. Sie hat sich nie persönlich geäußert zu politischen Themen.
Sie hat, könnte man sagen, gänzlich im öffentlichen Leben auf ein Ich verzichtet.
Also sie war nicht da, um sich selbst zu realisieren oder zu erfüllen, sondern um das Amt vorzuspielen.
Und das ist für mich überhaupt der wichtigste Clip zum Thema Queen. Also ich habe auch viel geguckt, aber das ist wirklich das Allerwichtigste, was er sagt.
Zwei Dinge will ich hier herausgreifen Sie hat diese Rolle mit einer unheimlichen Treue gespielt.
Man muss also hier das Spiel auch mit zehn Wir werden gleich noch einen Aspekt über Rituale bekommen, wo das Theaterspielen wieder eine Rolle spielt.
Sie hat die Rolle gespielt und als eine solch ein solches Spiel muss man das Ganze auch verstehen.
Und das Zweite und das macht es auch für uns so faszinierend, uns das anzusehen.
Man kann sagen, Heute gehe ich nicht ins Theater, heute gucke ich die Beerdigung der Queen.
In dieser Weise hast du das ja rezipiert, Auch dann denke ich.
Und dann gibt es noch diesen zweiten Aspekt, dass sie ihr Ich in der Öffentlichkeit nicht gezeigt hat, dass sie das hat zum Verschwinden bringen lassen und hat diese Rolle nur in den Vordergrund gestellt.
Und was wir heute unglaublich lieben, ist ja diesen Ich Kult, den haben wir nicht nur bei den Führungspersonen, den haben wir bei den Politikern, die die Homestorys machen. Jetzt war doch auch schon wieder im Spiegel irgendwas.
Drei Die drei jungen grünen Abgeordnete wie haben sie in Ihrer WG besucht?
Und dann erzählen Sie private irgendetwas. Und es gibt eine wunderbare Medien Satire.
Vielleicht kennst du die aus den Achtzigern? Schtonk! Über die Fälschung der Hitler Tagebücher mit Götz George und Harald Juhnke. Und dann steht da ja ganz viel banales Zeug drin.
Eva Braun sagt Ich habe Mundgeruch und so was. Und genau, Und dann und dann sind diese Journalisten dort alle so begeistert wie authentisch.
Ja, also da schlägt ja auch. Also selbst beim Führer schlug ein richtiges Herz.
Also in dieser Weise wird das dann rezipiert und das ist genau das Falsche.
Und die Queen mahnte uns eigentlich mit ihrer Präsenz, mit der reinen Repräsentanz könnte man auch sagen immer daran, dass wir hier das Amt betrachten sollen. Und das imponiert mir so sehr.
Wir haben diese ganze interessante Klammer. Das war ja auch interessant, sich sowohl die BBC als auch die deutschen Nachrichten dazu anzuschauen, dass wir die ganze Zeit nur eine Berichterstattung darüber hatten.
Wie haben sich die Leute gefühlt, wie haben sie gemeinsam getrauert? Wie viele Blumen wurden mitgebracht? Also dieses ganz persönliche.
Jeder Korrespondent sollte sich dazu verhalten, dass es dieses Ereignis jetzt gibt, das so vorhersehbar war.
Die war sechs Jahre alt und so und gleichzeitig als Subjekt der Berichterstattung oder eigentlich dann wirklich Objekt der Berichterstattung war es aber eben diese nicht Person, sondern nur dieses Amt und dieses Schauspiel und diese,
dieser Schmuck die ganze Zeit, der sich ja auch durch diese zehn Tage Ritual einfach zog.
Also das Protokoll wurde er eingehalten bis aufs letzte. Und selbst David Beckham stand natürlich 20 Stunden in der Schlange, um die Queen zu sehen und alle haben die Formalitäten da eingehalten und,
haben das Programm damit gefüllt, genau das Gegenteil zu machen, sich die ganze Zeit nach vorne zu stellen und über ihre Gefühle zu reden.
Und ach, es war ja so bewegend, hier zu sein. Und dann hat man sich noch so gefreut, weil am Beerdigung Tag dann auch noch dieser Regenbogen über London und so und das war eine interessante Klammer.
Ja, Ja, ja.
Nun habe ich ein Feature gefunden, das ein paar Jahre alt ist, nämlich Das wurde vom Deutschlandfunk veröffentlicht zur Hochzeit von Harry und Meghan. Und wir hören da erst mal einen Ausschnitt.
Meghan Markle ist der Star dieser Hochzeit. Schon bei ihren ersten Auftritten an der Seite von Harry fliegen ihr die Herzen in allen Teilen des Landes zu.
Harry, fielen ihr die Herzen in.
Die Menschen stehen zu Hunderten an den Absperrungen und rufen Harry, geh mal zur Seite, Wir wollen Meghan sehen.
Mal zur Seite. Wir wollen Mädels.
Die Briten, von denen man sagt, sie zeigten Gefühle nur bei Hunden und Pferden.
Sie haben ihr Herz für Megan entdeckt.
Das hat sich inzwischen gedreht. Also auch interessant, wie schnell man in der Gunst des Publikums, kann man vielleicht am besten sagen sofort sinken kann, wenn es irgendwelche Skandale gibt.
Bzw spaltet sich ja die Haltung zu Meghan nicht nur in England, sondern generell.
Die einen finden sie ganz furchtbar, sie reiße das Königshaus in ins Verderben, die anderen sagen großartig. Sie spricht über ihre Gefühle und dann auch noch bei Oprah Winfrey.
Vermissen ja Leute, die mit Oprah Winfrey sprechen, generell nicht ernst zu nehmen. Aber sie macht natürlich mit Harry zusammen und diesen Dokus und was sie da alles vermarkten und ausschlachten. Exakt das Gegenteil der Queen.
Und deswegen bin ich natürlich auch, wie schon zu Zeiten von Diana auf Seiten der Queen.
Er könnte aber dadurch, dass man sich vielleicht nicht erwehren kann, dass wir jetzt in dieses Instagram Zeitalter kommen, diese dann doch notwendige Modernisierung sein für das Zeitalter nach der Queen, also nach Elizabeth.
Die erklären kann, dass wir jetzt in dieses Zeitalter kommen. Diese dann doch notwendige Modernisierung sein danach.
Ich glaube aber, dass das dann nicht mehr funktioniert. Ich glaube, dass das wenn.
Na, mal sehen. Wenn die Mutter nicht mehr da ist, dann kann das ganze nicht laufen.
Wenn die Aura nicht mehr da ist, dann kann das Ganze nicht laufen.
Ich will jetzt hier gleich als Klammer einfügen. Ja, ich weiß um den britischen Kolonialismus und ich weiß auch, dass die Queen keine besonders rühmliche Rolle gespielt hat bei den Entschuldigungen, die man hätte leisten können.
Ich will jetzt hier gleich als Klammer einfügen. Ja, ich weiß um den britischen Kolonialismus. Und ich weiß auch, dass die Queen keine besonders rühmliche Rolle gespielt hat bei den Entschuldigungen, die man hätte leisten können.
Das waren alles Dinge, die jetzt auch wieder diskutiert wurden.
Das waren alles Dinge, die jetzt auch wieder diskutiert wurden. Und ich finde auch, dass sie zu Recht diskutiert werden können.
Und ich finde auch, dass sie zu Recht diskutiert werden können. Wenn da manche von Pietätlosigkeit sprechen, dann denke ich mir Na ja, gut, das ist ja jetzt nicht gerade, dass man über die eigene Oma spricht.
Denn wenn manche von Pietätlosigkeit sprechen, dann denke ich mir Na ja, gut, das ist ja jetzt nicht gerade, dass man über die eigene Oma spricht. Das ist gut.
Das ist ja eine Figur des öffentlichen Lebens. Also so muss man es machen, sonst braucht man das ja alles gar nicht.
So muss man es machen, sonst braucht man das ja alles. Sie ist ja auch trotz allem eine politische Figur.
Genau. Es ist. Wo? Wo? Worüber reden wir also hier? Das sehe ich natürlich. Alles will ich aber jetzt nicht hier nochmal eigens thematisieren.
Vielmehr geht es jetzt mal um das Ökonomische. Das ist auch aus diesem Deutschlandfunk Beitrag von ein paar Jahren.
Was bringen eigentlich die Royals so ein?
50 Millionen £ Einnahmen erwarten allein die Souvenir Händler des Vereinigten Königreiches aus der royalen Hochzeit.
Insgesamt, so haben es die Experten des Marketing Unternehmens Brent Finance ausgerechnet, ist das ganze Ereignis rund 1 Milliarde £ wert.
1 Milliarde.
Die königliche Familie sei ein prächtiges Treibmittel für die britische Wirtschaft, sagt Richard Hague, Geschäftsführer von Brand Finance, das 400 Millionen UK.
Nach unseren Berechnungen bringt die Monarchie dem britischen Tourismus rund 500 Millionen £ pro Jahr.
Also allein 500 Millionen £, weil die da eine Queen haben. Klar, man braucht Sehenswürdigkeiten. Nicht alle haben einen Eiffelturm.
Also ist dann vielleicht die Queen auch was, was man sich ansieht oder die Paraden und was dort alles geboten wird.
Dann gibt es natürlich die Kritiker der Royals.
80 Millionen £ gehen in diesem Jahr direkt an die Mitglieder der Königsfamilie.
Darin enthalten ist ein dicker Zusatz Batzen für die Renovierung des Buckingham Palastes.
Erwirtschaftet wird dieses Geld mit dem Besitz der Krone.
Er reicht von ertragreichen Landgüter bis hin zu teuren Einkaufsstraßen.
Dass das Königshaus angeblich jeden Staatsbürger nur 4,70 £ pro Jahr koste, wie dies die Freunde der Monarchie so gern vorrechnen, stimme nicht, sagt Graham Smith.
Nicht nur, dass das sowieso alles Steuerzahlergeld sei. Vielmehr seien in den Offiziellen 80 Millionen teure Posten wie die Sicherheit oder die Nutzung von Gebäuden gar nicht berücksichtigt.
Über 300 Millionen. Die wirkliche Zahl liegt weit über 300 Millionen £.
Gut 80 Millionen bekommen die direkt. Und dann natürlich diese Renovierung.
Da kann man aber auch sagen, die würden ja die Schlösser nicht verfallen lassen, wenn die royale Familie jetzt nicht mehr da wäre wie bei Hape Kerkeling, da müssen die ja fliehen.
Es gibt ja diesen Hape Kerkeling Film. Kennst du den?
Wo die Royals bei dann in den Ruhrpott kommen, weil sie in England nicht mehr geduldet werden? Ganz amüsant.
Nein, die würden ja auch gepflegt werden. Und ich würde mal sagen, ich will die Royals nicht in dem Sinne verteidigen für das, was sie stehen und repräsentieren. Und so weiter.
Aber jetzt mal rein ökonomisch betrachtet Wenn die,
500 Millionen allein der Tourismusindustrie zuspielen plus die ganzen anderen plus Übertragungsrechte und was es da alles gibt und Merchandise weltweit,
dann würde ich doch sagen, mit 80 Millionen £ sind die ein bisschen unterbezahlt, oder?
Also ökonomisch gesehen muss man sagen in dieser Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, in der wir leben, sind das wirklich die Proto influencer.
Ökonomisch gesehen muss man sagen in dieser Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie.
Ja, im Leben sind das wirklich die Brutto Influencer, die einen volkswirtschaftlichen Zugzwang haben.
Die einen volkswirtschaftlichen Zugzwang haben, der es lächerlich macht, überhaupt darüber zu diskutieren, dass sie angeblich Geld kosten, weil das nicht der Fall ist?
Der ist lächerlich aufgrund dessen, dass sie angeblich Geld sind.
Also da würde eine Kim Kardashian sagen Dafür stehe ich morgens nicht auf.
Ja, genau. Also es ist einfach. Es ist absurd, diese Diskussion überhaupt so zu führen. Das ist. Hier ist wirklich was in Bewegung und so!
Es ist absurd, diese Diskussion überhaupt so zu führen.
Ja, wir bleiben aber beim Ökonomischen und hören rein in den Podcast von Adam Tod.
Monsanto ist auch da war die Queen Thema.
Sechstens to other strange counts of aspekts of royal ownership overcome across Britain swans for example,
are und by the more work or there is a Klassifikation of royal fish Wales Dolphin sturgeon are all und by the monarch es.
Die Schwäne gehören der Queen oder jetzt dann dem König.
Und das ist für mich ganz interessant, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Also was heißt das eigentlich, die gehören dem Adam Tod? Führt das jetzt aus?
Crazy is the sound of course. Once upon a time resistance in any really serious.
I have you really big bang with the swan,
good to meet and they were read and so the king's being the king's all swans in the country belong to us when we the more of the United Kingdom on all of the swans of by now,
2000 say no longer is,
protected say we don't need the money,
that no one else.
Here I think because this is ownership, but it's not in the sense of it being a commodity.
I have a right to things you not free the do with it.
What you want it there's no we know what the end of the impression that king of all of the world.
Es ist Ownership, aber es ist nicht Commodity. Also es ist keine Ware und.
An wen sollte man die alle verkaufen?
Und das hat. Man könnte natürlich da auch noch ein Geschäft, was man.
Aber es ist keine Ware und man darf keinen Schwan töten, dann gibt es ordentlich Ärger.
Und das hat mich natürlich auf eine Idee gebracht. Wir haben ja einen Bundespräsidenten, der unser Queen Ersatz ist und da würden wir ja beide sagen, das haut uns jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig um, da würdest du nicht Stunden vor dem Fernseher hängen, wenn da irgendwas wäre.
Eher nicht. Und das liegt ja auch daran, dass man nicht so recht weiß, was soll man eigentlich mit diesem Amt?
Vielleicht könnten wir dieses Amt doch mal aufwerten, dadurch, dass wir auch so eine ownership, aber nicht Commodity Sache daraus machen.
Also könnten wir nicht Sachen sagen bei Dingen, die wir auf keinen Fall privatisieren wollen, die nicht Commodity werden sollen, wie zum Beispiel Autobahnen wie zum Beispiel Trinkwasser, wie zum Beispiel Stadtparks und was weiß ich, dass man sagt.
Die gehören dem Bundespräsidenten, aber der kann kein Commodity, keine Ware daraus machen.
Also damit könnte man das Amt noch mal gut aufwerten und würde eine sehr interessante Enteignung Debatte von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge führen.
Also man würde den Bundespräsidenten zu so einem Teil habenden Geschäftsführer der Deutschland AG machen, der dann einfach für die Zeit im Amt die Verantwortung hat, dass das bleibt ja nicht schlecht ins Grundgesetz damit.
Also man würde den Bundespräsidenten zu so einem Teil habenden Geschäftsführer der Deutschland AG machen. Ja, aber für die Zeit im Amt.
Dass das keine Ware wird. Das das bleibt im Grundgesetz, ins Grundgesetz. Genau. Und dann können wir immer wieder sagen Nee, also im Grundgesetz steht also, dass, da kommen wir ja jetzt ja nicht hin, dass wir das noch mal ändern.
Bei Hart aber fair, was ich sonst nie sehe. Aber ich habe es mir hier mal angesehen in ich glaube zehnfacher Geschwindigkeit, um es auszuhalten, dass da war also auch alles um die Queen zu Gast.
Unter anderem war James Horse, der Autor ist und sich mit der Monarchie auskennt. Und so weiter.
Und der kommt jetzt auf diese Rituale zu sprechen, die du ja auch schon mit Begeisterung rezipiert hast. Und ihm gegenüber steht Sascha Lobo, der gar nicht einverstanden ist.
Wir hören jetzt erst mal James Horse reden.
Freunde interessiert ist die angebliche Tradition, die heute so wunderbar dargestellt wurde.
Meine Mutter ist da, es wurde 1939 geboren. Diese ganzen Traditionen, die hier dargestellt wurden, sind erst beim Tod von Queen Queen Victoria aus dem Nichts heraus ergriffen. Warum ausgerechnet da?
Man hatte keine Tradition, sie hatte ja so lange regiert. Man wusste gar nicht, was machen, wenn ein König erstarrt. Und das war ein Theaterregisseur mehr oder weniger das alles erfunden hat. 30 Jahr vor dem Geburt. Meine Mutter, das ist keine uralte Tradition. Es ist nicht mal so alt wie die Gedächtniskirche zu Berlin.
Und das ist alles. Das waren Traditionen. Sie enttäuschen also mich. Ich hatte gedacht, es wäre tatsächlich alles. Mindestens zwei Jahrhunderte, die nur beim Tod des Monats und hören das, wo alles vor Queen Victoria, ihr Sohn erfunden aus dem Enttäuschen.
Also ich finde, Rituale müssen nicht immer historisch begründet werden, um ihren Wert und ihren Gehalt zu haben. Es reichen auch funktionale Gründe.
Das kennt jeder aus therapeutischen Zusammenhängen. Wenn man versucht, bei manchen Menschen oder auch in der Erziehung so ein paar Routinen mal zu etablieren.
Wenn man dann immer kommt mit na ja, das sollten wir aber eigentlich schon immer so gemacht haben, ansonsten können wir das nicht erklären. Ist das ein falscher Ansatz und.
Und wann ist denn schon für immer? Wenn man er sagt, dann Ach, ich dachte, die waren 400 Jahre alt.
Aber wo ist jetzt der Unterschied, ob die 80 Jahre alt sind oder 400 Jahre alt sind?
Es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass man immer, wenn es so lange zurückliegt, dass man nicht mehr direkt jemanden befragen kann, hier, das ist jetzt so schockierend für ihn, weil er sagt Ja, meine Mutter, die hat das ja noch so und so erlebt, da war das noch nicht, da haben die sich das ausgedacht, das war von einem Theaterregisseur entwickelt.
Also hier noch mal dieses Rollenspiel, auf das Clark auch angespielt hat, Das noch mal in den Vordergrund zu stellen, aber zu sagen, die sind damals erfunden worden.
Ja, und das ist ja gerade das Tolle an der menschlichen Zivilisation, sich so etwas auszudenken, weil man sich überlegt wie geben wir einer Sache eine Form?
Und das ist ja eine Frage, die sich grundsätzlich stellt, zum Beispiel wenn jemand stirbt.
Also es gibt wohl kaum Fälle, wo man einfach nur sagen verscharrt in, sondern man hat, auch wenn man längst aus der Kirche ausgetreten ist oder so noch den freien Redner oder da kommt jemand und spielt das Lieblingslied und all das.
Paare, die sich ja auch irgendwann treffen, kennenlernen, entwickeln meist gemeinsam Rituale, haben ein Lied, das sie verbindet, ein Restaurant, das sie immer wieder aufsuchen.
Also solche Ritualisierung sind eine sehr menschliche Eigenschaft, aber sie müssen nicht zurückreichen auf die Antike oder so was.
Vor allem der Anspruch. Es muss aber historisch begründet sein.
Wir haben ja auch extreme Bedeutungs schwankungen selbst bei Monarchien und Königshäusern.
Also Saudiarabien gilt heute als Monarchie.
Die haben das auch einfach nur erfunden vor so ein paar Jahrzehnten und erklären sich einfach dazu.
Und wenn er jetzt hier sagt, na ja, das wurde dann für König, für Königin Victoria, ja, Königin Victoria hat halt eben aus.
Ich will es nicht übertreiben, aber fast nichts. So ein Weltreich noch mal geschaffen.
Und klar wird man dann anders beerdigt als die vor allem Könige, die jetzt nicht so eine mega Geschichte sind. Vor allem die Königinnen, dass man das dann noch mal anders macht.
Und es war ja auch für mich eine große Frage jetzt, wenn wir jetzt feststellen okay, Königin Victoria, verdient der so ein großes Begräbnis, weil sie wirklich da in so einem Aufbau der weltweiten Bedeutung der englischen Krone. Und so weiter.
Jetzt haben wir Königin Elizabeth, die feststellte In meiner Amtszeit wurde so ganz schön viel zurückgebaut, aber gleichzeitig diese mediale Bedeutung so aufgebaut.
Also klar kriegt sie so eine Beerdigung, wie sie jetzt gekriegt hat.
Klar wird es da zehn Tage lang gemacht und alles fernseh tauglich und.
Es schwingen da viele Fragen noch mit im Raum, die man sich mal anschauen muss, wie zum Beispiel auch King Charles.
Er hat sich jetzt voll ins Erbe seiner Mutter gestellt. Also er hat gar keinen neuen, sozusagen Amtseid, sondern er hat in seiner ersten Rede, wo er hätte alles sagen können, betont.
Ich erinnere noch mal, wie meine Mutter ins Amt gekommen ist oder sogar vorher sich auf die Krone verpflichtet habe, bevor sie dann,
paar Jahre später erfahren hat, dass sie selber jetzt ihre, also die Pflicht, die sie der Kirche der Krone auferlegt, dann selber gewahr werden muss und entsprechen muss.
Und er hat dann gar nicht inhaltlich das erneuert, sondern nur gesagt Ich erneuere ihren Eid, den sie damals der Bevölkerung gegeben hat.
Warum nutzt er jetzt nicht die Gelegenheit, noch mal was Neues zu begründen? Aber man versteht natürlich sofort das war auch Thomas Einwand, dass es natürlich darum geht, das Erbe der Queen schon allein wegen diesem ganzen Merchandise.
Also ein Charles Ding wird man jetzt nicht 500 Millionen £ fach verkaufen oder so, sondern es wird immer noch die Queen und auch ihr Antlitz und ihre Würde, die in diesen ganzen Fotografien drin steckt.
Und so muss man halt jetzt auch nochmal aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht aufrechterhalten. Und all solche Fragen spielen da rein.
Und dieses Jahr ist, weil wir sagen, es ist König, muss es alt sein. Und deswegen muss aus der Tradition heraus ein Ritual begründet werden.
Nein, da gibt es funktionale Erwägungen. Wir kommen ja gleich noch mal kurz drauf zu sprechen.
Auch hier die Parallele vielleicht zu Lagerfeld noch mal?
Die Marke Chanel hat ja jetzt auch eine neue Chefdesigner. Und wahrscheinlich können die meisten sie gar nicht beim Namen nennen.
Sie wurde von Lagerfeld dort eingeführt und sie ist dann auch übernommen worden.
Aber natürlich versucht man jetzt erst mal noch ein bisschen diesen Lagerfeld Geist, auch wenn man keine Kollektionen mehr von ihm hat, wach zu halten.
Man kann nicht gleich Tabula rasa machen und sagen hier ist ein 25-jähriger hipper Designer und der macht das jetzt ganz anders, sondern man muss jetzt mal versuchen, noch diese Chanel Marke, die so aufgeladen wurde von Lagerfeld in dieser Weise eine Weile zu halten.
Und dann muss man sich sicherlich umorientieren.
Bei der britischen Monarchie wird das wahrscheinlich dann die Aufgabe von William werden, der dann da eigene Akzente reinlegen muss.
Wir bleiben noch mal kurz bei den Ritualen, denn es gibt ja auch das Ritual, dass die Bienen über den Tod der Queen informiert werden müssen.
Und es gibt ja auch wirklich lustige Elemente. Ich habe mir das angeschaut. Es ist eine völlig absurde Tradition, dass zum Beispiel der königliche Imker die Pflicht hat, die Bienen der Königin über den Tod Ihrer Majestät zu informieren. Ganz schlicht.
Und dann wurde eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass er das in gesetztem Ton getan habe. Schauen Sie mal nach rechts auf den Bildschirm.
Da wird heftig im Kopf geschüttelt.
Ich bin selber Imker, ich kenne viele Imker und ich weiß noch aus meiner Kindheit im Allgäu. Wenn da ein Bauer gestorben ist, der Bienen hatte, dann ist sein Sohn an den Bienenstock gegangen und hat den Bienen gesagt Pass auf, der Bauer ist tot, jetzt bin ich der Bauer.
Das macht jetzt aber diese königliche Tradition nicht weniger lächerlich. Da werden Sie mir recht geben, oder?
Nein, ich finde das. Warum ist eine Tradition lächerlich? Nur weil sie die Königin nicht reden kann. Sie sagen Leute, aufmachen.
Imker haben eine besondere Beziehung zu ihren Bienen.
Also, dass Rituale für diejenigen sind, die, die die Rituale durchspielen und nicht für die, die zuschauen.
Es ist ja nun keine neue Erkenntnis für alle Beteiligten oder auch das nicht versteht. Dann hatten wir mal fragen, was wir können, wenn wir vortragen.
Ich finde das wirklich erstaunlich, dass Sascha Lobo überhaupt das nicht versteht. Dann müssen wir mal fragen was?
Wir können dann sofort sagen Reißt alle Synagogen, Kirchen und Moscheen ab, denn das ist wirklich lächerlich, Das können wir sofort machen.
Reißt alle Synagogen, Kirchen und Moscheen ab, denn das ist wirklich lächerlich. Genau.
Wir können auch sagen Warum verhalten sich Leute bei Hip Hop Konzerten so? Also warum springen die da?
Setzt euch doch hin und hört der Musik zu.
Wir können ganz, ganz viele Beispiele nehmen, wo man sagt Ja, ein Ritual ist ja gerade das, was das also ein Wir.
Wir spielen hier mit Symbolen, wir spielen mit Repräsentanz, wir laden dies auf mit einer Bedeutung.
Genau dies macht uns eigentlich zu Menschen, dass wir dazu in der Lage sind. Tiere haben keine Rituale, Tiere haben keine Statuen, vor denen sie salutieren oder irgendetwas. Tiere haben nur Instinkte.
Tiere machen Dinge irgendwie immer gleich, vielleicht, weil sie den Instinkt dazu haben. Aber man hat noch nie irgendwo gesehen, dass Hunde anderen Hunden einen Schrein aufbauen oder irgendetwas machen.
Und gerade weil wir Menschen sind, machen wir dies und das ist eigentlich eine sehr, sehr intelligente Form, auch zum Beispiel mit der eigenen Sterblichkeit umzugehen.
Mit all diesen großen Fragen, die wir dann doch auch nicht beantworten können, ist das eine Weise, damit umzugehen. Und das zeigt sich dann jetzt sehr prunkvoll beim Beispiel der Queen.
Aber eigentlich können wir das als eine Einladung betrachten, um um über unsere eigenen Rituale nachzudenken und auch zu fragen Wo fehlen vielleicht gewisse Rituale inzwischen?
Denn vielleicht haben die Kirchen auch so wenig Zulauf, weil sie natürlich sehr stark auf das Ritual verzichtet haben. Sie wollten den Konventionen Abbruch, auch aus guten Gründen zum Teil.
Also gerade bei der katholischen Kirche mit dem Zweiten Vatikanischen Konzil. Und inzwischen ist aber alles so happy creepy, dass man gar nicht mehr weiß, wo bin ich hier eigentlich gerade? Ach so, es ist eigentlich eine Kirche, dass man schon irgendwann dann denkt ja mal braucht man sie dann überhaupt noch.
Das kann ich ja auch im Freundeskreis mal gerade so herstellen. Und da glaube ich, ist es sehr sinnvoll, wieder auch über Ritualisierung nachzudenken.
Die kann man jetzt nicht immer so, wie das hier bei der Queen Victoria geschehen ist, mit Theaterregisseur einfach mal so schnell ins Leben setzen.
Aber eine Welt ohne Rituale gibt es nicht, denn das ist genauso, wie man glaubt, man könnte permanent.
Dem Konformismus entgehen durch Nonkonformismus. Aber dann wird halt der Nonkonformismus zum Konformismus. Bzw.
Es gibt von, von von Söldnern auch immer diese Betrachtungen, dass er sagt, ja,
es gibt eigentlich so, so Rituale des Antikapitalismus, das kannst du ja zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt mal bei Sascha Lobo bleibt, auf der republica sehen, wie man da Leute begrüßt, wie man sich dort verhält, was man trägt.
Das ist halt dann nicht die Pabst Robe und die Queen mit ihrem Blazer. Aber eigentlich unterscheidet sich das nicht viel.
Ach nee, Blazer trägt sie nicht. Sie trägt diese mittellangen Kleider.
Also. Es ist nirgendwo belastender für alle als zum Beispiel bei diesem Casual Friday oder so an der Arbeitsstelle, Wenn es heißt Heute kommen wir alle mal ganz locker und dann kommen alle ganz locker und wissen Sie gar nicht, wie sie sich verhalten sollen.
Oder wenn der Professor sagt Ja, und dann ist heute der Vortrag und dann gehen wir mit den Vortragenden noch essen und da machen wir uns den gemütlichen Abend und alle Studenten so scheiße. Ich weiß zwar, wie ich mich in Seminar Situation verhalte, aber wenn es plötzlich so gemütlich und der Professor ist da und er gibt mir dann später trotzdem eine Note, auch wenn es jetzt hier gemütlich zugeht.
Und Sascha Lobo meinte ja gerade Das ist totaler Quatsch, den Bienen das Ritual vorzuspielen, weil die können ja nicht reden, die antworten ja nicht.
Und der eine Punkt, der ein Ritual zum Ritual macht, ist, dass man da nicht miteinander redet oder sich überrascht, sondern das wird natürlich vorher und deswegen Protokoll aufgeschrieben, was dann passiert.
Und dann hält man sich genau an dieses Protokoll.
Nur vollzogen.
Es geht genau darum, nicht zu kommunizieren, deswegen da zu sagen, die Bienen kommunizieren nicht mehr genau.
Die sind einfach nur Objekt des Rituals, so wie jedes Subjekt in dem Ritual plötzlich zum Objekt des Rituals wird.
Und gerade diejenigen, die bewusst daran teilnehmen und dann auch Schritt für Schritt und genau sehen, wo wird hier eigentlich mal abgewichen. Das kann man dann wieder zum Thema machen. Und so weiter. Und da wird ja auch viel.
Also da beginnt ja dann das Spiel, wo man das so macht und.
Ja, Rituale.
Was wäre, wenn wir uns jetzt mal wirklich auf die Spitze treibt und Sascha Lobos Idee hier folgt Wir schaffen diese Rituale ab.
Dann hätten wir eine Situation, dass wir einfach sagen Die Queen ist tot. Im nicht geschriebenen Verfassungsrang steht dann einfach drin Ja, dann ist automatisch der nächste König. Also Charles war ja ab dem Moment des Wissens darüber, dass die Queen tot ist, König.
Alle anderen Situationen sind völlig egal, wo er wäre, in welchem Zustand. Er ist ganz automatisch der König.
Und damit wäre das geregelt. Man hätte einen Haken dran machen können.
Man schreibt das dann kurz Information mäßig irgendwo auf und damit ist gut.
Und in dieser BBC Berichterstattung hat man mit einer Seelsorgerin gesprochen, die dann auch meinte.
Diese Art der gemeinsamen Trauer eröffnet für alle die Gelegenheit zu sagen Ja, ich kannte die Queen nicht persönlich, aber ich habe ja Bezüge zu anderen.
Und gerade nach diesen Corona Jahren hat man ja auch unverarbeitete Trauer, Erlebnisse usw und jetzt treffen wir uns auf der Straße zu einer Trauerfeier und jeder bringt seinen eigenen Fall mit bis hin zum Haustier.
Als sie ausdrücklich gesagt, irgendwer hat seine Eltern verloren, irgendwann seine Kinder verloren, irgendwer hat ein Haustier verloren und dann gehen alle auf die Straße und jeder bringt seine eigene Trauer Geschichte mit. Und dann wird das mal zum Thema.
Und eigentlich kommen wir jetzt so langsam in diese Schrumpfung und Altwerden Gesellschaft, wo wir sagen können Du kennst wahrscheinlich diesen Film.
Koko heißt da glaube ich, wo für Kinder mal dieses mexikanische Todes fest gefeiert wird.
Das ist ja für uns Europäer völlig wie die feiern, die Toten. Also einmal im Jahr gedenken die den Toten. Wir machen das doch nur am Tag der Beerdigung und danach ist es so durch und schon nach fünf Jahren. Ach ja, heut war ja der Tag, wo jemand gestorben ist. Wenn man vergisst es völlig.
Und eigentlich brauchen wir mehr diese Rituale. Also die Queen hat mir eigentlich auch noch mal gezeigt, so ein bisschen, nein, wir kommen jetzt in diese Gesellschaft, wo auch mein Buch Kategorie eins Sterben ist.
Also ich bin Bestseller in der Kategorie Sterben bei Amazon.
Ja, wir brauchen eigentlich diese Kategorie Mehr Wir müssen jetzt sterben lernen, weil demnächst werden sehr viele Leute sterben lernen.
Es gibt die ersten Unternehmen, die sich jetzt, nachdem sie jahrelang sich warmwerden mussten mit der Elternzeit. Und so weiter.
Dass Menschen sich da freinehmen für die Pflege ihrer jungen Kinder. Dass man sich jetzt auch fragt Wie geht man mit Pflegefälle, Angehörige, Ältere und auch Todestage um? Also kriegt man Sonderurlaub. Und so weiter.
Das muss jetzt diskutiert werden, weil demnächst eben sehr viele Leute einfach sterben. Und das findet Deutschland noch nicht so richtig statt.
Wir haben uns von der Queen so ein Angebot bekommen, das kollektiv zu machen, was ich sehr gut finde. So als Idee, dass man sagt egal wann man die eigene Verlusterfahrungen macht, man weiß keine Ahnung, 19 oder September oder so was.
Gibt es einen kollektiven Volkstrauertag oder so?
Aber in anderer Weise als jetzt hier wieder neu das Fernsehprogramm so ein bisschen, um an so ein paar Seelsorger, die auch ein bisschen darüber reden, wie es ist, Verlust von Erfahrung zu verarbeiten. Und so weiter.
Genau. Und man institutionalisiert das mal wieder neu. Man stellt das Fernsehprogramm so ein bisschen um, hört abends so ein paar Seelsorger, die auch so ein bisschen darüber reden, wie es ist, Verlusterfahrungen zu verarbeiten usw.
Aber man kann das jetzt mal reinholen, man kann das jetzt mal institutionalisieren und ritualisiert und ich glaube, damit wäre sehr vielen Menschen geholfen.
Aber man kann das jetzt mal reinholen. Man kann das jetzt mal institutionalisieren und ritualisiert ritualisierten. Und ich glaube, damit wäre sehr vielen Menschen geholfen.
Dass die Imker so ein bisschen in die Pionierrolle fallen. Okay.
Dass die Imker so ein bisschen die Pionierrolle fallen. Fein.
Aber ich finde, man kann das jetzt mal so!
Arbeitnehmer. Das ist aber bekannt, dass es ja bei bei Imkern tatsächlich diese ganz, ganz nahe Bindung zu den Bienen gibt.
Wir bleiben ja noch bei den Ritualen. Dazu gehört natürlich auch, dass man lange in der Schlange steht, zum Beispiel auch wenn man David Beckham ist. Und der wird hier mal ganz kurz interviewt, dann, während er zwölf Stunden in der Schlange steht.
David Bowie Does it today, you know it up in a house holt, Ruhe lässt And I was pop up that way so my if my gram would have been here today.
Friend.
Drei.
I know what I want it to be here so I am on their behalf on my family and with everybody else here.
Er sah natürlich wieder perfekt aus, sehr gut gekleidet.
Er nimmt jetzt auch noch mal die Großeltern, die nicht mehr leben, noch mal dazu. Die würden das jetzt auch so machen.
Es ist eine nahezu idealtypisch perfekte Antwort für diese Frage, die ihm gestellt wurde. Ich bin hier nicht nur für mich, sondern auch für diejenigen, die mir nahestehen, aber hier nicht mehr dabei sein können. Die Queen ist jetzt für uns alle gestorben, auch für die, die schon längst gestorben sind.
Das ist ein bisschen, wie das auch schon wieder Nachrufe aufgetaucht sind über die Queen von Menschen, die selber schon gestorben sind, also die, wo es zeitlich total auseinanderfällt, wer hier wem gedenkt und der Tod so eine große Rolle spielt.
Nun müssen wir aber noch mal als Kritik einfließen lassen, dass wir ja hier von folgender Konstellation ausgehen Wir haben da jemand, der aufgrund von Geburt.
Diese besondere Position bekommt.
Diese besondere Position kommt wie wir alle.
Na? Wir alle in der westlichen Welt im Sinne von eines Orts Bonus Ja, aber wir sind natürlich jetzt nicht jetzt Oberhäupter irgendwo und haben die Aufgabe, ein Land zu repräsentieren.
In der westlichen Welt. Wir in der westlichen Welt im Sinne von eines Ortsbewohner. Richtig.
Aber wir sind natürlich nicht als Oberhäupter und Farmer, als Touristen nach Nigeria. Wie du dich fühlst. Du wirst aufgenommen wie ein König.
Das? Mag sein, okay. Aber dennoch, wenn wir es jetzt mal auf unsere Gesellschaft beziehen, dann haben wir ja eine Hierarchie darin.
Also du weißt ja auch die Hanseaten, wenn sie das Bundesverdienstkreuz bekommen, dann lehnen sie das ab, weil sie nicht einen Orden tragen wollen, weil nicht einer über dem anderen stehen soll.
Und das ist ja ein demokratisches Grundprinzip und natürlich auch der Schritt zur Aufklärung und auch zum.
Demokratischen Bürger, dass man nicht mehr jemanden braucht, den man bewundern kann, sondern wir wollen Amtsträger, die eine Kompetenz haben in den verschiedenen Dingen, die nicht so wie Christian Lindner unterwegs sind.
Und dann sind wir froh. Aber wir müssen jetzt goutieren. Habeck macht Dinge gut, aber wir würden jetzt nicht in blinder Bewunderung hier sitzen und sagen Mein Gott!
Also Themen einmal die Hand zu geben, das wäre das Höchste. Ja, so Leute gibt das natürlich, das finde ich immer hoch verdächtig.
Hier haben wir das aber bei einer Person. Und man kann doch auch sagen, solange eine Gesellschaft dies noch braucht oder solange man nicht da wirklich eine fundamentale Kritik daran übt, sind wir eigentlich in einer unaufgeklärten,
Lage, die ja niemals dazu führen wird, dass man tatsächlich mal die großen wichtigen Schritte angeht.
Und ich will jetzt einen Clip spielen, auch aus diesem älteren Deutschlandfunk Beitrag.
Ganz kurz, wo jemand sich äußert ein Brite, der diese Hochzeit jetzt sich ansieht und man kann das jetzt direkt übertragen, nehme an, der hätte das zur Beerdigung gesagt.
Wenn du dir überlegst, dass die nur ein paar Meter entfernt sein werden. Das passiert uns nur einmal im Leben. Meinen Leuten sage ich Das hier ist etwas, woran wir uns unser ganzes Leben lang erinnern werden. Wir werden unseren Enkelkindern noch erzählen können. Wir waren dabei.
Ist das nicht eine ungeheuer traurige Aussage? Ähm.
Hm. Du willst dich ja noch rechtfertigen mit deinem Queen Tech.
Ja noch rechtfertigen. Fintech Ja, also wir kennen natürlich alle dieses Phänomen.
In China wird ja zum Beispiel komplett übertrieben. Es gab kürzlich in den Abendnachrichten,
einen Bericht darüber, dass irgend so ein Dorf ein sich komplett selbst in ein Museum verwandelt hat, nachdem China da vor acht Jahren mal zu Besuch war für drei Tage.
Man hat jeden Stationen dieser kurzen Stippvisite, weil der hatte das so als Beispiel Dorf ausgesucht für Hier kultivieren wir jetzt den ländlichen Raum und sorgen auch hier für Wachstum. Und so weiter.
Und dann sind die halt auf die Idee gekommen, das einfach diesen Moment festzuhalten. Jeden Stuhl, den Che berührt hat als den hat zuletzt Chi berührt und.
Und so. Also man kann es komplett übertreiben, aber das ist halt Popkultur.
Wir gehen alle deswegen in diese Konzerte, weil wir über die Musik hinaus diese Anwesenheit, dieses Raum gebundene und auf da braucht man dann auch mal seinen Körper, da reicht nicht nur der Tonträger und man hört diese Art der Nähe. Ich kann das irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Und ist diese Nähe schlimm? Also wir haben jetzt ganz häufig auch diesen Begriff der sozialen Beziehungen, den man aufbaut.
Das haben wir bei den Followern zu den Influencern, aber das haben wir ja auch bei Wählern zu Politikern vielleicht. Oder wir haben das bei Leuten, die die Podcasts hören.
Und da steckt natürlich in diesem Wort eine Kritik gleich drin.
Es ist etwas pejorativ gebraucht, weil man dann sagt Ja, das ist keine richtige Beziehung, weil man sich ja nicht.
Face to face gegenübersitzt und man sich wirklich kennt, sondern jemand hört nur zu oder sieht nur und ist dann Empfänger, aber kann nicht wirklich zurück kommunizieren, vielleicht mal was kommentieren.
Aber es ist nicht diese Kommunikation, die wir zwei jetzt gerade hier miteinander führen. Und dann würde ich aber sagen.
Das ist ja auch etwas, was es immer schon gab.
Also ich sehe das Problem der sozialen Beziehungen da, wo das Abhängigkeiten produziert, also wo junge Leute dazu angetrieben werden, sich in den,
Bankrott zu shoppen durch irgendwelche Hypes, die Influencer auslösen oder durch abhängen.
Abhängigkeiten sexueller Natur. Dass Leute immer mehr bereit sind, bei Uni Fans zu zahlen, weil sie glauben, dass es eigentlich ihre wahre Freundin, die sie da haben.
Da hat das sicherlich eine sehr ungesunde Komponente.
Aber zugleich würde ich sagen, zu Martin Walser habe ich auch eine paar soziale Beziehungen.
Ich habe alle, alle wichtigen Romane von ihm gelesen, und natürlich war das für mich ganz wichtig, schon in der Jugendzeit.
Und ich habe den Mann mal bei einer Lesung gesehen, aber nie mit dem irgendwas zu tun gehabt. Aber trotzdem würde ich sagen, ist da ein Band da. Ich würde jetzt nicht gleich an den Bodensee fahren, wenn er stirbt und würde da zur Beerdigung gehen.
Aber natürlich ist es eine Paare soziale Beziehung, ein paar soziale Beziehungen, die ich aber auch habe zu gewissen Sängern, weil diese Stimmen immer für mich so wichtig waren.
Und die habe ich auch nicht im Realen. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich hätte aber eigentlich gerne Maria Callas würde ich jetzt gern treffen. Es gibt halt niemand so meinen Bekanntenkreis, der so singen kann.
Diese Sozialität steht immer in der Kritik, weil sie eben nicht ganz sozial ist, sondern nur asozial.
Und wir müssen das aber in beide Richtungen denken, denn sie ist asozial und damit auch nicht asozial.
Also es gibt so ein, ich sag es mal so die Queen Elizabeth. Die zweite ist nicht Queen Elizabeth die erste oder Queen Victoria.
Die beiden haben wirklich materiell Weltreiche aufgebaut, 25 mal fünfmal so groß wie Alexander der Große in seiner Zeit.
So war natürlich viel Technik getrieben Schifffahrt, unglaubliche Materialschlacht, Kolonialismus, alles, was da reingehört, so richtig.
Hier wurde regiert, und zwar über Land, Boden mit Blut und Schwert. Und so weiter.
Und jetzt haben wir festgestellt jetzt bei Queen Elizabeth. Das Reich ist zerbröckelt. Es blieb noch so ein Commonwealth.
Es war also die Idee von der Da machen wir wenigstens gemeinsame Jugendspiele und man hat so parallel zu Olympia organisiert. Und wir stellen fest, sie hat nicht über Land und Leute regiert, sondern einfach über die Gemüter, und zwar global.
Also auch wir in Deutschland konnten dann irgendwann diesen Spruch übernehmen. Zuerst war sie die britische Queen, dann war sie die globale Queen, dann war sie nur noch die Queen. Also sie gehörte auch irgendwie zu uns. Wir konnten unseren Zeit damit füllen, die Zeitungen waren voll. Und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ist doch eigentlich interessant, dass wir dann Leute haben, die dann irgendwie sagen Ja, so ein Mal nutze ich die Gelegenheit, wenn sie sich bietet, auch in ihrer Anwesenheit zu sein.
Aber sie ist halt grundsätzlich bei mir auch abwesend, nicht asozial. Und das ist ja was ganz Besonderes.
Also dass man so eine Art von Ich will es nicht übertreiben, aber es fehlen einem auch ein bisschen die Worte Weltgeist und so was hat ja, dass einfach immer jemand irgendwo ist. Ich schon. Irgendwer sieht sich schon gerade.
Irgendwer kann ich schon gerade bezeugen, dass sie gerade lebt und arbeitet. Und so weiter. Es muss nicht ich sein. Ich kann mich drauf verlassen. Sie ist da. Andernfalls würde ich es mitbekommen. Und dann kriegt es aber die ganze Welt mit Her Majesty just did.
So, dann ist es einfach der Satz, der alle anderen Sätze aufhebt.
So, und solange diese Art von Welt Gewissheit irgendwie da ist, dass es weitergeht, dass die Rituale laufen, auch wenn ich selbst gerade nicht involviert bin, genau das bringt das.
Das war der eigentliche Wert, der so mitgeliefert wurde.
Und wäre das denn auch möglich, ohne das zu leben? Ich meine, es gibt ja viele Leute, denen ist das jetzt sonstwo vorbei gegangen mit der Queen, oder?
Wir haben ja auch Konstellationen, wo wir das nicht so erleben. Beispielsweise war ich vor einer Weile in Berlin und dann fuhr der Bundeskanzler im Auto an mir vorbei und der Taxifahrer sagte zu mir Da ist der Bundeskanzler.
Und dann sagte ich Aha, aber da habe ich ja nicht gerade toll, diesen Moment erlebt zu haben. Der Bundeskanzler, das haben wir vorbeigefahren.
Also wir kommen wir zu einer Gesellschaft. Und deswegen noch mal meine Frage Bist du Royalist?
Das war ja ernsthaft gestellt, gerade weil ich das noch mal adressierte an den Systemtheoretiker.
Inwieweit hat das jetzt diese funktionale Komponente, dass du sagst So möchtest du, dass die Gesellschaft funktioniert?
Oder sagst du, das dient dem Funktionieren einer Gesellschaft, weil ja die Kritik jetzt wäre? Und das ist ja nicht eine besonders linke Kritik einfach nur, sondern generell eine Kritik aus der Aufklärung heraus gesprochen Wozu brauchen wir die?
Sehr gute. Ich nehme die Herausforderung jetzt an und liefere jetzt meine vorbereitete Antwort. Denn ja, sehr viele kam es mit dieser Kritik.
Sie hat ja gar keine formale oder politische Macht. Und ich sage Nö.
Sie war aber trotzdem da, hat gewirkt. Es greift dieses Thomas Theorem.
Gibt es einen Gott? Ja oder nein? Wenn alle in die Kirche gehen, gibt es ja eine Ursache dafür.
Die ist Gott. Also muss es Gott irgendwo geben. Und dann ist die Frage in welchem Zustand.
Und ich will mal eine sozusagen formale, historische, historische.
Wie soll man es fassen? Ich beschreibe es mal und dann kann jeder selber überlegen über die Antwort auf die Frage, welche Funktion und welche Folgen hatte die Anwesenheit und das Leben der Queen?
Würde ich jetzt ganz. Wir wollen ja hier spontan historisieren, die letzten 70 Jahre mal aufgreifen und sagen 1952 gab es.
Eine Nachkriegszeit, die schon im Abklingen war. Wir wussten so ein bisschen okay, wirtschaftlich geht es bergauf, die Leute profitieren davon. Aber Europa hat immer noch Diktatoren gekannt, Spanien, Portugal usw.
Das war noch die Blütezeit der Diktaturen, während wir schon Kohle und Stahl und wir wissen heute, wohin es führte. Europäische Union, das Aufblühen dieser Demokratie.
Wir sprachen ja zuletzt über die den neuen Autokratien.
Also wir kennen so eine Blütezeit von Demokratie.
Und es war eben nicht.
Schon vorher reingeschrieben, dass Europa jetzt eine ganz tolle Demokratie wird bis zum Jahr 2000 und danach kommt so ein Orban oder so und Polen und dann wird es wieder zertrümmert.
Und jetzt gerade während wir hier sprechen, finden im Iran Volksaufstände statt.
Es begann bei den Frauen, hat sich jetzt durch die ganze Gesellschaft gezogen. Es gibt diese große, große Unzufriedenheit, große Wut. Und jetzt rätseln wirklich gerade alle, was passiert denn da eigentlich?
Und wir haben und deswegen biete ich jetzt einen funktionalen Vergleich, also den darf man jetzt nicht sachlich übertreiben, das rein funktional.
Wir haben im Iran diese Konstellation Bevölkerung und Regierung und dahinter aber noch als drittes im Bunde ein Ayatollah.
Wir wissen, es ist ein schiitisch dominiertes Land. Die Schiiten haben einen Ajatollah und der übernimmt vor allem die religiöse Führerschaft, aber eben auch viele weltliche. Also er sagt einfach, was ihr politisch gemacht wird, alles hängt von ihm ab.
Und das mal funktional. Verglichen mit der Queen, die 1952 viele Gelegenheit bekommen hat zu sagen Ich nutze meine mediale Macht, um mich trotzdem politisch einzumischen.
Es steht nirgendwo so richtig geschrieben, dass mir das verboten ist. Ich hätte die Macht. Ich habe diese wöchentliche Konsultation mit dem jeweiligen Premierminister.
Ich. Überlebe viele Premierminister. Ich kann auch langfristige Linien hier einfach aufziehen und immer mal wieder hier und da.
Und sie hat ja dann auch mit ihren Kostümen gespielt, den Brexit entsprechend kommentiert, mit blauem Hut und gelben Blümchen drin. Und so weiter und so fort.
Und die große Leistung der Queen, die wir heute als absolut selbstverständlich ansehen, die aber nicht selbstverständlich ist, ist sich 52 dafür entschieden zu haben, zu sagen Egal, was passiert, die nächsten 70 Jahre, die ich regiere.
Meine Botschaft lautet Ihr habt euch für Demokratie entschieden und jetzt müsst ihr auch Demokratie machen.
Erwartet nicht von mir, dass ich noch mal und ich selbst hatte diese Wünsche in mir, als wir den Brexit kommentiert haben, Dass die Queen hier doch noch einmal interveniert, dass wir noch mal so, so eine göttliche Fügung oder so was, ja, so eine, so eine divine Intervention.
Und Devine, meint ihr wirklich, die Queen, die hätte diese religiöse Kraft, um da einfach genau. Aber es passiert da alles nicht, sondern sie hat ihr Land, das ihr unterstand England auf die Demokratie verpflichtet, egal was passiert.
Ja, ja, das wäre wirklich der der Deus ex Machina. Wie im Theater.
Ja, das. Ihr unterstand England.
Auch die Demokratie verpflichtet. Egal, was passiert, Boris Johnson wollte die BBC zertrümmern. Jetzt kommt List Trust. Und wir wissen alle nicht, was das bedeutet.
Boris Johnson wollte die BBC zertrümmern. Jetzt kommt Liz Trust und wir wissen alle nicht, was das bedeutet.
Ganz großes Durcheinander. Aber ihre Botschaft war Ihr habt euch für Demokratie entschieden, also macht es Demokratie.
Hofft nicht darauf, dass ich jetzt mit Autokratie zurückkäme, obwohl ich in der Poleposition wäre.
Jetzt noch mal das eine oder andere zu versuchen, da wirklich inhaltlich einzugreifen und.
Jetzt noch mal das eine oder andere zu versuchen, da wirklich inhaltlich einzugreifen, das wurde ja jetzt auch noch mal laut.
Es gab ja jetzt noch mal Artikel, die noch mal aufgeschrieben haben.
Da hat sie damals versagt beim Brexit. Und sie verstehen gar nicht, was das bedeutet hätte,
wäre sie in der Weise nach vorne geschritten und hätte gesagt Ich will den Brexit nicht und überlegt euch das mal, wenn sie das gemacht hätte, hätte sie alles riskiert.
Bzw. Dann wäre wahrscheinlich die Monarchie abgeschafft oder irgendwas anderes wäre Kraut und Rüben.
Das wäre ein gigantischer Schritt gewesen. Das wäre undenkbar gerade.
Hm? Genau. Und ich sehe die Bandbreite und damit auch, wie man die Leistung dieser Lebensleistung einschätzen soll.
Irgendwo in dieser Dimension, wo auf der einen Seite der Ayatollah ist, der immer noch versucht, das Land einfach zu unterdrücken und die Biografien der jungen Frauen und Männer zu brechen.
Und auf der anderen Seite der Queen, die einfach dieses.
Unendlich stabile, weitreichende Versprechen gegeben hat. Wir machen jetzt Demokratie.
Trotz aller Tradition, die wir hatten, mit der mit unserer.
Und es ist eben nicht nur weltliche Herrschaft. Es war auch. Sie ist auch Oberhaupt der Kirche dort.
Einfach das andere Angebot zu fahren. Und dass wir es heute als so selbstverständlich ansehen, dass die Quellenlage so gar nicht und überhaupt es ist ja nur noch so eine formale Rolle.
Ja, das ist Ihre Leistung, dass wir das heute so sehen und sagen, Genau das ist einfach die Herausforderung der Demokratie. Jetzt macht mal ihr Demokraten, und wir werden jetzt sehen, welchen Pfad England da einschlägt. Es wird ja gruselig.
Die ökonomischen Daten sehen ja nicht so aus, als ob man da ohne autokratische Züge irgendwie das Land befriedet halten kann, wie das der letzten 70 Jahre gelang. Und in der Hinsicht.
Und Russ hat ja vor, jetzt erst mal Steuererleichterungen zu bringen, weil sie ganz fest an den Trickle Down Effekt glaubt.
Das war Steuererleichterung. Ganz fest an den trickle down. Ja, es ist. Es ist traurig.
Es ist richtig traurig. Es gab auch einen Skandal. Bei dieser ganzen Zeremonie nämlich ist es ja so Man steht ganz lange in der Schlange, auch ein David Beckham.
Aber dann gibt es die Gerüchte bzw auch entsprechende Bilder.
Dass Bill und Holly, das sind die berühmtesten Frühstücks Fernsehmoderatoren Englands, sich vorgedrängelt haben bzw als Journalisten akkreditierte irgendwie sich vorbei geschlichen haben.
Es gab da Aufnahmen davon, es gab einen immensen Twitter Shitstorm.
Man muss sagen, die sind wirklich ganz populär. Wir haben zwar auch Frühstücks Moderatoren, aber das ist nicht vergleichbar.
Also das sind Institutionen und das waren dann überall auch auf den Blättern.
Dann als der große Skandal der Stunde und ich habe mit einem Bekannten telefoniert, der Engländer ist und er sagte Wolfgang, wenn du mal wissen willst, wenn du mal wirklich einen, einen britischen Satz haben willst, was ist wirklich britisch?
Dann soll ich mir das Statement durchlesen, das daraufhin Holly und Bill verfasst haben, nachdem es diesen Shitstorm gab. Und der letzte Satz ist entscheidend.
One of the broke masters and journalist there any one's place in the queue and no one. Filed post the Queen of course respect rules however like something else.
And there for totally understand a reaction, please know what we would never jump a.
Please know me with never trump uk. Britischer ginge es nicht mehr, sagte man mir.
Also niemals würden sie eine Warteschlange überspringen.
Und es war dann überall großes Thema. Ich habe es mir ein bisschen bei YouTube angesehen.
Hier noch ein Ausschnitt aus Piers Morgan weil du jetzt auch gerade von der Einigkeit, die die Queen noch mal hergestellt hat usw.
Und ist sie jetzt vielleicht schon zerbrochen? Kaum hat die Queen die Augen zugemacht, geht schon alles drunter und drüber. Wenn man sich das hier anhört.
Everything is,
a lot of people to be right now And I don't think they should be the wall of this,
people of the front page of the biggest of all time is they made in my opinion management as every journalist died in this.
Because the public Where are you xy and a lot like the journalist world. So they are a.
The most all been talking. I was here on you want to go talking about the unity of this is the outcome.
Britain is a great Britain jumping the cure. Olten take,
away in.
Ja, das ist vielleicht geblieben von all dem. Man weiß es nicht. Wird König Charles das noch mal einigen?
Wir werden es vielleicht Ende des Jahrzehnts noch mal aufgreifen, sonst werden wir nicht weiterhin so realistisch unterwegs sein.
Es ist ja auch jetzt wirklich Ansehen des royalen Königshauses, für Ruhe zu sorgen.
King Charles wird alles auf sich ziehen. Er hat sich ja von allen anderen Engagements getrennt nur noch die repräsentative Rolle übernehmen.
Wir wissen, dass alle Medienhäuser, die akkreditiert waren, jetzt den Auftrag gekriegt haben, die eine Stunde Material aus den zehn Tagen im Königshaus vorzulegen.
Die darf dann später weiterverwendet werden, alles andere nicht mehr.
Also die Erinnerungskultur wird auf einen ganz engen Fokus gelegt, also nur noch auf die Highlights. Und so weiter.
Damit solche Diskussionen dann gar nicht mehr groß, weil man einfach gar kein Material mehr zeigen darf davon, wie jemand in der Schlange stand oder so, weil das ist ja alles Postproduktion gewesen.
Und die große Herausforderung wird Prinz Harry sein, der ja nun schon.
Thomas hat mir das gestern gezeigt. In einem Interview, über die Suizidgedanken von Megan sprach, wie er sich im Stich gelassen fühlte.
Und er holt ja auch gerade aus, mit einem 40 Millionen Vorschuss ein Buch vorzulegen, in dem all seine Sorgen noch einmal dargelegt werden. Und Prinz Williams Aufgabe wird sein, da irgendwie wieder so eine Augenhöhe herzustellen.
Ich finde, die sollten denn einfach jetzt dafür stoßen. Ja, es ist ja auch auch richtig.
Sie haben ihn ja im Grunde verstoßen. Und das ist ja genau die. Ich finde, ab einem gewissen. Millionenbetrag auf dem Konto für das.
Ich finde, ab einem gewissen Millionenbetrag auf dem Konto hat man auch nicht mehr das Recht, unglücklich zu sein. Ja.
Ja, also es gibt jetzt viele Einflugschneise in diese Diskussion.
Viele. Weißt. Es ist immer gut. Es ist dann wirklich jetzt auch mal gut. Und ich verstehe auch nicht. Das haben die auch gewusst. Und das hat auch Megan.
Die hätte sich ja auch einen anderen Mann ohne Haare suchen können. Also, es gibt ja.
Es gibt ja keine Veranlassung dazu, dass man sagt, ich würde mal gerne ins Königshaus einheiraten und glaubt dann, das sei so wie immer, wie überall mit irgendeiner Beziehung. Nein, das ist natürlich, das ist.
Man geht nicht eine Beziehung nur ein, sondern man wechselt den Job, und zwar vollkommen. Und wenn man das nicht machen will, dann muss man das nicht machen. Die sind ja nicht.
Das ist ja keine Zwangsehe gewesen, sondern die haben sich ja selbst dafür entschieden. Und dann muss man das entweder mitmachen, oder man kann sich auch in aller Stille zurückziehen und wird ja dann immer noch prächtig alimentiert.
Es ist ja keineswegs so, dass man sich um die finanzielle Sorgen machen muss und das finde ich wirklich so was von degoutant.
Und dass das aber trotzdem in einer Gesellschaft, wo keiner mehr irgendwas Vernünftiges erbt, wo das ja, wo das.
Also gut, es gibt noch Leute, die erben, aber die meisten Leute erben nix. Und wo wir so eine unglaubliche Ungleichheit haben, dass dann Leute noch glauben, sie müssen jetzt Prinz Harry und Meghan empowern, da muss man wirklich sagen, sind ja jetzt alle verrückt geworden.
Also da ist mir ja jeder Royalist, der zwei Stunden in der Schlange zwölf Stunden in der Schlange steht, lieber, weil der wenigstens ja noch eine Form wahrt. Also dass man jetzt noch glaubt, man müsste diese Leute da unterstützen. Nein, sie haben diesen Weg gewählt.
Dann haben sie plötzlich gemerkt Ach so, das bedeutet ja auch Arbeit und bedeutet Repräsentanz Und in jedem Sinne des Wortes ja, Pech gehabt. Aber da muss man nicht gleich zur Oprah Winfrey laufen.
Ja, ich bin auch begeistert von der Professionalität von William und Kate. Um das noch mal zu sagen Das ist toll zu sehen und mal sehen, was die Zukunft bringt.
Wir wollen noch ganz kurz, weil wir das noch gar nicht angesprochen haben, über den Salon sprechen.
Es ist soweit Das Buch von Richard David Precht und Harald Welzer ist erschienen.
Es liegt jetzt schon auf meinem Schreibtisch. Ich habe schon mal ganz kurz rein geblättert, aber ich fange mit der Lektüre jetzt nach der Aufnahme dieses Podcasts an 260 Seiten, einige Fußnoten auf Lager.
Ich habe schon mal reingeguckt. Was wird da so alles zitiert?
Sie machen wohl einen großen Rundumschlag. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf das Buch und habe auch mir folgendes geschworen Ich werde bis zu der Aufnahme des Salons,
kein Interview mit den beiden lesen und auch keinen Podcast mir mit denen anhören.
Ich will wirklich nur das Werk, will die Argumente haben und will diese anderen Dinge ausblenden.
Das ist das, was mich interessiert an diesem Buch und ich würde aber gerne eine,
Argumentation schon mal vorwegnehmen, die jetzt gemacht wird von vehementen Gegnern dieses Buchs, die sagen Wie können die ein Buch über die Medien schreiben, dass die Medien über Dinge nicht berichten oder so? Die kommen doch die ganze Zeit in den Medien vor.
Sollen wir wirklich uns auf dieses Niveau jetzt begeben und sagen ab wann darf man dann das Buch schreiben, wenn man gar nicht mehr in den Medien ist?
Oder kann es vielleicht sein, dass diese Leute ganz prominent sind und deswegen noch in den Medien natürlich vorkommen, egal was sie machen?
Also auch wenn die beiden zusammen ein Kochbuch geschrieben hätten, würden die natürlich vorkommen. Aber das ist dann wieder ein Prominenz System.
Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man jetzt immer sagt na ja, aber die kommen vor und wir machen es ja hier auch immer wieder thematisch fest, dass so vieles nicht vorkommt, also wie unterrepräsentiert zum Beispiel europäische Themen in den Medien sind.
Natürlich ist dann nicht jemand, der sagt, das darf jetzt nicht gebracht werden, sondern es geht ja hier um Strukturelles.
Ob das in dem Buch dann analysiert wird, wird sich zeigen. Ich finde nur, dass diese Argumentationen, die sind dann in den Medien, also sollen sie sich doch nicht beschweren, dass sie in den Medien nicht vorkommen.
Das finde ich ein bisschen albern, weil man jetzt.
Auch. Trotzdem, auch wenn man davon nicht in dem Sinne betroffen ist, kann man ja trotzdem Argument machen. Also ich kann ja auch.
Ich könnte jetzt ein Buch über die Geschichte des Sports schreiben, auch wenn ich selbst keinen Sport mache.
Na also. Es gibt, und das kenne ich aus eigener Erfahrung in den Redaktionen, diesen Moment, wenn man feststellt, dass derjenige.
Über den man berichtet oder mit dem man berichtet, als Journalist oder Redakteur selber sehr viel mehr Reichweite hat.
Das ist vor allem im Sportjournalismus so, wo dann irgendwann doch sich eingestellt hat, dass ein Sportschau Moderator Millionen Gehalt hat, weil das wäre ja irgendwie sonst nicht auf Augenhöhe, wenn er mit Millionären die ganze Zeit redet, die nämlich den Sport ausüben und die sehr viel mehr Follower haben. Und so weiter.
Wenn er da selbst so unter ferner liefen läuft.
Und das, was du jetzt angemerkt hast, ist, finde ich, gerade der Grund, warum wir dieses Buch so ernst nehmen sollten. Weil nämlich die Journalisten es ernst nehmen, weil sie nämlich von den beiden in Sachen Reichweite schachmatt gesetzt werden.
Und das ist genau der Grund, weshalb wir alle auf dieses Buch gucken und ihm damit noch mehr Reichweite verschaffen.
Also da ist halt so ein kleiner Zirkel drin, den kann man auch Paradoxie nennen usw, Aber das ist, das ist der Anlass, warum wir uns mit diesem Buch beschäftigen.
Darüber hinaus wir haben ja die beiden Autoren hier schon häufiger irgendwie thematisiert, oft kritisch. Genau das ist der Punkt. Und diesmal? Ich werde es auch machen, so wie du.
Oft kritisch, will ich hinzufügen, diesmal rückwärts machen, so wie du.
Ich habe dadurch, dass ich jetzt Zeit Abonnent bin, natürlich mal quer gelesen, dieses Gespräch, was Sie da führen. Aber da ist ja auch nichts, was jetzt irgendwie mich vorher schon aus der Bahn wirft oder so, sondern ich kann mich jetzt auf das.
Dadurch, dass ich jetzt Zeit Abonnent bin, natürlich mal quer gelesen. Dieses. Sie noch?
Fahren wir fort. Ich brauche auch nicht noch mal ein Interview zu einem Buch. Also, wenn die 260 Seiten aufgeschrieben haben, dann reicht mir das ja auch vorerst mal!
Ja, genau. Also. Ja, genau. Und ich finde fast, Sie quatschen jetzt zu viel in irgendwelchen Podcasts.
Ich finde fast, sie quatschen jetzt zu viel in irgendwelchen Podcast, wo sie irgendwie zu Gast sind und eine Stunde lang mit den Leuten reden. Hey, lasst doch das Ding für euch stehen.
Dass Sie irgendwie zu Gast sind und dann eine Stunde lang mit irgendwelchen Leuten reden. Nee, lasst doch das Ding für euch stehen. Wir nehmen also das Buch ernst.
Wir nehmen das Buch ernst. Finde ich auch sehr gut. Ich würde auch.
Finde ich auch sehr gut. Ich werde auch nichts weiter darüber hinaus lesen, sondern einfach Dann werden wir das Buch besprechen.
Wir besprechen in aller Sachlichkeit und Nüchternheit und ohne Aufregung.
Und wir haben jedenfalls keine besonderen Sympathien mit denen, sondern schauen da leidenschaftslos, sagen wir drauf, weil wir.
Ich habe natürlich eine Vorfreude auf die Debatte und all das. Klar. Ich freue mich auch sehr auf die Aufnahme. Schon, aber wir haben nicht in irgendeiner Weise, dass wir sagen, den fand ich schon immer toll oder schon immer schlimm, sondern ich fand manches immer toll und manches immer schlimm bei beiden.
Und das wird sich dann zeigen, welche Seite das Buch mehr einlösen wird.
Jedenfalls sprechen wir darüber. Dann nächste Woche im Salon noch kurz der Hinweis Der Salon ist, wir müssen es immer mal wieder erwähnen, weil es sonst Irritationen gibt. Der Salon ist komplett.
Buchbar über Steady. Das ist über unsere Seite neue 20 HD zu machen.
Das kann man aber, wenn man den Podcast über Spotify hört, auch da über einen Button machen.
Dann kommt man direkt dorthin. Und wenn man das Ganze über Steady abschließt, dann das ist wichtig, dass wir darauf hinweisen, hat man auch das gesamte Salon Archiv von Januar angefangen, 2020 bis heute.
Wenn man den Salon jetzt über Apple bucht, dann ist es so, dass man dort auch ältere Folgen buchen kann.
Aber nicht alle. Und bei Patreon sind wir ja auch, weil wir wissen, dass manche Leute Gamer zum Beispiel bei Patreon Leute unterstützen.
Und dann kann wir das natürlich verstehen, dass man sagt, Ich will nicht noch mal einen neuen Account haben jetzt, Warum muss ich noch steady?
Da kann man also den Salon auch abonnieren und hören. Und da sind auch ein paar Folgen jetzt da, die ja schon bei Patreon sind. Ich glaube, zwei sind es oder zwei oder drei.
Aber da wird jetzt nicht noch mal das gesamte Archiv hochgeladen. Das wäre eine Herkulesaufgabe.
Wer also wirklich alles haben möchte, der kann das dort über den Salon.
Ich kann das über Steady tun und die neue Seite empfiehlt sich sowieso, die mal zu besuchen, weil dort auch für die, die den Salon nicht abonniert haben, immer das aufgelistet ist, was gemacht ist, worüber wir sprechen.
Und vielleicht ist dann auch bei manchen noch mal das Interesse da, das abzuschließen, um auch noch mal eine ein oder andere alte Folge nachzuhören.
Denn wir besprechen ja doch auch viele Bücher und Texte, die eine gewisse Zeitlosigkeit haben. Wir wollen ja nicht so sehr dem Tagesgeschäft hinterher hecheln.
Genau. Der Salon steht ja so ein bisschen für sich. Wir spontan historisieren, aber dann wirklich im Jahrzehnte Maß.
Da sind jetzt 70, 80 Bücher oder so, haben wir mittlerweile besprochen. Und wie gesagt, Steady, weil da kriegt man für den kleinsten Betrag das ganze Archiv und noch den ein oder anderen Vorzug, wie zum Beispiel da sind die Kapitel Marken mit drin.
Da kann man also selber von Text zu Text springen. Wir haben ein Cover, machen damit den Salon noch mal erkenntlich, welcher Monat ist es überhaupt?
Und man kann ihn im Podcast Player seiner eigenen Wahl hören, denn man kriegt einen ganz normalen RSS Feed, seinen eigenen, aber trotzdem ein ganz normalen RSS Feed.
Man kann also mit dem Podcast Player, den man sowieso nutzt, dann auch da einfach ganz normal abonnieren und kriegt einen Hinweis.
Neue Folge ist da und da muss man nur noch Play drücken.
Wir gehen zur Helmut Kohl Stiftung.
Wir gehen. Zur Helmut Kohl Stiftung.
Nein, ich kläre dich auf. Es gibt eine Helmut Kohl Stiftung und es gibt eine Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl Stiftung. Und wir gehen zur Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl Stiftung, weil das nämlich die der Partei ist.
Nein, auch es gibt eine Helmut Kohl Stiftung. Ach, und es gibt eine. Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl Stiftung.
Wir gehen zur Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl Stiftung, weil das nämlich die der Partei ist und nicht die von Maike.
Ganz genau. Ja.
Das hat mich mich gewundert, die ganze Zeit. Schön, dass du das aufklärt. Ich habe es mir angeguckt, Also nicht die gesamte Veranstaltung, aber die Merkel Rede ganz insbesondere. Und die wollen wir nun auch hier vorstellen. Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, wo ist Maike Kohl?
Ich will, dass du das auf der Veranstaltung aber die Merkel erzählt, und die nehmen auch, was ich dir vorstellen. Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, Wo ist Michael Kohl?
Und das erklärt es natürlich, dass es also die Gegenveranstaltung, möchte man fast sagen, denn ich war natürlich auch überrascht, wenn da Maike Kohl noch dabei wäre, dann hätte sie ja niemals Merkel eingeladen.
Das erklärt natürlich, dass es, also die Gegenveranstaltung, möchte man fast sagen, genauso.
Ich war natürlich auch überrascht, wenn da mal für Kohl noch dabei wäre, dann hätte sie ja niemals Merkel eingeladen.
Denn Merkel ist ja auch so ein bisschen unsere Queen, insofern, als sie Akzente zu setzen weiß.
Merkel ist ja auch so ein bisschen unsere Quinten, als sie Akzente zu setzen weiß.
Bei der Kohl Beerdigung nämlich dankte sie ja als erstes einmal Hannelore Kohl und hat damit auch ganz deutlich gesagt, was hier los ist.
Bei der Kohl Beerdigung nämlich dankte sie ja als erstes Hannelore Kohl. Also.
Man könnte eine eigene Netflix Netflix Code Serie draus machen, wie Angela Merkel in der Stiftung so gar nichts zu suchen hat, weil die Gründer das nicht wollen. Und in der anderen trifft sie dann auf Friedrich Merz.
Was machen, wie Angela Merkel in der Stiftung so gar nichts zu suchen.
Ja und? Und ist aber noch so mit ihm. So ein bisschen ja.
Und es ist ein bisschen er hat ja auch schon darauf hingewiesen, aber das habe ich jetzt mal alles nicht mitgebracht.
Friedrich Merz hat ja auch eben schon darauf hingewiesen. Aber das habe ich uns jetzt mal alles nicht mitgebracht.
Warum habe ich überhaupt uns jetzt noch mal Merkel mitgebracht? Nun, ich habe ein bisschen in die Clips rein geschaut. Was wird jetzt gerade in den Talkshows, die alle zurückgekehrt sind aus dem Sommerurlaub leider.
Warum haben die überhaupt uns jetzt noch mal Merkel mitgebracht? Nun, ich habe ein bisschen in die Clips rein geschaut. Was wird jetzt gerade in den Talkshows, die alle zurückgekehrt sind aus dem Sommerurlaub leider.
Und was wird da jetzt zu Ukraine gesagt? Und ich will es kurz zusammenfassen Das passiert da gerade.
Noch mal! Noch mal!
Mal.
Genau. Es ist eine sehr schöne Darstellung deines Satzes, für die es immer Tag I.
Genau. Mann, eine sehr schöne Darstellung deines Satzes, für die es immer Track I Man redet über ein Thema, als ob man nie darüber geredet hätte. Erst recht nicht gestern.
Man redet über ein Thema, als ob man noch nie darüber geredet hätte. Erst recht nicht gestern.
Als wenn ich Programmleiter wäre oder derjenige, der das am Ende ins System einspeist. Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ich würde einfach mal eine Sendung vom, sagen wir zwölf März nehmen und die statt der aktuellen spielen und mal gucken, ob es irgendjemand merken würde. Ich würde es mal probieren.
Jedenfalls war Merkel da und sie soll natürlich über Helmut Kohl sprechen und hat eine Anekdote mitgebracht.
Sie trifft zum Ersten Mal Kohl zu einem richtigen Gespräch, denn es soll wohl für sie nach oben gehen in der Partei.
Sie soll ein wichtiges Amt erhalten. Und diese Anekdote habe ich mitgebracht. Zum einen, weil sie amüsant ist, zum anderen auch, weil sie uns jetzt so ein bisschen dahin führt, wie man Politik auch verstehen kann.
Als wir dann zusammensaßen, hatte Helmut Kohl im Kern jedoch nur eine Frage an mich. Und die lautete Wie verstehst du dich mit anderen Frauen?
Er duzte ja, er duze ja andere gerne einfach so Und nun war ich verdutzt, erzählte etwas von Freunden der Tatsache, dass ich es in der Akademie der Wissenschaften in meiner Arbeitsgruppe außer der Sekretärin nur mit Männern zu tun gehabt hätte.
Und dass ich mit anderen Frauen genauso wenige und genauso viele Probleme und Gemeinsamkeiten hätte wie mit Männern.
Helmut Kohl genügte diese Auskunft augenscheinlich. Er fragte noch irgendetwas nach meinem zukünftigen Wahlkreis.
Dann war das Gespräch schnell beendet.
Offensichtlich hatte es ihn bestärkt, mich beim Bundespräsidenten als zukünftige Bundesministerin für Frauen und Jugend zur Ernennung vorzuschlagen.
Sie hatte sich auf alles vorbereitet. Man kann sich vorstellen, welche Fragen werden wohl kommen? Und er fragt nur Wie verstehe ich mich mit Frauen?
Was sie aber mit dieser Anekdote sagen will, ist natürlich, dass Helmut Kohl so ein Gespür hatte für etwas.
Natürlich hätte er sie jetzt löchern können, mit irgendwelchen Kompetenz fragen, Aber wahrscheinlich hat er ohnehin gewusst, dass sie sie beantworten kann. Und wahrscheinlich, dass sie besser Bescheid weiß über diese Fragen. Familienpolitische Fragen als er selbst.
Also was soll da jetzt gespielt werden? Also fragt er so etwas, um dann eine Antwort zu bekommen, die seinem politischen Gespür hilft, zu entscheiden Wer ist die Richtige auf dem Posten?
Hm. Am Ende weiß man ja immer nicht, ob da sowieso schon alles mögliche greift, Proporz usw oder man kommt gar nicht drum herum, sie dann und dann.
Am Ende weiß man ja immer nicht, ob da sowieso schon alles mögliche greift. Proporz usw. Ja.
Klopft man noch mal kurz ab, ob sie denn dann auch sich mit Frauenthemen überhaupt befassen möchte und wie sie sich mit Frauen versteht. Und dann legt sie es kurz ab.
Ja. Frauenthemen überhaupt befassen möchte. Und.
Kanzler der Wiedervereinigung. Das bedeutet, Merkel geht auf 89 ein.
Und sie macht hier etwas sehr deutlich, denn wir konnten den Satz anders sagen Wir haben gerade Pech.
Und damals hatte man Glück.
Angesichts des heutigen Krieges Russlands gegen die Ukraine können wir uns gar nicht glücklich genug schätzen, welch unglaubliche Konstellation der Weltgeschichte uns 1989 90 diese Entwicklung ermöglichte.
Glücklich genug. Welch unglaublich!
Es sind so verschiedene Dinge, die dann zusammenkommen damit, dass gerade diese Tür sich öffnet. Denn Helmut Kohl war ja einige Jahre vorher auch noch da.
Das wäre schön, wenn das so käme.
Aber wir haben diese Gegebenheiten nicht, also müssen wir mit was anderem arbeiten.
Merkel versucht jetzt mal festzumachen, wo wir gerade stehen.
Der Angriffskrieg Russlands und Präsident Putins gegen die Ukraine,
zerstört das Fundament all dessen, worauf sich die Staatengemeinschaft einschließlich der damaligen Sowjetunion und später Russlands im KSZE Prozess und in der Charta von Paris geeinigt hatte.
Das Fundament.
Vereinigte.
Das ist der Befund der jetzigen Lage. Aus diesem Befund gilt es nun, die im Wortsinne notwendigen Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen.
Aus diesem Befund gilt es nun, die im Wortsinne notwendigen.
Eine ungeheuer schwierige Aufgabe, das weiß ich sehr wohl.
Und sie versucht jetzt eine Frage zu stellen, die eigentlich, wie sie selbst sagt, unstatthaft ist oder die man nicht seriös beantworten kann. Nämlich Was würde Helmut Kohl heute tun?
Und da sagt sie Na ja, er ist ja jemand, der aus seiner Zeit heraus gehandelt hat. Deswegen lässt sich das eigentlich nicht so übertragen.
Aber wenn man so sieht, politischer Instinkt, Gespür, politische Klugheit dann natürlich auch den Moment erkennen, wo etwas geht.
Wenn das die Politik von Helmut Kohl ausmachte, dann lässt sich vielleicht doch etwas zu dieser Frage sagen. Und da fangen wir mal an!
Ich denke, Helmut Kohl würde heute auf der Grundlage der ihn kennzeichnenden drei Prinzipien nach der Zäsur, die der Beginn des Angriffskriegs Russlands gegen die Ukraine am 24.
Februar 2022 markiert, zum einen alles daran setzen, die Souveränität und die Integrität der Ukraine zu schützen und wiederherzustellen.
Daran kann es, so denke ich, keinen Zweifel geben. Ruft man sich in den Geist der eingangs erwähnten Tischrede mit ihren zitierten zwei Kernaussagen anlässlich des Honecker Besuchs in Bonn in Erinnerung.
Zugleich war Helmut Kohl ein Politiker, der in Fragen derartiger Tragweite, also in Fragen von Krieg und Frieden, von Unfreiheit und Freiheit, niemals den Tag danach aus dem Blick verlor.
Mehr noch, der diesen Tag immer mitmachte. Auf unsere heutige Zeit übertragen, so denke ich,
würde er neben der entschlossenen Unterstützung der Ukraine parallel immer auch das Moment, das im Moment so Undenkbare, schier Unvorstellbare mitnimmt.
Denken nämlich wie so etwas wie Beziehungen zu und mit Russland wieder entwickelt werden können.
Beides würde er natürlich niemals in einem deutschen Alleingang angehen, sondern nur im gemeinsamen Handeln mit unseren Partnern in der Europäischen Union und in der NATO.
Melnyk ist ja bei Twitter direkt ein bisschen nervös geworden aufgrund dieser Aussagen, oder wir sagen mal, ist wieder ausgeflippt, aber das ist ja so seine Masche inzwischen. Und er findet ja auch immer noch großen Zuspruch bei deutschen Medienhäusern.
Aber diese Vermessung des,
Cool Erbes und die Übertragung ist ja zunächst einmal sehr sinnvoll, die Merkel hier macht, indem sie sagt Wir haben zum einen natürlich die Unterstützung, die würde Helmut Kohl auch leisten.
Zum anderen aber muss der Tag danach mitgedacht werden. Und da bekommt man zumindest in der medialen Berichterstattung den Eindruck, dass es gar keinen Tag danach geben kann.
Genau Tag danach ist ja immer die Frage mit oder ohne Putin.
So und ich weiß nicht, ob sie hier selbst zu viel. Ähm.
Aktuelle Politik, wie sie gerade gemacht wird. Helmut Kohl über dümpelt so im Sinne von der hätte das auch so gemacht.
Also noch mal so eine eigentlich ein bisschen illegitime Legitimation, sich da einfach abholen aus so einem Na?
Einfach herausgelesen im Erbe, das so gar nicht drinsteckt. Denn wir wissen ja von Helmut Kohl.
Er hätte es ja vielleicht doch abwenden können im Sinne von Sein Tagesablauf, also seine Agenda pro Tag, begann ja immer damit, erst mal fünf sechs Parteimitglieder anzurufen, die Geburtstag haben.
Also erst mal ne halbe Stunde so fünf Minuten Gespräche zu führen, zu gratulieren, zu fragen wie geht's und so?
Und diese Entfremdung auf persönlicher Ebene zu Russland zum Beispiel wäre ihm vielleicht gar nicht passiert. Also wirklich im Sinne von.
Gut, das ist jetzt natürlich schwierig. Also sie würde jetzt mal sagen, das war halt diese unglaubliche historische, weltgeschichtliche Konstellation, die es ergeben hat.
Sie würde jetzt sagen, das war diese unglaubliche historische, weltgeschichtliche Konstellation, die es ergeben.
Und da war er dann auch noch der richtige Mann für ihn selbst, Angela Merkels Amtszeit, dass sich Putin da so was nicht getraut hat oder hätte.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja von selbst Angela Merkels Amtszeit, dass sich Putin da so was nicht getraut hat oder hätte.
Und dass auch Christoph Heusgen aus allen Wolken fiel, dass das plötzlich klar, man hätte jetzt im Nachhinein sagen können Ja, der Putin lag so auf Lauer und er wollte diesen Merkel ist nicht mehr da.
Moment, abwarten, weil er gewusst hätte Also Merkel muss nur mit dem Finger schnippen und die Allianz gegen ihn hätte gestanden weltweit, weil sie einfach diese Rolle hat.
Moment, abwarten, weil er gewusst hätte Also Merkel muss nur mit dem Finger schnippen und die Allianz gegen ihn hätte gestanden, dass sie einfach diese Rolle hat.
Und er setzte auf eine gewisse Schwäche von Olaf Scholz. Also er hat sozusagen so einen historischen Moment.
Und er setzte auf eine gewisse Schwäche von Olaf Scholz.
Und beiden noch dazu auch als Schwäche.
Und beiden genau so eine, so eine, so ein Schwachpunkt der Demokratien, dass sie nämlich einfach mal wirklich starke, durchsetzungsfähige und auch medial überzeugende Amtsführung oder einfach wenn die aussortiert werden,
dass man dann da in so eine Lücke springt.
Aber ich es wäre bestimmt so ein.
Großes, was man heute nicht sieht. Auch so ein großes Bedauern,
bei Helmut Kohl gewesen, dass man es auf persönlicher Ebene nicht verhindert hat, dass man da zu selten angerufen hat, dass jemand zu weit enteilt ist und man eigentlich noch mal hätte das Gespräch suchen sollen. Und diese Art?
Weil der auf. Weil der andere nicht wollte. Wir haben ja, Du hattest ja diesen Clip damals von Masha Gessen, die noch mal so schön sagte.
Das ist auch ein Resultat des Look Downs.
Also Putin hat sich völlig isoliert und hat dadurch auch niemanden an sich herangelassen und hat diese einsamen Entscheidungen gefällt.
Ich glaube, man kommt jetzt so ein bisschen man man hat fast den Eindruck, wenn wir darüber sprechen, wir sind noch in so einem royalen Modus.
Was hat die Queen gedacht und was denkt sie über Meghan? Aber wir haben das schon mehrmals deutlich gemacht.
In diesem Podcast würde sie ja auch noch mal sagen. Und deswegen ist dann auch so eine Anekdote gar nicht so blöde von Merkel, wie sie da auf Helmut Kohl trifft und befördert wird.
Nun, wir haben natürlich große wirtschaftliche Interessen, geopolitische Konstellationen, wir haben Gremien, die tagen, Experten, die beratschlagen.
Und so weiter. Aber es gibt auch diese direkte, persönliche Komponente, die du jetzt auch gerade meintest.
Wie oft hat man eigentlich telefoniert und Dinge ausgemacht?
Und diese Art des persönlichen Vertrauens, das ist ja das, was bei Helmut Kohl immer so gesagt wird, was er dann selbst zu Maggie Thatcher aufbauen konnte, weil er ihr erzählte Ich war heute Nachmittag am Grab von Churchill, da wollte ich immer mal hin.
Solche Dinge sind es dann, die plötzlich Weltpolitik entscheiden.
Das ist so verrückt, weil es auch diese unglaubliche Kontingenz in der Weltpolitik zeigt, weil es dann sich nicht einfach logisch oder teleologisch entfaltet, hin auf ein zielgerichtet.
Aber dass das eine wichtige Komponente ist, ist zweifellos gegeben.
Sieht man ja an Gerhard Schröder und Putin. Also das wäre undenkbar gewesen, dass Putin Schröder vor so ein Problem stellt, das sie jetzt als Bundeskanzler organisieren zu müssen, sondern die hätten da natürlich.
Das sieht man ja. Ja.
Putin Schröder vor so ein Problem stellt. Als Bundeskanzler? Ja.
Alle möglichen Wege gesucht. Und welche?
Dummerweise hat jetzt Schröder uns in das Problem weiter hineingeführt.
Richtig, Genau. Also es führt ein.
Das ist dann auch das Wo, wo der, wo die persönliche Bindung natürlich dann,
einen vergessen lässt, dass man auch eigentlich ja sein Land da vertritt und dessen Interessen und nicht nur schaut, was kann ich eigentlich danach noch Schönes machen, wenn ich nicht mehr Bundeskanzler bin?
Das ist natürlich dann genau dieser Kipppunkt, also wo man glaubt jetzt wir verstehen uns ja nur auf persönlicher Ebene.
Ach so, mit den Ländern, da ist mir egal. Und das ist genau diese Vergessenheit.
Und eigentlich hat das ja bei bei Schröder so eine, also mindestens eine doppelte, wenn nicht dreifache Konstellation.
Einmal so ich lasse die Sozialdemokratie hinter mir mit der Agenda 2010.
Ich trete auf und sage Hurra, wir haben den Niedriglohnsektor, wo man eigentlich sagt mir sind jetzt die Menschen nicht wichtig.
Ich habe hier als Bundeskanzler andere Aufgaben zu vertreten und dann noch mal so einen dritten Verrat, wenn man so möchte, zu sagen,
Ja, klar ist das sinnvoll, in einem guten Verhältnis zu Russland zu stehen, aber ich mach da jetzt so ein persönliches Verhältnis draus, dass ich davon ein großer Profiteur bin und denke gar nicht mehr darüber nach,
was das eigentlich für das Land bedeuten könnte, wenn diese Abhängigkeit so groß wird.
Ja, ich finde es sehr gut, dass Merkel diesen Punkt gemacht hat. Dieser Tag danach. Denn.
Das ist eine gute Erinnerung an Helmut Kohl im Sinne von Wenn man sie heute,
also sie wird ja heute vorgetragen, wenn man sie heute sozusagen so interpretiert, weil das ja der aktuellen Bundesregierung fehlt, also wir diese Sanktion auch, wie Ursula von der Leyen, der die Sanktionen bleiben.
Und da führt auch kein Weg dran vorbei, egal wie die Bevölkerung leidet und die leite da eben krass.
Also dass man da wirklich krass rücksichtslos vorgeht und diesen Tag danach gar nicht mitdenkt.
Schon allein, weil man schon diesen Tag, nicht nur den Tag danach, sondern schon diesen Tag, wo sich das mal ändern sollte.
Also Sieg, Niederlage, von wem auch immer. Selbst das wird ja gar nicht thematisiert, sondern man versucht nur den Zustand jetzt, da muss man auch sagen, so einem gewissen Demütigungen so lang wie möglich zu strecken, in der Hoffnung, dass sich dann schon irgendwas ergibt. Aber so richtig Zielsetzung hat man ja nicht.
Wir hören mal weiter, wenn es um die politische Klugheit geht.
Im Juni wurde ich in einem Zeitungsinterview gefragt Sie kennen Putin schon lange. Was ist er für ein Mensch?
Ich habe geantwortet, man sollte seine Worte ernst nehmen.
Und heute möchte ich angesichts der Entwicklungen der letzten Tage ergänzen, Worte ernst zu nehmen, sie nicht von vornherein damit abzutun, sie seien nur ein Bluff, sondern sich ernsthaft mit ihnen auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich wollte wirklich.
Ziemlich überfordert mit der Migrationswelle. Wenn man sich erst. Auseinanderzusetzen.
Das ist beileibe kein Zeichen von Schwäche oder Beschwichtigung, sondern ein Ausweis politischer Klugheit.
Wichtiger wäre ein.
Einer Klugheit, die dazu beiträgt, Handlungsspielräume zu erhalten oder mindestens so wichtig sogar neue zu erarbeiten.
Einer Gruppe, die dazu weiß. Handlungsspielräume zu erhalten.
Auch das ist noch mal ganz klar an die gerichtet.
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Aussage in der ganzen Rede, dass ja alle,
so von der ja, wir brauchen den Namen nicht nennen Sie kennen, sind ja weithin bekannt, dass wann immer jemand kommt und sagt Na ja, wir müssen aber schon aufpassen, dass wir nicht einen Atomkrieg bekommen,
und dann so gesagt wird na ja, der blufft und man denkt immer Ja, aber woher wollt ihr das wissen, dass der blufft?
Und wenn sie jetzt noch mal sagt, ich kenne den und die sollte man ernst nehmen. Und das ernst zu nehmen ist auch kein Zeichen von Schwäche.
Dann ist hier jemand, der das wirklich aus der direkten Erfahrung politisch ganz anders betrachten kann als irgendwelche Kolumnisten Schreiber.
Und ich finde das noch mal ganz entscheidend, dass sie das hier sagt.
Und das ist auch meine große Hoffnung. Ja, dass diese politische Klugheit, die Merkel hier beschreibt, bei Olaf Scholz, auch wenn es uns nicht immer so gleich erscheinen will, doch vorhanden ist.
Und mir scheint es, dass es da jedenfalls in der SPD am stärksten momentan vorhanden ist, die politische Klugheit angesichts dieser Bedrohung, die da ist.
Das ist eigentlich super interessant, weil wir ja schon sagen müssen Olaf Scholz hat es vor dem Kriegsbeginn wahnsinnig ernst genommen. Er ist zu beiden gefahren. Er hat.
Wann nimmt der Nord Stream in den Mund? Dieses ganze Theater ein bisschen ausgeblendet. Hat dann gewartet, bis er bei Putin war, um dann dort die Drohung auszusprechen. Dann ist Nordsee Geschichte. Und so weiter.
Heute denken wir Nachhinein. Na klar ist das dann Geschichte. Das muss man gar nicht noch sagen. Aber die Journalisten haben uns das ja so als Theater, Schauspiel und Drehbuch da hingestellt, dass wir irgendwie da auch ganz verpeilt waren.
Also die haben das alles ernst genommen und ich finde, genau wie du sagst, genauso ernst muss man heute auch nehmen, dass eben der Olaf Scholz, der das damals schon so ernst nahm, dass der Krieg wirklich droht und dann noch mal diese ganzen Reisen macht, auch damit rechnet, dass es wirklich zu Atomwaffen Einsatz kommt.
Und das sollte man auch ernst nehmen. Und jetzt schon wieder diese Häme, wenn man Precht hört in diesen kleinen Snippets.
Ich habe sie jetzt im Markus Lanz Podcast gehört dieses Jahr.
Würdest du heute noch mal anders über den Krieg reden als damals? Weil es ergibt sich ja jetzt eine andere Situation.
Ja klar, jetzt würde ich auch sagen kann man mit Waffen anders umgehen, weil man ja sieht, okay, so stark sind die Russen da gar nicht. Und so weiter.
Ja, aber das führt eben auch zu der Situation, dass man diese Häme darüber, dass Precht ja immer vor Atomwaffen gewarnt hat, dass man dem eigentlich näher gekommen ist, also dass man das eigentlich droht, dass,
man jetzt sagen muss na ja, der Brecht, er hat einfach, der ist ja völlig irre, der hat ja irgendwie mit Atomwaffen und so gelabert.
Dabei schaffen die es ja nicht mal, einen normalen Krieg zu führen. Und dann ja, genau deswegen wird es ja so gefährlich mit den Atomwaffen, weil der konventionelle.
Ja genau das, was Merkel sagt, also aufgrund der Entwicklung der letzten Tage.
Die Rede wurde ja vor zwei Tagen halten und das war jetzt aufgrund Generalmobilmachung, aufgrund der Niederlagen, dass sie sagt,
ich habe da mal so ein Interview gegeben vor zwei Monaten und habe da gesagt ja, wir müssen das sehr ernst nehmen, wenn Putin droht.
Und ich will das sogar noch mal ergänzen mit folgendem Das scheint so verrückt zu sein, dass das so eine randständige Position ist.
Also ich meine, wir beziehen uns hier auf den Bundeskanzler und auf die Bundeskanzlerin, die ehemalige.
Das ist jetzt nun wirklich nicht besonders subversiv, aber, aber es ist, es ist so, so absurd. Und ein letzter Gedanke, der auch mich etwas überrascht hat, ist folgender von Merkel.
Wenige wußten die Bedeutung politischer Klugheit so zu achten wie Helmut Kohl, der sein Amt 1982 in den dunklen Zeiten des Kalten Krieges antrat.
Übrigens der damals von vielen abgelehnte NATO Doppelbeschluss, für den er, wie auch sein Vorgänger Helmut Schmidt sich sehr einsetzte, hieß Doppelbeschluss.
Nun werde ich jetzt hier nicht zum Verteidiger eines NATO Doppelbeschluss, das ist auch gar nicht notwendig.
Aber die Überlegung noch mal hier der NATO Doppelbeschluss, der sagt,
wir rüsten zwar auf, aber das eigentliche Ziel ist, dass es dann eine Abrüstung, eine nicht weitere Aufrüstung von der anderen Seite gibt, sondern dass wir dann gemeinsam abrüsten und dass sich auch da eine geschichtliche Konstellation für genau das ergeben hat.
Das ist wirklich etwas, was man noch mal in anderer Weise betrachten muss.
Also wenn Sie das noch mal so betont. Doppelbeschluss Also das ist, momentan haben wir so diese wir gehen in diese eine Richtung und wir fragen nicht nach dem Tag danach und all das.
Aber wenn man den Doppelbeschluss sieht, als immer schon den Tag danach mitgedacht und eigentlich soll es dann generell eine Abrüstung geben. Wir gehen da noch mal den Weg, inwieweit das jetzt wirklich so wahnsinnig intelligent und alles, aber das brauchen wir nicht noch mal aufdröseln.
Aber dass man zumindest auf so eine Konstellation kommt, also wo man so eine Kipp Figur dann baut, das ist etwas, was wir momentan im Diskurs auch von diesen ganzen,
Militärexperten oder den meisten Militärexperten, die wir hören, überhaupt nicht erleben.
Und das ist schon dann erstaunlich, wie man da in den 80er Jahren war. Und klar, da gab es die Friedensbewegung, die sich aufgrund dessen ja erst mal erstarkt hat und die gegen diesen Doppelbeschluss war.
Aber vielleicht hat man doch immerhin sehen können, dass es grundsätzlich eine Idee auch der Abrüstung wiederum war.
Und da geht ja momentan gar nichts hin, sondern wir haben ja von allen Ländern und man sieht es ja an den Budgets, an den Entwicklungen nur Aufrüstung, und da ist überhaupt nicht mehr irgendwo diese Idee.
Und dann könnten wir, wenn wir so eine so ein Gleichgewicht haben, wieder abrüsten gemeinsam, dass das ist ja ein weiter, weiter Ferne.
Ja, finde ich auch auf Ebene der Sanktionen, die ja nun wirklich ein zivilgesellschaftlicher Eingriff ist.
Da ist ja wirklich das Ziel, die Volkswirtschaft zu zerstören.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man nicht von Anfang an wir haben es ja auch schon ein paar Mal thematisiert sagt,
okay, wir frieren Geld der Zentralbank ein, es bleibt aber russisches Geld und alle Oligarchen Vermögen, die wir ja einfrieren, werden minutiös bilanziert und stehen dann auch dem Tag danach Russland zur Verfügung.
Also hier wird nicht enteignet, sondern sozusagen dieses, dass man dieses Einfrieren einfach noch mal richtig ernst nimmt und ausformuliert, was das bedeutet, um damit auch ein Angebot zu machen, den zivilen Kräften, den es da in Russland gibt.
Und es werden ja Petitionen geschrieben und auch in die regionalen Parlamente eingebracht, dass man denen so ein bisschen Rückhalt gibt, eine Argumentations basis.
Wenn wir erst mal uns hier durchgesetzt haben und die Duma wird ja auch nicht drum herum kommen auf ihrer Tagesordnung, so Abberufung von Putin und so was dann zumindest ablehnen zu müssen.
Aber damit ist es Tagesordnungspunkt, dass man da so Argumentation dranhängen kann. Da haben wir gesagt Das ist.
Ich glaube auch, man kann. Also, wir haben ja gesagt, das ist eigentlich eine kluge Strategie oder eine.
Kluge Strategie oder eine.
Das ist eine Kriegsführung, die es seit über 100 Jahren gibt und die sicherlich die sinnvollere ist, also einen Wirtschaftskrieg zu führen oder auch ein Financial Warfare.
Das ist eine Kriegsführung, die es seit über 100 Jahren gibt und die sicherlich die sinnvollere ist, also ein Wirtschaftskrieg zu führen.
Financial warfare und dann muss aber eigentlich auch so NATO Doppelbeschluss mäßig das so mit drin sein, dass wenden dann muss da sein.
Und da muss aber eigentlich auch so ein NATO Doppelbeschluss mäßig das so mit drin sein, dass wenn, dann muss da sein.
Und ich habe momentan wirklich den Eindruck, es gibt so eine Phobie das zu denken. Also wir haben jetzt Männer, die aus Russland rauswollen.
Und ich habe momentan wirklich den Eindruck, es gibt so eine Phobie das zu denken. Also wir haben jetzt.
Männer, die aus Russland rauswollen. Die, die vor Krieg flüchten.
Die, die vor Krieg flüchten und wir haben eine Debatte darüber.
Ja, solche, die jetzt wirklich aufnehmen. Also Mik, der ja häufiger bei diesem Podcast zu Gast ist, hatte das so schön getwittert.
Er schrieb Wir sind nicht Herren über Leben und Tod, die Menschenrechte und Bedürfnisse wie zum Beispiel nicht sterben, jetzt an irgendwelche fraglichen Umfragen oder individuelle Moralvorstellungen zu koppeln.
Geht's noch? Manche deutsche Helden sollten mal Pause machen, wenn es so entmenschlicht.
Und das finde ich sowas von entsetzlich, dass man jetzt glaubt.
Also Leute, die vor Krieg fliehen, die nicht sterben wollen in einem Krieg und nicht kämpfen wollen und damit auch nicht andere töten wollen, dass man die jetzt nochmal extra befragen würde und sagen Ja und warst du denn vor zehn Jahren auch schon gegen Putin oder was?
Was sollen die denn da sagen? Na ja, offenbar sind die bereit, das Land zu verlassen. Das muss man ja erst mal machen, nur um dann zu kämpfen. Und dass das jetzt dann noch so getan wird.
Also es gibt ja auch jetzt diese Also wir haben die ganze Zeit über Verschwörungstheorien gesprochen und haben viel gelacht auch hier.
Aber jetzt wird plötzlich aus allem so eine russische Verschwörung gemacht. So ne, das sind eigentlich dann Putins Trolle, die sind dann nur hier und nisten sich dann ein.
Also ja, da. Mag sein, dass da auch irgendjemand dann auf diesem Wege. Aber jetzt haltet doch mal bitte die Füße still.
Genauso wo jetzt immer gesagt wird bei bei bei jeder Meldung ja, da ist jemand auf Putin Propaganda reingefallen und so würde ich sagen, na ja, wir können auch noch von mündigen Subjekten bisweilen ausgehen.
Das finde ich ehe. Das wir das in Deutschland wirklich nicht reflektieren wundert mich.
Entweder wir unterstellen Putin, er ist der Böse, er zwingt seinem Land über Propaganda und was auch immer diesen Bereich autokratisch muss, den wir ja in dem Buch auch nachgelesen haben, auf.
Oder wir erklären das ganze Volk zum Tätervolk. Wir haben uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt. Nein, Putin, es ist Putin, der ist das Problem.
Man kann auch Russland anders regieren. Und wir kennen auch Wege, da von außen unterstützend tätig zu sein, in welchem begrenzten Rahmen auch immer. Aber.
Hat der Unterstützer, der ist nicht umsonst da. Aber es ist nicht das Volk identisch mit Putin. Und ich will noch eine Sache machen. Zum einen sagt man, Putin hat mit seiner Propaganda das ganze Land im Griff.
Also es wird gesagt, seit Jahren gibt es ja eigentlich keine freie Presse mehr.
Seit Jahren führt Putin seinen Infokrieg und steuert das Volk mit mit Fehlinformationen.
Und dann muss man ja sagen ja, dann sind ja offenbar die Bürger ideologisch verblendet dadurch und das wird sich auch so wiederfinden. Und da werden auch viele sagen Ja dann, nee, das ist kein Krieg, das ist eine Militäroperation.
Aber wie will man dann zugleich wiederum von den Bürgern dann erwarten, die dann jetzt sagen Oh Gott, ich habe Angst zu sterben, ich fliehe, dass die natürlich jetzt.
Den westlichen Liberalismus, ohne dass sie je mit ihm richtig in Berührung kamen, im Fernsehen oder so inhaliert haben und jetzt sofort hierhin kommen und sagen ich würde gerne Mitglied bei den Grünen werden oder was? Also was soll denn da sein?
Also es reicht doch, wenn Männer sich entscheiden, für ein Land nicht sterben zu wollen. Was will man dann noch? Und ich bin da wirklich ganz entsetzt darüber, dass das überhaupt als Thema ist.
Ich würde ja eher sagen ja, je mehr aus einem Land fliehen, das kennen wir ja noch aus anderen Ländern wie zum Beispiel DDR oder so, ja,
also wo Leute fliehen aus einem Land, dann ist das für das Land immer scheiße, aus verschiedenen Gründen und und das ist unser.
Also damit können wir ja richtig wuchern mit diesem Pfund, wenn wir sagen, also wir haben jetzt ja schon 100.000 Russen, sind schon hier bei uns und die fühlen sich auch gut und wohl.
Überlegt euch das auch mal, ob ihr noch kommen wollt.
Sehr gute Punkte. Wir werden es im Salon aufgreifen. Es gibt Text Grundlagen zur demografischen Problemlage Putins.
Nicht nur das viele flüchten, sondern wenn man die ganze Leute in so ein Pflichtjahr Krieg schickt, entzieht man sie auch dem erwerbsfähigen Potenzial.
Und wenn es dann gerade die 18 bis 27 jährigen sind, ist natürlich Katastrophe vorprogrammiert, was das angeht.
Und zu dem, was du eben noch meintest Ja, es sind Wir haben uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt.
Die Bevölkerung ist ein Propaganda Opfer von Putin und wenn die meinen, sie müssen jetzt vor Krieg flüchten, sollten wir ihnen genau den Kulturschock bieten, nämlich aus dieser Propaganda Szenerie raus bei uns mal rein.
Heißt natürlich auch wir müssen den dann ein Angebot machen. Wir stellen ja gerade fest, dass sich selbst die Ukrainer nicht besonders wohl in Deutschland fühlen und sagen Ich weiß, da ist es noch Krieg zu Hause, aber ich gehe lieber schon mal zurück,
denn da ist dann doch mehr Lebensaufgabe für mich als hier in Deutschland, obwohl man hier mittlerweile ja arbeiten darf und so, es ist ja noch eine etwas privilegierter Stellung, als wenn jetzt aus Syrien oder Afghanistan geflüchtet wird.
Aber das wirft uns doch auch nochmal auf uns zurück mit der Frage Welches Angebot können wir denn den Russen eigentlich machen hier vor Ort, wenn sie ganz konkret kommen? Und darüber hinaus?
Welches Angebot können wir den Russen eigentlich machen gegen Putin? Und diese Frage steht unbeantwortet im Raum.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel. Wir haben letztes Jahr auch über Ursula von der Leyens State of the Union gesprochen.
Damals hat sie nämlich das Jahr der Jugend ausgerufen für 2022 und die EU Gelder verteilt diese 750 Milliarden Pandemie.
Hilfe, von denen wir heute wissen, ja, die werden jetzt gerade ausgezahlt, an Italien zum Beispiel.
Und die sind auch extrem abhängig davon, dass diese Gelder fließen. Wir kommen nachher drauf zurück.
Ursula von der Leyen war also wieder im Parlament und hat dort gesprochen. Und man muss sagen ja, es war nicht sehr voll, und zwar nicht Krone bedingt, sondern irgendwie so richtig zieht es nicht.
Was schade ist, denn ich will jetzt nicht überschwänglich in diese Rede reingehen, aber es sind doch so ein paar Sätze gefallen und wir werden das nachher koppeln mit Olaf Scholz vor der UN.
Man muss ja nicht dort das sagen, was sie jetzt ankündigt und sagt, sondern ich hätte ja alles sagen können. Aber sie hat sich dafür entschieden.
Und Olaf Scholz wollte seine Rede verstecken. Sie fand keinen Anklang.
Seine 17 Minuten vor der UN. Hier ist es ein bisschen schade, dass wir Ursula von der Leyen nicht gehört haben. Aber wir hören uns langsam warm.
Zuerst einmal geht es um ihre Bewunderung darüber, wie schnell Europa zu Solidarität gefunden hat, als Putin die Ukraine angriff, während es ja bei anderen Krisen anders war. Und da würde ich sagen na mal den Winter noch abwarten.
From that very moment European snider hit No it they found the courage to do the right thing,
and from that very moment our union as a hole has to the occasion.
15 years ago during the financial crisis.
As years to find last thing solutions a decade later when the global hit ad hoc as only weeks.
Ja unterwegs zu wir machen jetzt mal dies und jenes Sanktions Paket und jetzt sehen wir gerade, wie wir uns auch selber mit in den Fuß schießen.
Und da würde ich sagen mal die Energie Preisentwicklung abwarten den Winter. Ob dann die große Einigkeit, wie sie hier von ihnen auch propagiert ist, da ist oder vielleicht nicht,
sie wird so ein bisschen pathetisch. Mut kennt einen oder hat einen neuen Namen. Es ist die Ukraine.
Und darin steckt aber dieses etwas verlogene Argument. Wir haben es schon ein paarmal gebracht, wir müssen es ja auch noch mal anbringen, weil das auf so prominenter Bühne so pathos überladen dargeboten wurde.
Today courage has the name and that name is you crane.
Courage has a face. And that face is the face of you can man women were standing up to the russian aggression.
Face to face of.
Wir haben es schon ein paarmal thematisiert. Wir schicken Material in die Ukraine, damit die dort auch unsere Freiheit mit verteidigen.
Und wir haben sehr gute Argumente, keine Soldaten hinzuschicken, also nicht unsere eigene Biomasse zu gefährden, weil dann werden wir ja Kriegspartei und das wollen wir nicht. Und?
Deswegen sagt Habermas Wir sitzen immer nur auf den Zuschauerrängen. Das ist aber ein echtes Problem, weil wir die Ukrainer damit auch ein bisschen im Stich lassen. Genau.
Immer nur auf den Zuschauer. Ja, genau. Und das ist aber ein echtes Problem, weil wir die Ukrainer damit auch ein bisschen im Stich lassen, muss man einfach sagen.
Denn da gibt es unendlich viele Todesfälle und Leid. Und an dem beteiligen wir uns nicht, sondern wir.
Da gibt es unendlich viele Todesfälle und Leid. Und an die beteiligen wir uns nicht, sondern wir senden schöne Sätze.
Genau und kippen Material hinterher. Damit dieser Krieg auch lange hart gefochten wird.
Als ich jetzt Richard David Precht hörte, wie er da auf Lanz reagierte und meinte, ja, heute würde ich anders über den Krieg reden als damals.
Direkt danach war ich nämlich auch überrascht, bin davon, wie schwach die zweitgrößte Armee der Welt Russlands aufgestellt ist.
Da würde ich sagen, wir haben bisher noch nicht ganz verstanden und es ist auch uns noch nicht gezeigt worden, wie groß die bemühen.
Zum Beispiel im Pentagon waren diese historische Gelegenheit, Russland zu besiegen und auch in einem echten Krieg zu bekämpfen, genutzt wurde.
Man darf sich darüber natürlich öffentlich nicht freuen und da gibt es auch keine Lorbeeren einzusammeln. Das würde ja alles sozusagen zu diesem Gesichtsverlust Problemen.
Zufügen. Aber ich glaube, da ist noch so eine ungeschriebene Geschichte, dass man sich das noch mal genau anschauen muss.
Die Unterstützung ist immens, die Unterstützung und Unterstützung ist immens und es wird so ein bisschen verdeckt. Mit hat Deutschland schon das und das geliefert.
Aber da wir ja gemeinsam mit den Verbündeten alles machen, ist es ja abgestimmt.
Und dann gibt es natürlich immer solche Nickeligkeiten.
Wer hat jetzt mehr und was und so? Aber natürlich ist da schon eine extrem Macht dass ja nicht so, als hätte jetzt das kleine Land das nur für sich geregelt, sondern es gab diese große Unterstützung.
Und ich finde auch diese Sätze so wohlfeil, die zu sagen ja, Mut hat einen Namen usw und wir sehen in die Gesichter, ja in die Gesichter, da kann man bald nicht mehr sehen, weil die dann auch getötet sind. Und das sind dann einfach da.
Da zeigt sich dann auch wieder rum, so klar, dass wir es jetzt schon mit einer Politik zu tun haben, die.
Sagt wir halten unsere Leute da raus. Aber wenn ihr das da macht, dann finden wir das wunderbar.
Aber wir sind damit natürlich in der Konstellation.
Wenn wir diesen Satz da ernst nehmen, die sterben auch für unsere Freiheit, dann kann man das auch aktiver formulieren. Die lassen wir für unsere Freiheit dann sterben.
Also man kann nicht das, das wir. Also ich weiß, dass der Krieg ja nicht aufzulösen ist, ganz leicht, sondern.
Und der Aggressor ist der andere. Da können wir nicht einfach sagen wir, wir schrauben das runter, sondern der andere ist der Aggressor.
Nur wir kommen da in einer ganz, ganz heikle Sache an, die überdeckt wird mit so blumigen Formulierungen, wo man sagen muss Nein, da das.
Das ist nicht einfach dieser Heroismus, so der, der, der da heraufbeschworen wird, und da sind,
sehr, sehr kalte Machtinteressen dann dahinter, die auf Kosten von Menschen gehen, die da und das sind in dem Sinne, in dem in dem Falle Ukrainer, die dann da sterben.
Und wie gesagt, glaube, wir überbetonen den Heroismus der Ukrainer und wir unterbelichteten unsere Kriegsbeteiligung.
Genau. Wir überbetonen den Heroismus der Ukrainer und wir unterbelichtet unsere Kriegsbeteiligung.
Es gehört aber auch dieser Spruch Die Wahrheit stirbt immer zuerst im Krieg dazu.
Gehört aber auch dieser Spruch Die Wahrheit stimmt.
Dazu. Es ist ganz wichtig für die Art der Kriegsführung, dass der Tenor glatt ist Wir unterstützen zu wenig, weil ansonsten werden russische Reaktion.
Es ist ganz wichtig für die Art der Kriegsführung, dass der Tenor gerade ist Wir unterstützen zu wenig, weil ansonsten wäre die russische Reaktion wahrscheinlich auch eine andere unterstützen würde.
Aber auch wenn wir mehr unterstützen würden, also das muss man auch ganz klar sagen, auch wenn wir, wenn wir doppelt so viel liefern würde oder zehnmal so viel.
Das muss man auch ganz klar sagen, auch wenn der Sender doppelt so viel liefern würde oder zehnmal so viel.
Wir kommen aus der Konstellation nicht raus, dass das andere da machen. Also wir haben das outgesourct, wenn man so möchte. Also wir sind nicht aus Gründen.
Wir kommen aus der Situation nicht raus, dass das andere da machen. Also wir haben das outgesourct, also wir sind nicht aus Gründen.
Sonst könnte ein dritter Weltkrieg drohen oder so, zum Beispiel nicht daran beteiligt.
Dort könnte ein dritter Weltkrieg drohen oder so, zum Beispiel nicht daran beteiligt, aber natürlich auch, weil das sehr schlecht zu verkaufen ist in Ländern wie Deutschland, dass wir aktiv da reingehen.
Aber natürlich auch, weil das sehr schlecht zu verkaufen ist in Ländern wie Deutschland, dass wir aktiv da reingehen.
Wir sehen das Afghanistan Debakel und da würden wir jetzt hier es auch mit viel mehr deutschen Opfern zu tun haben. Also tausende deutsche Soldaten sterben in einem solchen Krieg.
Wir sehen das Afghanistan Debakel und da würden wir jetzt hier es auch mit viel mehr deutschen Opfern zu tun haben.
Und deutsche Soldaten sterben in einem solchen Krieg.
Nehmen wir mal an, man würde den über so einen ganz klassischen Weg führen können und wir klammern mal diese Atomwaffen Geschichte aus.
Man würde den über so einen ganz klassischen Weg führen können und man mal diese Atomwaffen geschickte aus.
Das wäre ganz schwer verkaufbar und nun wirklich auch nicht wünschenswert. Und insofern sourcen wir die Soldaten Tode, um das ganz drastisch zu sagen out.
Das wäre ganz schwer verkaufbar und nun wirklich nicht wünschenswert. Und insofern so sind wir die Soldaten, wurde, um es ganz drastisch zu sagen, aus, es ist eine ganz normale europäische Wirtschaft rein, die da stattfindet.
Europäische Wirtschaft, in der stattfindet? In gewisser Weise schon.
Irgendwo arbeiten 50 Sklaven für uns in der Hinsicht Das alte Modell noch mal durchgepeitscht.
Ursula von der Leyen übertreibt so ein bisschen. Sie hat die First Lady.
Sie lenski da und betont noch mal die großen Leistungen. Und ich würde sagen, dann fasst es Häuserkampf ist.
We are the First Lady. Leading a silent crowd of heart. Broken mothers and fathers.
And Hank small bells in the twice one for every fallen child.
And now this bells will ring for ever in the wind. Forever.
Die Innocent Victims of this war will live in our memories.
And yes, cheese here with us today. My dear Olena Slenczka ed took immens courage to resist Putin's cruel tie but you found the courage.
Weil wir voller Vertrauen sind. Äthiopien hat Polizisten die Zuflucht. Bei 500. Animate schonungslos als bis.
Eine nation of heroes has wisdom.
Today New Crane stand strong because I need tired country has fourth street by street and house by house and we are singing in the last days the brave very of the Ukraine is playing of.
Zudem verfolgt Sievers einen Teil der Wall Street Wall Street, von Haus aus viele Brise.
Ja. Naja, gut.
Er. Ja, das ist schon ganz erstaunlich. Da hat aber auch jemand sehr viele Marvel Filme geguckt und.
Ja, also sie referiert auch viel. Dann noch mal, wie Salewski ihr berichtet, wie das so im Schulalltag ist, weil man den Kindern morgens nicht nur, dass die Brot Büchse für den Tag füllt, sondern auch noch schon mal denkt was wäre, wenn sie es heute nicht nach Hause schaffen?
Und man sagt noch so ein paar Tage vor und so alles rührselig. Wahrscheinlich zu Recht da angebracht, aber eben auch auf so einer etwas komischen Ebene, sie da so im Parlament darüber reden zu hören.
Dann geht sie allerdings ins Eingemachte. Wir wissen ja der EU, also die EU hat über alle Staatsführer usw der Ukraine die Solidarität und auch die EU Mitgliedschaft angeboten.
Das ist ja vor allem dann auch Olaf Scholz ist Coup gewesen. Und dann kam gleich die Reaktion.
Das wird aber noch Jahrzehnte dauern und so und das er EU Mitgliedschaft eigentlich bedeutet ist ja Teilnahme am EU Binnenmarkt.
Und da war sie, wollte sie ein bisschen kurzen Prozess machen.
Der Kommission will work with you crane to go a step further and two and sure a samples.
Denn Kommission will die. Du steht fest. Oh, diese Glocken, Ey! Das ist wirklich.
Access to the single market of the European Union our single market is one of Europe the great to success stories we know the power that las like a single market to know it is time.
In Buenos Aires.
Genau das. Zum Ende des.
To make it a success story for your friends two,
and this is why today.
I'm going to Kiew to diskus all this with president the lansky and to show him what the single market is as a potential for Ukraine the future.
Also. Stimmt es, dass?
Schon dem Single market is.
Denn wir wissen ja, im EU Binnenmarkt geht es allen Ländern prächtig, die mitmachen, vor allem Deutschland oder vor allem vor allem Deutschland.
Denn wir wissen ja, im EU Binnenmarkt geht es allen Ländern prächtig. Richtig. Vor allem dort.
Also EU Binnenmarkt ist deswegen immer wieder interessant, weil das eben diese immensen Reichtümer sind, die da plötzlich eine Rolle spielen. Und wir wissen, dass die EU nur aus Agrarsubventionen besteht und sonst fast nichts. Alles weitere.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Das sollte mal echt ein Journalist aufgreifen und mal beschreiben, was das.
Also was das bedeutet, wie viel Umverteilung der Subventionen das dann so mit sich bringt zu dem es ist eben auch ein großes Land, da kommen dann wieder 40 Millionen Menschen.
Also je nach Migrationsfrage, die dann auch wirklich diese Freizügigkeit genießen.
Kommt ja alles so in die Waagschale und ist ja dann auch 80 90 % der eigentlichen Bedeutung von EU Mitgliedschaft.
Das ist ja ein bisschen wie die Schotten, die jetzt sagen, wir wünschen uns jetzt wirklich den Abgang aus dem Vereinigten Königreich, aber die Queen als Staatsoberhaupt kann ruhig bleiben.
Das ist die Botschaft, wo man sich denkt Ach so, ja genau, stimmt, Ihr wollt ja nur alles andere mit der Queen.
Das ist ja dann nur noch so Kür und so ist das ja hier auch. Ob man es dann EU Mitgliedschaft nennt oder nicht.
Wenn der Binnenmarkt offen ist, dann ist bedeutet das für alle was.
Na ja, mal sehen, wie die politische Diskussion da läuft, denn es soll ja vor allem.
Kommen aber dann hoffentlich auch sofort eine Schuldenbremse. Das wird ja dann auch drohen.
Ja, also, da wird natürlich dann.
Also die hatten ja jetzt schon zu wenig Geld. Das ist ja auch. Wir unterstützen, Wenn wir über Unterstützung in deutschen Talkshows reden, dann meinen wir Waffen, siehe Lenski.
Diese Regierung hat eine ganz hat ja immer wieder Probleme, weil die natürlich einen Krieg an der Backe haben, der extrem teuer ist, was auch sonst. Und natürlich kommt sehr viel weniger rein.
Und es war ja so, dass man da dringend Hilfe von der EU brauchte und man dann von der EU gesagt hat Ja, August ist jetzt gerade schlecht, wir sind gerade im Urlaub.
Wir kümmern uns dann danach darum. Also ich will das noch mal deutlich machen Wir reden die ganze Zeit über Unterstützung der Ukraine.
An dem Finanziellen wird das am Ende ganz stark festzumachen sein.
Also wir werden diese Debatten, wir werden die wahrscheinlich hier noch führen, wenn die keiner mehr führt.
Das wird dann nämlich sein ja, EU hat sich noch mal händeringend noch mal irgendwie durchringen können, noch mal so 5 Millionen für Bildung in der Ukraine auszugeben.
Aber mehr war da nicht und so und dafür hat man eine halbe Schule gebaut.
Also das wird genau in diese Richtung laufen.
Und da ist aber dann nicht mehr jeden Abend Talkshow zu.
Wir brauchen jetzt einfach eine Ernte von denen. Also Binnenmarkt heißt einem auch wirklich kurzer Weg, kurze Erträge, nicht so viel Bürokratie, denn am Ende Binnenmarkt.
Ja, übernehmt einfach wie jedes andere EU Land natürlich die Gesetzgebung wie sie ist.
Es gilt dann alle Schlichtung und Juristerei. Nein,
ausgehend von Brüssel oder so und dann schauen wir mal, aber,
es ist halt schon so eine materielle Aneignung, muss man auch irgendwie sagen, weil in dem Moment, wo man die Ukraine in den europäischen Binnenmarkt aufnimmt, zieht man sie natürlich auch aus den anderen Wirtschaft Zusammenhängen raus.
Gerade was die Versorgung Afrikas und so weiter angeht.
Ursula von der Leyen macht hier mal einen ganz kurzen Sprung vom Der Gasmarkt funktioniert nicht mehr zur Klimakrise. Das finde ich ja gut, dass man zu verkoppeln, denn wir blenden ja gerade Klimakrise so ein bisschen aus, dass wir jetzt wieder 17 % mehr Kohle verfeuern als letztes Jahr.
Wird ja gar nicht so groß thematisiert, weil ne, muss ja alles sein, auch das mit den Atomkraftwerken.
Da sind bei ihr die Wege zwischen dem Problem so ein bisschen kürzer.
To figures that I interesting last year Russian gas account for 14 percent of our important gas today its down to 9 %.
Alle Importe. Today ist dann zu.
But we also see that Russia keeps aktives eating our energy market I mean tai prefer to flare the ghost instead of setting it to Europe according to the contract that are.
Schrecklich. Es ging.
Ein Investor sollte mehr bedacht sein, Dinge zu.
So this market is not function anymore.
So macht es Not.
In addition The climate crisis is heavenly waiting in our builds.
An den. Meine Praxis ist Heavenly Way.
So über die Klimakrise kann sie natürlich hier dann einfach ein bisschen ausholen, weil erneuerbaren Energien das ist ja dann zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe, also Resilienz und Klimaschutz.
Aber am Ende dieses kleinen Klimaschutz Segments, von dem wir uns einfach vorstellen können, wie er so abläuft, kommt sie dann wieder zurück aufs Gas.
On the other hand, we have to entre global competitive ness the security of the play because the gas still has to come to the European Union the energy overall on the other hand of that's to expansive.
Welcher Idiot hatte dieses? Das war die Kunst. The Gastel hat to come to the European Union die.
It is our global competitive mess.
Es.
So we will developer with the member states a set of measures to take into to account the specific nature of our relationship with supply as.
Wohl kaum, dass Pacific Nature of Our Relation. Religion, vor allem Liebe.
Changing from unbreakable supplier Russia to.
Facebook Friends.
Able friends such as our norwegian friends for example.
Na also. Erneuerbare Energien schön und gut. Vielleicht ab 2025 oder so, aber bis dahin sollen dann die LNG Boote doch noch zu uns fahren.
Aber wir werden auch noch mal eine Liste aufführen. Wir wissen jetzt gerade, das kommt aus Katar und wir sind uns da auch bewusst, dass es da nicht gut läuft. Aber soll man trotzdem zu uns fahren?
Man führt so eine Klassifizierung ein für Ja, wir wissen schon, es ist irgendwie blöd, aber soll man trotzdem her fahren? Also das ist so, naja, diese typische Verlogenheit.
Am Ende muss man die Wirtschafts Konkurrenzfähigkeit dann aufrecht erhalten Europas und kann nicht durch zwei Jahre Düsternis gehen um zu glauben, danach könne man mit erneuerbaren Energien jetzt alles wieder aufbauen.
Wir sprechen ja noch über Aserbaidschan heute.
Zum Beispiel. Da kommt ja dann alles zusammen. Sie erinnert an die Ölkrise von vor 50 Jahren und möchte einen Fehler vermeiden.
Have century ago. In the 19 Seventies The world fake another for sexual crisis.
Some of us remember the call free weekend to save energy.
Jetzt We keep driving on the same road.
We did not get with of our defence oil and worse.
Fossile Fouls where even massivs this was wrong, not just for the climate, but all of public finance and for independence as we know today and with still playing the price for that.
Only a few vision is understand that the real problems problem with the fossil fouls that is not their price and among them world danish friends.
Und wie sieht denn Max started to invest into the power of the Wind?
We late the foundation for the global leadership in the sector and created tens of us of new jobs.
This is the way to go.
Und das ist The Way, den die CDU nicht gegangen ist.
Sie spricht ja hier aus ihrer eigenen Partei heraus, in den Siebzigern.
In den Siebzigern. Also der Club of Rome kommt und spricht von den Grenzen des Wachstums. Und die stellen fest Ganz schön teuer, dieses Öl.
Also der Club of Rome kommt und spricht von den Grenzen des Wachstums. Und ich stelle fest Ganz schön teuer, dieses Öl.
Na, dann subventionieren wir es mal und gehen den Weg weiter. Es ist ja auch Sie beschreibt eigentlich die große Dummheit.
Ja, dann subventionieren wir es mal und gehen den Weg weiter. Es ist ja auch sie beschreibt ja eigentlich die große Dummheit, das damals gemacht haben verspricht uns jetzt, ja jetzt machen es gerade anders, während sie gleichzeitig vor fünf Minuten erst sagte Ja, aber die Boote brauchen wir dann doch noch mal, die das Gas liefern. Jetzt also.
Ja, macht es doch und verspricht uns, dass sie alles machen kann. Anders, Während sie gleichzeitig vor fünf Minuten erst sagte Ja, aber die Boote brauchen wir dann doch noch mal!
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich habe noch nicht diese große Investitionsoffensive gesehen.
Wir sehen mal die eine oder andere kleinere Summe und damit kann man auch das eine oder andere Windrad bauen.
Aber heute, als ich hier losfuhr, schon wieder, war ich auf 180, als ich sah die Bahn wird teurer. 4,9 % glaube ich, wegen Inflation. Und dann denke ich mir, das ist die große Verkehrswende.
Also ich sehe das nicht.
Ich kann ja verstehen, dass man nicht sagt ab sofort, dass das vielleicht drei Jahre was dauert, Aber dass ich wie gesagt, da bin ich ja vollkommen pessimistisch.
Also Bahn Preise müssen natürlich rapide sinken, denn das muss dann vom.
Also Bahnreise müssen einfach sinken, um schon den Verkehr einfach von der Straße weg zu leiten.
Das ist dann in die Bahn geht. Das sollten wir als Angebot nehmen, dass wir zumindest eine Möglichkeit haben, von langen Autofahrten abzusehen. Gerade Intercity Verbindungen sind ja mit dem Zug auch viel schneller zu machen. Sie sind halt nur teuer.
Das allerdings würde ja bedeuten, irgendwer anders muss den Ticketpreis bezahlen.
Könnte ja eine staatliche Aufgabe sein.
Jetzt wissen wir, wer da im Wege steht, nämlich zum Beispiel Andreas Jung mit seinem Gestammel zur Schuldenbremse usw Da haben wir ja vorhin gehört, bei Ursula von der Leyen klingt das alles ganz anders.
Ist wirklich erstaunlich. Vielleicht sollten wir Deutsche, weil sie eine Deutsche ist und aus dieser CDU kommt uns das wirklich noch mal besonders anhören, was sie jetzt hier sagt.
Sie möchte nämlich eine neue EU Finanzpolitik oder sie möchte überhaupt mal eine EU Finanzpolitik und nicht einfach nur irgendwo in den Verträgen steht irgendwas drin.
Da hat sie sich ja auch völlig zu Recht noch mal angemerkt, die Maastricht Kriterien 60 % aus dem Hut gezaubert an den Haaren herbei.
Da gibt es keine irgendeine Kalkulation, die das irgendwie absichert, akademisch oder rational oder sonst irgendwie, sondern man hat einfach so gewürfelt und kam dann auf 60 %. Schuldenquote sei irgendwie so ein gesunder Wert.
Sie möchte das alles mal zur Diskussion stellen.
The future of our children. Let's both that we invest in sustainability.
Diese Box. Seit sie in West. In. Sensibilität.
But also that we invest sustainable to have to a knowledge a new reality of.
Bei mir in West Sustainable. So habe ich.
Diese Sprünge im Video sind übrigens original im Material der Europäischen Union. Es ist irgendwo klemmt es da.
Hat man nicht besser hinbekommen.
Of higher public debt We need fiscal rules that allow for strategic investment.
Die.
Darauf. Kritik im besten.
While safe guard. Fiscal sustainability.
So Strategic Investment Mind sowie auch von den Grünen vorgeschlagen.
Wenn man nicht verkonsumiert, sondern wirklich in etwas Neues investiert, darf man die Schuldenbremse einfach ignorieren.
Das hat sie hier nochmal betont, diese grüne Idee aufgegriffen und dann gesagt Financial Sustainability, das ist halt das, was die CDU dann so will. Dieses Zugeständnis soll man ja machen, aber halt eine sehr viel offener formulierte Schuldenbremse Regelung.
Rules that of fit for the challenges of this dekade. An der vollen Oktober We welcome for with new ideas for economic governance.
Challenges of.
Oktober. Welcome forward with my news. For Economic Governance.
Let me few Basic Principles with you.
So im Oktober wird sie eine finanzpolitische Rahmengesetzgebung andeuten.
Wir können jetzt alle schon mal, für uns ist das dann die nächste Ausgabe.
Wir können ja alle mal darauf achten, was wir jetzt im deutschen Journalismus davon geliefert bekommen, wenn diese Vorschläge kommen.
Die EU versteht es natürlich auch gut, dann keine Pressekonferenz zu machen, sondern ein PDF hochzuladen, was dann wieder keiner sieht und so, aber mal gucken, ob wir da jetzt im Oktober 1 Diskussion bekommen.
Müssen sich jetzt die deutschen Steuerzahler Sorgen machen? Werden sie noch mehr zur Kasse gebeten für das Bürokratiemonster EU?
Es ist euer. Richtig. Richtig, Richtig, Richtig.
Genau. Wie teuer wird's denn, Ursula? Und so?
Ganz genau. Aber sie hat ja angekündigt, hier kurz mal ein paar Punkte aufzuzählen. Macht sie hier.
Member states should have more flexibilität on their debt reduction path.
Der Should be more accountability on the delivery of what we have a great on there should be simple rules that all can follow.
To open the space for strategic investments, we needed and to give the financial markets the confidence they need.
So leaders chart once again a joint way forward with more freedom to invest. That's necessary.
Mosquito on the process. What has been a great has to be done more ownership by member states and better results for the citizens.
So in short Let's read discover the Maastricht spirit stability and growth can only go. Hand in Hand.
Offenbar jetzt gemerkt, dass die Schuldenbremse eine Wachstumsbremse wird.
Es ist eine Wachstumsbremse. Das ist ein sehr guter Vorschlag, es genau so zu nennen. Die Schuldenbremse ist eine Wachstumsbremse, und wir sind in Europa.
Wenn man jetzt die kollektive Verschuldung aller Länder nimmt, bis hin auf die kommunalen Ebene, haben wir so einen Schuldenstand von 68 % im Vergleich zur Wirtschaftskraft.
Wir wissen aus Amerika 120 oder so, Japan 250.
Also da ist noch Spiel nach oben, da sind Billionen, die man noch bewegen kann. Ohne dass hat sie ja betont, dass irgendein Investor dann glauben müsste Oh, das funktioniert aber dann künftig nicht mehr.
Man muss es einfach nur mit neuen Formulierungen in Gesetzen absichern.
Und dann ist auch klar da droht nichts. Auch Italien muss man jetzt nicht wieder 4 % abverlangen.
Die fallen genauso wenig aus bei 4 % wie bei 1 % und dann nimmt man einfach 1 %. Das muss dann auch reichen für so einen Investor in der Hinsicht.
Ich sehe auch eine Aufgabenstellung für die Europäische Zentralbank, dass man jetzt wirklich diese Wege geht und auch ein politisches Mandat hinterher schiebt und nicht nur Inflationserwartungen und so.
Na ja, nächster Punkt, den sie anmerkt, sie möchte die Grundlagen der europäischen Volkswirtschaft jetzt endlich mal, na ja, so ein bisschen auf die zukünftigen wichtigen Fundamente stellen. Die Konsequenz?
Because the strings of our social market economy will drive the train and the digital transition and our Achilles heal for the small and medien enterprises are three things.
Bei so viel Marketing kann. Kursive.
Da fehlt. The Smart IT Medien Enterprise.
Let's do, we have a new business environment. It's the question do we have a work force with the right skills.
Let's do, we have a Naivling.
We have to work for. Skills. Adobe hat.
And do we have access to rohmaterials our industry need.
Zugang zu Rohstoffen, Arbeitskraft, Mangel.
Genau die beiden Sachen, die adressiert sind, sehen wir ja gerade. Demographische Wende und plötzlich viel zu Gas und so was auch als Rohstoff für BASF und den ganzen Kram zu machen.
Und sie möchte gern für die mittleren Unternehmen eine Adresse in Europa einrichten, damit die sich da besser aufstellen können, beispielsweise durch eine einheitliche Steuergesetzgebung.
Und da ist ja fast egal, ob wir eine Homogenisierung haben oder einfach eine europarechtliche Verordnung Regelung, die dann sagt für mittelständische Unternehmen, sie kommt dann gleich auf diese SSM, also small und Mittel,
also die deutsche Verwendung ist KMU,
dass man da den mal ein bisschen Orientierung bietet, dass sie beispielsweise auch schneller europäisch oder global Handel treiben können, ohne immer gleich.
Ach so, jetzt fahren wir mit unserem ICE über die Grenze, also brauchen wir da ein anderes Bremssystem und andere Feuerlöscher, die dann eingebaut werden müssen. Die Bahn kann das dann irgendwie leisten, aber für andere Unternehmen ist das halt immer total bescheuert. Immer noch so was.
Und na ja, da will sie große große Vereinheitlichung angefangen.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, ob das hier so eine Begründung europäischer Haushalte rei ist.
Also dass man dann auch wirklich sagt, wir homogenisieren das Steuer system und setzen uns gleich mal mit als Empfänger ins Netz.
Denn ja, wir haben uns schon verschuldet. Wieso sollten wir nicht auch Steuern einnehmen?
We must for a sms, remove the news that still hold back,
they must be at the centre of this transformation because they are the backbone of our industry and you are long history of industrial profis and they have always put their employer is first even and special in times of crisis.
Bei den Flaschen And they are weins as specialist heart on them.
This is why we will put forward and sme relief package,
it will include a proposal for single set of tags rules for doing business in Europe called benefit.
So be fit. Während wir in Deutschland gerade diskutieren, dass das dritte Entlastung Paket zwar jetzt die Rentner und Studenten in den Blick nimmt, diskutieren wir schon wieder. Ja, aber die Unternehmen, die kleineren Unternehmen wurden alle übersehen.
Jetzt kommt sie mit B fit B fit und sagt Uns geht es erst mal nur um die kleinen Unternehmen, also nur um die KMU.
Und so finde ich gar nicht so ungünstig strategisch platziert, weil die kommen ja mit einem echten Interesse und sehen dann solche Reden, egal was Journalisten nicht darüber berichten. Und denken Sie sich so Ja, das ist vielleicht gar kein schlechter Weg zu gehen.
Und dann ist da auch so ein Einfallstor offen, um da so Interesse zu wecken, was die EU denn zu bieten hat für diese Unternehmen.
Sie ist sehr auf der Höhe der Zeit. Also hier wird mal so richtig. In diesen kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen.
Noch eine Sache mit diesen kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen.
Die sind ja nicht alle EU freundlich, sondern wenn man sich da so umhört und wenn man auch so Verlautbarungen dann mal vernimmt, dann ist es ja so, dass gerade Unternehmen eine gewisse EU Feindschaft auch haben.
Die sind ja nicht alle EU freundlich, sondern wenn man sich da so umhört und von den Verlautbarungen mal vernimmt, dann ist es ja so, dass gerade Unternehmer eine gewisse Judenfeindschaft haben.
Insofern wenn man auf Dauer die EU stabilisieren will, dann geht das nur, indem man diesen Unternehmen auch mal zeigt Guck mal, das lohnt sich wirklich hier für euch.
Insofern, wenn man auf Dauer die EU.
Hören will. Dann geht das nur im Kino. Ja, das stimmt auch.
Genau. Wir wollen dir nicht nur die Gurke verbieten, weil sie nicht krumm genug ist oder so, sondern wir finanzieren dich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen hier.
Dann ist sie wirklich auf der Höhe der Zeit, was so die alten republikanischen Herausforderungen ganz Europas angeht.
Die Zahl der Arbeitslosen ist so niedrig wie nie. 6.0 %, 6 % Arbeitslosigkeit, das ist gut.
Aber gleichzeitig liegt die Zahl der offenen Stellen auf Rekordniveau.
Lastwagenfahrer, Kellnern, Flughafen, Personal, Krankenpfleger, Ingenieurinnen, IT, Techniker, Technikerinnen von ungelernt bis Universitätsabschluss.
Europa braucht sie alle.
Und wir müssen daher viel stärker in Aus und Weiterbildung investieren.
Dazu wollen wir eng mit den Unternehmen zusammenarbeiten, denn sie wissen am besten, welche Fachkräfte sie heute brauchen, aber auch, welche Fachkräfte sie morgen brauchen.
Und wir müssen diesen Bedarf viel besser in Einklang bringen mit den Zielen und den Wünschen der Arbeitssuchenden selbst für ihren Berufsweg.
Wir haben dieses wunderbare große Instrument ist.
Aber wir brauchen auf der anderen Seite auch eine Struktur, dass diese Gelder wirklich effektiv eingesetzt werden können.
Und ein zweites ist auch wichtig Wir müssen gezielter Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland anwerben, die hier Unternehmen und Europas Wachstum stärken.
Und deshalb ist ein wichtiger Schritt ihre Qualifikationen.
Die können, was diese Menschen, ihre Qualifikationen in Europa besser und schneller anzuerkennen. Das ist die Möglichkeit, Europa attraktiver zu machen für alle, die etwas können und die sich einbringen wollen.
Und deshalb schlage ich vor, es ist ein Riesenthema, das kann man nicht hier abhandeln.
Ich schlage vor, dass wir das Jahr 2023 zum Europäischen Jahr der Aus und Weiterbildung machen.
Lasst uns einen Schwerpunkt darauf setzen.
Aus und Weiterbildung ist ja eigentlich Olaf Scholz Lieblingsthema gewesen.
Ist ja im Koalitionsvertrag groß, kommt da jetzt gerade nicht dazu.
Er will ja die Ausbildung Berufsausbildung auf das akademische Niveau mit Stipendien und Auslandssemester und dem ganzen Kram heben.
Sie macht das jetzt einfach zu ihrem Thema. Warum nicht Sie Reuber? Da einfach mal thematisch, mal gucken, wie weit sie es treiben kann.
Am Ende ist es eine Finanzierungsfrage. Aber wenn sie noch mal so ein 57 Milliarden Programm draus strickt, wer weiß.
Wir kriegen das in Deutschland nicht so mit. Aber die Italiener hängen ja komplett daran, dass da 200 Milliarden jetzt fließen in alles mögliche bis hin zu, dass Kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt wird und so, das sind alles EU Quellen und naja, da sind schon so einige Möglichkeiten da.
Weiß, dass Gabriele Melanie auch.
Kaffee und Melone auf. Sie weiß es.
Denn sie versucht ja momentan Stunk in Europa zu verbreiten.
Also, was sie über Macron gesagt hat.
Du hast vielleicht das gehört, was sie über Macron gesagt hat dass er zynisch sei, dass er.
Dass er zynisch sei, widerwärtig geradezu sei, dass er derjenige ist, der alles den Investoren gibt und die kleinen Leute.
Widerwärtig geradezu sei, dass er derjenige ist, der alles den Investoren gibt und wir, die kleinen Leute usw sie hat ja da eine Rede gegen Macron hält, wo ich das so gut werden die sich jemals noch mal treffen können?
Und sie hat ja, dann rede gegen Macron halt nicht so gut werden, die sich jemand so macht.
Also Melone ist gewählt worden. Wir kommen auf das Wahlergebnis gleich mal im Detail dann nachher zu sprechen.
Also Melanie ist gewählt worden. Wir kommen auf das Wahlergebnis vielleicht mal en detail der Einheit zu sprechen.
Und kurze Stunden später hat die EU die nächste Tranche, wie man so schön sagt, bewilligt, um damit vier das Zeichen zu setzen. Von den 200 Milliarden bleiben wir treu. Das Geld fließt.
Und kurze Stunden später hat die EU die nächste Branche, wie man so schön sagt, bewilligt, um damit ihr das Zeichen zu setzen. Von den 200 Milliarden.
Bleiben wir treu. Das Geld fließt aber an diese Bedingung geknüpft, unter denen er Orban leidet, der gerade kein Geld überwiesen kriegt, das dafür Gegenleistungen erbracht werden müssen. Und jetzt muss Melanie überlegen, wie sie es regelt.
Aber an diese Bedingung geknüpft, unter denen ja Orban leitet, der gerade kein Geld überwiesen kriegt, dass dafür Gegenleistungen erbracht werden müssen. Und jetzt muss Melanie überlegen, wie sie es regelt.
Wohl wissend, dass sie von Salvini und Berlusconi der eine hat neun oder 8 % bekommen. Und das sind zwei sehr gekränkte Männer, gerade was das angeht.
Wohl wissend, dass sie von Salvini und.
Berlusconi der Einheit neun und 8 % bekommen. Und es sind zwei sehr gekränkte Männer gefallen und sehr, sehr Berlusconi.
Ich habe mir die Bilder, ich habe mich ja auch noch mal groß gemacht mehr auf dem Bildschirm.
Ja, Ja. Zombie.
Es ist ja, ich habe so was Fratzen haftes, das wirklich noch nie gesehen.
Es ist gruselig. Genau jetzt.
Es ist die Addams Family. Jetzt. Ja, es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, was da passiert.
Es ist wirklich ein bisschen merkwürdig, was da gerade passiert. Genau.
Und Ursula von der Leyen hat nicht nur die Arbeitnehmerschaft im Blick, sondern und das ist ja auch ein großes Thema, diesen Zugang zu Rohstoffen.
Und ja, Ursula von der Leyen hat nicht nur die Arbeitnehmerschaft im Blick, sondern das ist ja auch großes Thema diesen Zugang zu Rohstoffen, der Zugang zu Rohstoffen.
Der Zugang zu Rohstoffen ist entscheidend für den Erfolg unserer Transformation digitalen Wirtschaft.
Sind. Für den Erfolg von.
Für den Erfolg.
Lithium und Seltene Erden werden bald wichtiger sein als Öl und Gas.
Lithium und Seltene Erden. Werden bald wieder.
Lithium und Seltene Erden. Werden bald wichtiger sein.
Ist ein starker Satz, weil wir es uns noch immer nicht so ganz vorstellen können, weil das hieße ja auch, ein Nicht Verfügbarkeit von diesen Rohstoffen würde uns noch mehr unter Druck setzen als jetzt.
Ein starker Satz, weil es uns noch immer nicht so ganz vorstellen können, weil das hieße ja auch, eine Nicht Verfügbarkeit von diesen Rohstoffen würde uns noch mehr unter Druck setzen als jetzt dieser Mangel an Gas. Und genau.
Dieser Mangel an Gas und der bringt schon ganz schön Turbulenzen mit sich, würde ich mal so sagen.
Ja, und da ist China dann der nächste Partner für die Abhängigkeit.
Und dann können die sich jetzt angucken, was passiert hier mit Ukraine wurden, dann können die das auf Taiwan übertragen und sagen, da ist ja die Abhängigkeit noch größer, wie wird das dann da ausgehen?
Wird man sich da anders aufstellen?
Also ich meine, wir haben ja Zahlen in diesem Monat bekommen von vom ersten Halbjahr.
Es gibt einen neuen Rekord zu verzeichnen. Noch nie hat die deutsche Industrie, haben also deutsche Firmen so viel Direktinvestitionen in China getätigt.
Wir haben zugleich diesen Diskurs, den Habeck ganz stark macht.
Wir müssen auch sehen, dass wir diversifizieren. Wir müssen von China unabhängiger werden, und wir verkünden jetzt hier einen Rekord.
Noch nie gab es so viele Direktinvestitionen und die könnten jetzt noch sogar steigen, oder?
Bzw die Abwanderung nach China, das Outsourcen nach China könnte steigen, weil einige Unternehmen übrigens auch aus dem Mittelstand sich sagen jetzt sind die Energiepreise hier so hoch.
Na, stimmt, das lohnt sich für uns nicht.
Das lohnt sich für uns nicht. Beziehungsweise jetzt lohnt sich es wirklich für uns, es endlich in China zu machen.
Beziehungsweise jetzt lohnt sich wirklich für uns, es endlich in China zu machen.
Das heißt, wir lösen uns von Russland, aber zu dem Preis, dass wir möglicherweise die Abhängigkeit zu China verstärken, die dann wirtschaftlicher Natur ist.
Das heißt, wir haben uns von Russland aber zu dem Preis, dass wir möglicherweise die Abhängigkeit zu China verstärken, die dann wirtschaftlicher Natur ist.
Und die ist dann so stark durch die Unternehmen und das sind ja immer auch Menschen, Arbeitsplätze und all das, dass man dann sagen kann, da kommen wir gar nicht jetzt so los.
Und die ist dann so stark durch die Unternehmen, die immer auch Menschen, Arbeitsplätze und all das, dass man dann sagen kann, da kommen wir gar nicht jetzt so los.
Na also, wenn uns Fachkräfte und Energie fehlt, dann haben wir genau diesen Trend, weshalb sie das auch zu ihrer Großbaustelle erklärt.
China Controls The Global Global Processing Industry. Es mussten 19 % 90 % of rare earth and sixty percent of Lithium are processes in China.
Du musst 90 % meines. Over and President of Mission. Apostel China.
So we will identity strategic projects all along the supply chain from contracting to define from processing to recycling and we will build up strategic reserve where supply is at risk.
Wenn die Zeit für Telefonsex oder normale Supply Chain.
Back to find von professor Recycling and we will built expertise free service.
Ja. Also es ist nicht nur ein obligatorischer China Blog da drin, sondern sie hat es noch mal auf die vorher gefassten Probleme Zugang zu Rohstoffen und Arbeitskraft hier noch mal betont. Es ist.
Das ist auch wichtig, das europäisch zu sehen. Also hier ist dann auch unsere lieben Verbündeten in Amerika noch da.
Eine neue Meldung, das ist jetzt hier aus der Wirtschaftswoche.
Beiden schottet US Markt ab, da geht es um die E Autos.
US Präsident Joe Biden erhofft sich von seinem Milliardenschweren Gesetzespaket gegen die Inflation Auftrieb. Für die Midterm Wahlen im November haben wir ja schon drüber gesprochen.
Er diskriminiert damit aber offen. Hersteller von E.
Autos aus Drittländern Steuervergünstigungen von bis zu 7.500 $ erhalten Käufer von eAutos nur noch, wenn die Wagen in den USA, Mexiko oder Kanada produziert wurden.
Wir merken Europa ist nicht dabei.
Ab dem kommenden Jahr muss auch mindestens die Hälfte der Batterie Komponenten in Nordamerika hergestellt worden sein.
Und das hat dann wiederum zur Folge, dass Elon Musk mit Tesla jetzt doch plant, weniger Batterien in Deutschland zu produzieren, weil er die ja dann gar nicht in Amerika absetzen kann.
Deswegen eine wirkliche Unabhängigkeit, die von der Leyen hier schildert, ist dann auch wirklich eine, die auf europäischem Boden stattfindet.
Hm, ich find ja solche Tendenzen auch gut. Insgesamt muss man diese Autos mal um die ganze Welt fahren, nur um hier so einen kleinen Gewinn nochmal abzuschöpfen, der sich irgendwie ergibt.
Nein. Da muss man aber aber selbst darauf auch vorbereitet sein.
Aber selbst darauf vorbereitet sein. Also absolut nicht, dass wir da hingucken und und einfach nur.
Das geht jetzt nicht, dass wir da hingucken und einfach nur sagen America is back, wie, wie, wie, wie von der Leyen, Dass man sagt Ja, ja, klar, die sind zurück. Aber die meinen es auch nicht nur gut mit uns.
Hm. Wie.
Die meinen es nicht nur gut mit uns. Genau. Ist eine Aufgabenstellung für uns. Sie kommt auf die Queen zu sprechen.
And for the future. I will push to create a new European City fund.
Push the Present nur in Serenity fand.
Because we have to make sure that the future of the industry is made in Europe on will members.
In. Hast du mich schon? Das Buch Future of Industry is made in your.
Also Members.
As we look around. AT the state of the world today.
Was will Look around? A state of the world today. Die Trennung von.
IT can I feel like. T a fading away.
Reese Fading away. Och wat once sind so Vermont. In Summe zwei.
Auf. What Ones summt so permanent. Einen Somewhere.
The Passing of Queen Elizabeth The second last week reminder minded us all of that.
Parzinger Viele.
Plastik. Wie meinst du das? Oh Gott.
Sky is a legend.
Sie ist elegant. Und jetzt? Sie nimmt sich nicht allzu viel Zeit. Ich finde es so angemessen.
Aber ich bin ja da auch anders gepolt.
Sie macht einen ganz interessanten Punkt. Was ist eigentlich das Erbe der Queen? Ich fand es nicht schlecht.
Scheiß book not only to the heart of our nation, but to the soul of the whole world.
So? Wenn man der King of the Situation male today.
I when I think of the rain today words at the height of the comic still red with me she said.
AT the night of the still Revolution. Sie setzt.
We will and that success will belong to every one of us.
We will sexy. Ansatz Success will belong to every one of us.
End. Of course. She always reminder us that I future is built a new years and found it in our own test values.
Ein doppelt. Wenn wir meinen, dass der Future den Bürgern Nevadas ahnt, verwundert den Autoren des Bandes.
Since the end of world what you we have pursuit the promise of democracy and of the rule of law.
Fünf Jahre Ruhe. Wozu? We are the promise. Auch Democracy und Rule of law.
And the nations of the world have built together international system for peace and security.
All the Nations of the World hat Lottogewinner hinterlassen. International.
Community sind Security Justice das Ziel von Ausbeutung.
Justice and economic Progress.
Today. This is the very target of Russian missiles.
To be this is the Russian missiles.
So kommt sie wieder zurück zu Aber diese Idee von Ja, wir wohnen alle in so einem Haus, von dem wir dann irgendwann mal sagen können, wir können es auch mal zurückbauen, solange wir das Fundament stehen lassen. Und dann bauen wir darauf wieder was Neues.
Das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, weil das ist die Herausforderung. Die Zäsuren sind ja alle da.
Abhängigkeit von Russland, was Energie angeht, demographische Wende und so,
jetzt könnte man sich ja wirklich auf die Fundamente, die einem wirklich wichtig sind, mal fokussieren, die auch thematisieren und alles andere, was nur so nicht tragende Deko, Wände und Fassade usw alles mal zur Disposition stellen.
Von der Leyen war ja nicht Merkels Wahl. Das haben wir ja heute vergessen, sondern Macrons Wahl.
Und deswegen ist es auch kein Zufall, dass sie sagt Wir brauchen einen Souveränitätsverzicht.
Souveränität ist das Lieblingswort von Präsident Macron. Souveränität ist das, was er für Europa einfordert.
Deswegen eigentlich auch eine Europaarmee und und und. Würde ja, wie wir wissen, viel Kosten sparen, wenn nicht jeder da sein eigenes Preußen aufbaut.
Aber hier können wir noch mal deutlich sehen, Denn erst mal Mag es ja verwundern, wieso will denn jetzt Macron eine Deutsche?
Na ja, da gibt es schon eine große Nähe. Also Macron und von der Leyen sind sich da sehr nah und deswegen auch diese Begrifflichkeit der Souveränität.
Und wenn man mal ein bisschen drauf achtet, da, es ist ein Wort Souveränität, dass auch sie relativ häufig im Munde führt. Und da ist diese Nähe da. Wie lang ist sie denn eigentlich jetzt noch?
Präsidentin Das geht bis.
Hm. 19201 123. Also, es stimmt. Gute Frage.
Gute Frage. So oder so, es ist ja so lang.
Anderthalb Jahre oder so? Es ist gar nicht mehr so lang wie gedacht.
Lustig wäre doch, wenn die CDU sie dann als Kanzlerkandidatin aufstellt. Klappt das noch gerade so? Ja, könnte klappen. Und dann könnte sie mit Macron sind ja ist die Zeit so locker, Sie ist ja noch jung.
Wenn die CDU sich dann als Kanzlerkandidatin aufstellt, klappt das noch gerade so? Ja. Dann könnte sie,
ja das. Mal gucken, was die Zeit so noch. Sie ist ja noch jung, um sich mal da zu räuspern in dem Punkt.
Also denkbar. Denkbar wäre so was. Ja, denkbar wäre so was natürlich.
Denkbar wäre, es wäre denkbar. Apropos jung.
Aber wir sind ja auch jetzt mal mit. Also ich finde ja an sich jetzt so wie wie Scholz wir sind uns da ja sehr einig alles in ruhigen Gewässern lassen.
Ich finde ja an sich jetzt so wie die Scholz. Wir sind ja sehr ähnlich. Ruhigen Gewässern.
Keine Aufregung. Keine Turbulenzen im Nahverkehr, bitte.
Keine Aufregung. Keine Turbulenzen im Nahverkehr.
Apropos Jung. Es ist gerade das Jahr der Jugend. Sie hat es letztes Jahr ausgerufen. Sie geht dem so ein bisschen nach.
Apropos Jungs Es ist gerade das Jahr der Jugend. Sie hat es letztes Jahr ausgerufen. Sie gibt dem so ein bisschen nach.
Sie freut sich, junge Menschen getroffen zu haben.
I had an incredible opportunity of the shining.
Johannes. 2200. Genau, ich.
One 1500. Young people from all over Europe and all over the world that gotthardt in Taize.
Von 1500 Young People vom World.
Das Ganze in. So, die waren da in Taize. Tessin. Ah, okay.
So, die waren da. Und sie war auch mit da. Tessin? Taize? Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwo, irgendwo in Europa haben sie sich getroffen.
Und jetzt, zum Ende ihrer Rede, kommt ein echter Knaller. Das muss man einfach so sagen.
Es ist ein echter Knaller. Und ich verstehe das nicht, warum wir davon nichts gehört haben.
Klar, es ist eine lange Rede, und da werden so Ideen vorgetragen. Aber es ist doch,
irgendwie Ursula von der Leyen, die als Kommissionspräsident denn als Präsidentin der Europäischen Kommission hier eine Forderung aufstellt, die wir einfach nicht mitbekommen haben. Und das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Plus Es ist noch ein kleines i Tüpfelchen dabei, aber wir hören uns das hier mal an!
And this Generation is a phänomenal. Generation It's a Generation of dreamers and makers.
Und in My love state of the union I told you that I would like you to look more like this young people.
We should put are as operations at the heart of everything we do. On the place for this.
IS in our funding treaty.
Every action that union takes should be inspired by a very simple principle,
that we should do no harm to our children's future and that we should leave the world a better place for the next generation,
and there for on river members.
I believe that it is time to in Shrine solidarity between generations in our treaty.
IS time to the European Promis. And wealth so need to move the way we do things and the way we decade things some might see the and the right time.
But if we are serious about prepare for the world of tomorrow.
We must be able to act on the things that matter the most for people.
And as we are serious about a larger union.
We have to be serious about reform so as this parliament has called for I believe the moment has a net for European convention.
Das Europäische Parlament hat seit Ewigkeiten immer mal wieder diese Forderung vorgetragen. Wir brauchen einen neuen Europäischen Konvent, also so einen neuen Bürger Tag, der dann letztendlich neue Verträge, also einfach wirklich neue EU Verträge schreibt.
Und sie hat sich jetzt bereit erklärt, diesen Weg mitzugehen.
Also die EU Kommission und das Parlament sind sich jetzt irgendwie einig wir updaten die EU Verträge plus wir bauen.
Das, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Sachen Klima der Jugend zugeschrieben hat.
Ihr habt ein Recht auf Zukunft und es darf nicht alles erst nach 2035, wenn dann nur noch ihr das Problem löst, sondern die Zukunft.
Die Freiheitseinschränkungen müssen auch jetzt schon von den gerade in Verantwortung seienden Generationen mitgetragen werden.
Und dass sie jetzt neue EU Verträge möchte, ist schon ein Knaller für sich. Und dass sie das gleichzeitig noch als Generation Verträge konzipieren möchte.
Das ist doch. Also ich versteh das gar nicht, wie wir hier durch den September gekommen sind in Deutschland.
Und wir sprechen jetzt hier tatsächlich über ein Vorhaben. Wir sprechen jetzt ja hier nicht nur über. Das wäre mal eine schöne Idee.
Ohne dass mal hier,
nicht nur über das Germanische eine Idee, das ist die EU Kommissions Präsidentin in ihrer State of the Union, in ihrem Finale ihre Rede, was sie sich jetzt wünscht und wo sie sich.
Das ist die EU Kommissions Präsidentin in ihrer State of the Union, in ihrem Finale, Ihrer Rede.
Wenn Sie sich jetzt wünschen. Und wo Sie sich.
An die Seite des EU Parlaments stellt, die das schon seit einer Weile fordern.
So. Und das ist, äh. Weiß nicht.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Eigentlich müssten sich jetzt die EU Mitgliedstaaten über die Ministerräte und an die Staats und Regierungschefs dazu verhalten.
Eigentlich müssten sich jetzt die EU Mitgliedsstaaten über die Ministerräte und dann die Staats und Regierungschefs dazu verhalten, weil das Initiativrecht für alles liegt bei der EU Kommission und sie hat hier die Initiative ergriffen in einem sehr relevanten Punkt.
Weil das Initiativrecht für alles liegt bei der EU Kommission und sie hat hier die Initiative ergriffen, einem sehr relevanten Punkt.
Und es ist wirklich verrückt, dass wir so eine Rede bekommen und dann nicht eine Eilmeldung.
Ursula von der Leyen möchte EU Verträge neu schreiben, weil das ist ja das wofür, wovor wir so große Angst haben, weil dann.
Ursula von der Leyen möchte die Verträge neu schreiben. Ja, weil das ist ja das, wofür wir ja große Angst haben.
Weil dann weil es so viel Populismus. Und so weiter. Wie wirkt es dann? Herein. Und man sieht es wirklich nicht. Aber bisher.
Aber jetzt haben gerade so viel Populismus. Und so weiter. Wie wirkt das dann da rein und sollen wir sie jetzt wirklich?
Eigentlich haben wir bisher immer so, ja, wir lassen sie lieber wie sie sind, weil wir wissen nicht genau, wohin das führt und so?
Nicht, dass da noch mal eine Debatte aufflammt. Wir machen jetzt im Konvent, dass die Jungen mit anderen EU Generation Verträge als die neuen Verträge.
Genau. Und sie sagt jetzt einfach Ja, wir machen jetzt EU Konvent.
Hören uns die Jungen mit an und dann schreiben wir EU Generation Verträge als die neuen Verträge.
Also ich finde das wirklich Wahnsinn, dass das so auf der Bühne stattfindet und wir das überhaupt nirgendwo aufgegriffen sehen, weil wo sonst sollte das jetzt formuliert werden?
Also ich finde das wirklich Wahnsinn, dass das so auf der Bühne stattfindet und wir das überhaupt nirgendwo aufgegriffen sehen, weil wo sonst sollte das formuliert werden? Also echt irre.
Das ist echt irre. Aber es ist, wie es ist.
Aber es ist, wie es ist. Solche Reden finden irgendwie nirgendwo statt. Die mächtigste Frau Europas sagt die wichtigsten Sachen aus.
Solche Reden finden irgendwie nirgendwo statt. Die mächtigste Frau Europas sagt die wichtigsten Sachen und niemand interessiert sich dafür.
Niemand interessiert sich dafür.
Kommen wir zu Olaf Scholz. Der. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das.
Kommen wir zu Olaf Scholz. Der Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das.
Also, das ist ja richtig. Ursula von der Leyen ist eine formale Rolle in einem formalen Termin, nämlich State of the Union. Und so weiter. Sie redet im Parlament von den Parlamentariern.
Also das ist ja richtig. Ursula von der Leyen ist eine formale Rolle in einem formalen Termin in der Union. Und so weiter. Sie redet im Parlament von den Parlamentariern.
Ein deutscher Bundeskanzler vor den Vereinten Nationen ist so Hm, ja, keine Ahnung. Wie ist das zu verstehen? Also man redet halt irgendwie.
Ein deutscher Bundeskanzler vor den Vereinten Nationen ist. So mehr. Keine Ahnung. Wie ist das?
Ich habe einige Artikel über die Vereinten Nationen gelesen, was da so los war.
Gelesen, was da so los war, aber da war vielleicht zwei zwei Olaf Scholz dabei war Maschine und das war.
Aber da war vielleicht zwei Zeilen Olaf Scholz dabei. Bei mir schien auch, es war nicht so besonders relevant.
Würde ich auch sagen. Aber man wünscht sich doch eigentlich anderes. Man wünscht sich doch eigentlich, dass wir nach 16 Jahren Merkel, wo die EU nun komplett marginalisiert wurde.
Hm.
Ja, natürlich.
Dass das eigentlich noch ernst genommen wird dort. Da wird der Hunger thematisiert, Krieg und Frieden. Und so weiter und so fort.
Aber fand alles nicht statt? Und Olaf Scholz Rede fand ich.
Wie soll ich sagen, unsäglich und auch nicht gut. Er wollte sie verstecken, was für uns heißt. Jetzt schauen wir besonders hin.
Es ist erst mal dieser große Appell. Wir müssen jetzt mal die Regeln einhalten.
Globale Krisen türmen sich vor uns auf, verbinden und verstärken sich.
Manche sehen darin die Vorboten einer Welt ohne Regeln. Zutreffend ist Die Risiken für unsere globale Ordnung sind real.
Und dennoch kann ich wenig anfangen mit dem Bild von der regellosen Welt. Aus zwei Gründen. Erstens Unsere Welt hat klare Regeln. Regeln, die wir als Vereinte Nationen gemeinsam geschaffen haben.
Diese Charta.
Verspricht uns allen ein friedliches Miteinander. Diese Karte ist unsere kollektive Absage an eine regellose Welt.
Unser Problem sind nicht fehlende Regeln. Unser Problem ist der mangelnde Wille, sie einzuhalten und durchzusetzen.
Ja. Regeln. Regeln, Regeln, Regeln, Regeln. Aber was meint er denn jetzt?
Also, dass die Logik der Bundesregierung Für uns müssen 50 Sklaven irgendwo auf der Welt arbeiten, weil wir sind ja der reiche Westen weiterhin gelten soll und wir gerade ein bisschen verstört sind davon, dass das so aufgestört würde, dieses Gefüge, oder?
Und der Hunger ist uns eigentlich auch egal. Auch schon bevor der Krieg begann, war uns der Hunger eigentlich egal und er verteidigt jetzt immer so diese Idee der globalen Ordnung und auch der Globalisierung.
Genau. Was ist mit dem Hunger?
Festung Europas, Migration und so?
Er war ja auch bei der Industrie in diesem Monat unterwegs bei verschiedenen Sachen, hat dann immer gesagt Nein, es gibt natürlich keine de Globalisierung und die soll es auch nicht geben.
Und die Globalisierung ist der Motor unseres Wachstums und Wohlstands, und das ist in der Weise richtig.
Als man festhalten muss. Das beruht auf diesen Ausbeutungsverhältnisse natürlich ganz stark.
Ich halte auch viel für die Globalisierung im Sinne von einer Vernetzung, die dann durch diese gegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten auch Konflikte verhindert oder oder zumindest Kriege verhindern kann. Also für mich ist auch nicht das Ding.
Wandel durch Handel völlig ausgestorben. Jetzt nur weil Putin durchgedreht ist.
Aber ich würde deutlich machen, dass diese Regeln, die da so hochgehalten werden, von denen, die sie am Ende,
setzen können und und sich leisten können, sie zu brechen, doch sehr lax gehandhabt werden.
Das würde ich auch sagen. Und gerade dieses Wir hatten doch Regeln. Und so weiter.
Wenn die Regel lautete Hauptsache Globalisierung, der Rest ergibt sich von alleine, dann hast du uns ja gerade die Zahlen vorgetragen.
Die Globalisierung, der geht's gut. Es ist halt jetzt Chinas Globalisierung.
Das gefällt uns nicht so richtig. Aber die Regel, also Globalisierung, machen wir mal die, an der rüttelt gerade keiner so, sondern Apple geht halt nach Indien um da jetzt das neueste iPhone Modell herzustellen.
Das ist immer noch nicht in Amerika und na ja.
Olaf Scholz erste Aufschlag. Zweitens ein kleiner Satz zu Hunger und Krieg.
Nicht. Ein Sack Getreide wurde aufgrund dieser Sanktionen zurückgehalten.
Russland allein hat die ukrainischen Getreide Schiffe am Auslaufen gehindert, Häfen zerbombt und landwirtschaftliche Betriebe zerstört.
Ukrainischen Getreide Schiffe. Ungehindert Häfen zerbombt und Landwirtschaft.
Wer den Krieg ächten will, muss auch den Hunger ächten. Mein Amtsvorgänger, Friedensnobelpreisträger Willy Brandt, hat diesen Satz gesagt, als er als erster Bundeskanzler im Jahr 1973 hier vor dieser Versammlung sprach.
Da den krieg ächten will, muss auf den.
Mein Amtsvorgänger, Friedensnobelpreisträger Willy Brandt. Hat diesen Satz gesagt. Der Bundeskanzler.
Zieht ihr von dieser Versammlung?
Heute erleben wir. Dieser Satz gilt auch umgekehrt.
Heute leben wir.
Wer den Hunger ächten will, der muss Russlands Krieg ächten. Diesen Krieg, der auch in Ländern weit weg von Russland für steigende Preise, Energieknappheit und Hungersnot sorgen.
Für den Hunger ist die Welt Russlands in.
Energieknappheit. Was wir ja alles ausblenden. Wir kümmern uns ja wirklich nur um Europa gerade. Und wünschen.
Und was heißt den Hunger ächten? Dann muss man ihn bekämpfen, also ächten. Das ist ja so, wie zu sagen Schön, dass sie immer da kämpft. Also das ist ja überhaupt nichts gesagt. Und wie gesagt, wir haben es aufgedröselt.
Ja, Also echt zusammen. Schön, dass sie immer da kämpft.
Genau. Überhaupt nichts gesagt. Und wie gesagt, wir haben es aufgedröselt.
War es im April oder Mai mit dem Welthunger und ich hatte ja da die Ausschnitte vom November 2021, wo alles schon katastrophal aussah und da hat Putin noch nichts gemacht.
Was im April oder Mai mit dem Welthunger. Und ich hatte da die Ausgabe vom November 2021 schon katastrophal versagt. Und da hat Putin noch nichts gemacht.
Naja, vor allem er ist ja in der UN und es wurde doch immer gesagt Ja, gerade die UN Flüchtlings Hilfswerke,
stellen fest, sie brauchen jetzt doppelt so viel Geld, um die gleiche Menge an Nahrungsmitteln zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Aber diese doppelte Menge Geld stellt ja niemand zur Verfügung.
Also hier muss ja nichts geächtet, sondern finanziert werden. Aber das wird so alles so ein bisschen weg versteckt.
Plus Und das finde ich wirklich ne Katastrophe, dass man dann in diesem Zuge wie eben bei Ursula von der Leyen gehört, natürlich dann auch abgestimmt mit dem Kanzleramt.
Irgendwie ja, wir wollen die Ukraine im europäischen Binnenmarkt, weil dann haben wir wenigstens die schwarze Erde, die so fruchtbar ist und das ganze Getreide usw ja perspektivisch so ein bisschen näher an uns dran.
Also das ist doch alles hier sehr verlogen und besonders verlogen ist diese Anmerkung zum Klima.
Deshalb haben wir beim G7 Gipfel im Juni in Deutschland noch einmal bekräftigt, beim Klimaschutz voranzugehen, um das 1,5 Grad Ziel zu erreichen.
Nicht trotz des Krieges und der Energiekrise, sondern gerade weil Klimaneutralität auch größere Energiesicherheit bedeutet.
Wir stehen zu unseren Zusagen, Schwellen und Entwicklungsländern bei der Emissionsminderung und ihrer Anpassung an den Klimawandel zu unterstützen, zum Beispiel durch neue Partnerschaften für eine gerechte Energiewende.
Und wir werden auch die Länder nicht allein lassen, die am stärksten mit Verlusten und Schäden durch den Klimawandel zu kämpfen haben.
Bis zur Klimakonferenz in Ägypten wollen wir deshalb einen globalen Schutzschirm gegen Klimarisiken entwickeln.
Ja der globale Schutzschirm. Also Olaf Scholz kriegt es nicht mal hin, seiner FDP ein Tempolimit abzuverlangen im Sektor Verkehr, wo wir nun wirklich gar keine Ersparnisse vorzuweisen haben, was CO2 angeht und so,
und nicht mal das klappt, während wir gleichzeitig,
er total einknickt.
Also die FDP sagt, wir sollten jede Energiequelle nutzen, auch Atomkraftwerke machen wir, da ist die Not groß.
Aber bei der CO2 Ersparnis und wir haben gar keine im Verkehrssektor zumindest zu sagen dann lasst uns wenigstens langsamer Autofahren, okay, nee, ist nicht.
Und dann da zu stehen und den anderen das abzuverlangen und dass man ihr aber auch gerne hilft in so einem Club usw man steht gerne dabei und hält das Händchen.
Das finde ich echt so logisch, dass diese ganzen auch bevölkerungsreichen Länder auf Wachstums Länder Schwellenländer sich sagen ich lass mir doch nicht diese Moralpredigten erhalten.
Und dann ist doch logisch, dass diese ganzen oft bevölkerungsreichen Ländern auf Wachstums Länder Schwellenländer sich sagen ich lass mir doch nicht diese Moralpredigten hier halten, da sind mir die Chinesen angenehmer, die wollen.
Ja, da sind die Chinesen angenehmer.
Genau, Business machen mit uns und da können wir uns irgendwie auf Augenhöhe begegnen. Aber nicht noch, dass man sich moralisch hier zurechtweisen lassen.
Ein Business machen mit uns und da können wir uns irgendwie auf Augenhöhe begegnen.
Aber nicht noch, dass man sich moralisch hier zurechtweisen lassen muss von jenen, die sehr unmoralisch ihren Wohlstand erworben haben.
Genau in der Hinsicht. Das ist einfach. Ich weiß auch nicht. Es ging dann beim Thema Menschenrechte gut.
Hinsehen und handeln müssen wir aber auch dort, wo Hunderttausende in Straflagern oder Gefängnissen Leid, Willkür und Folter erdulden müssen Nordkorea, Syrien, dem Iran oder Belarus.
Und handeln müssen. Aber dort, wo Hunderttausende von Fahrzeugen. Im Gefängnis sind Leid, Willkür und Folter durch.
Hinsehen und handeln müssen wir, wenn die Taliban Frauen und Mädchen in Afghanistan ihrer grundlegendsten Rechte berauben.
Hinsehen und handeln müssen wir, wenn die Taliban frauen und.
Und hinsehen und handeln müssen wir, wenn Russland in Mariupol Burka oder Kriegsverbrechen begeht.
Ja, Hinsehen und Handeln bei Afghanistan ist natürlich dramatisch.
Er hat jetzt hier von Hunderttausenden Inhaftierten und so gesprochen, China da noch mal ausgespart.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, der wird wahrscheinlich einen eigenen Blog machen. Kam dann auch so. Kommissarin.
Die frühere Kommissarin für Menschenrechte hat uns vor einigen Wochen über die Lage der Uiguren in Xinjiang berichtet.
China sollte die Empfehlung der Kommissarin umsetzen. Das wäre ein Zeichen von Souveränität und Stärke und ein Garant für die Veränderung zum Besseren.
Ja, also dieses Drama um diese Hoch Kommissarin, die sozusagen fünf Minuten vor dem Ende ihrer Amtszeit noch diese Email verschickt damit. Das ist übrigens mein Bericht.
Ab jetzt bin ich nicht mehr dafür zuständig.
Es war ja unklar und es war ja wirklich unklar, ob der überhaupt noch kommt. Aber sie hat es dann auf diese Weise gemacht. Ja.
Genau. Sie hat es dann so kurz vor Ladenschluss noch gemacht, was hieße, der ist jetzt in der Welt, aber es ist niemand ansprechbar dafür.
Der ist jetzt in der Welt, aber es ist niemand ansprechbar dafür, dass er das noch mal so aufgreift, als Hammer behandelt.
Und dass er das noch mal so aufgreift als Ja, haben wir ja behandelt, so ist ja thematisiert worden, die Umstände völlig ausgeblendet und dann so, das wäre auch ein schönes Zeichen, wenn China das jetzt mal macht.
So ist ja thematisiert worden, die Umstände völlig ausgeblendet. Und das wäre auch ein schönes Zeichen, wenn China das jetzt mal macht. Das ist wirklich die allerschlechteste Form, die man kriegen kann.
Das ist wirklich die aller schwächste Form, die man da hätte wählen können. Das ist wirklich kurz vor Verschweigen.
Danach kommt nur noch Verschweigen, wollt ich gerade sagen Ja.
Ja, also das ist einfach nicht gut. Und naja, dieses Finale, es ist ich also echt nicht gut.
Als diesjähriger Präsident der G7 ist es mir daher ein zentrales Anliegen, für eine neue Art der Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern des globalen Südens einzutreten.
Eine Zusammenarbeit, die Augenhöhe nicht nur behauptet, sondern herstellt.
Zumal diese Augenhöhe de facto ja längst besteht, wenn man das wachsende politische, ökonomische und demographische Gewicht Asiens, Afrikas und des südlichen Amerikas beachtet.
Von Beginn an haben wir unsere Ziele auf das Engste mit Indonesien als die G20 Präsidentschaft abgestimmt.
Die Vorsitz Länder der Afrikanischen Union und der Gemeinschaft lateinamerikanischer und Karibischer Staaten haben wir unseren Beratungen als G7 beteiligt, ebenso wie Indien und Südafrika.
Der globale Süden ist uns gerade sowas von egal. Und hier anzumerken, dass man ja an die Philippinen eine gute Amtsübergabe der G20 Präsidentschaft gemacht hat und bei den anderen beratend dabei saß, als sie tagten,
ist nun wirklich, das ist so Mindestmaß von irgendwas.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie im Verein, wo man noch mal so sagt Ja, es sind die Trikots, alle gewaschen wurden und wieder gebügelt worden und die sind jetzt wieder verfügbar.
Also ein Verein, wo man noch mal so sagt ja, es sind die Trikots, alle gewaschen wurden und wieder gebügelt wurde.
Die sind jetzt wieder verfügbar und außerdem haben wir auch die Abrechnung vom letzten Sommerfest fertig.
Und außerdem haben wir auch die Abrechnung vom letzten Sommerfest fast fertig.
Ja, und kann noch mal jemand sich zum Beisitzer wählen lassen? Keine Sorge, es kommt auch keine Arbeit drauf zu. Wir brauchen nur. Es steht in Gesetz, wir brauchen einen Beisitzer.
Also, das ist wirklich schlimm, was wir hier geliefert bekommen oder die Welt von uns Deutschen geliefert bekommt.
Hier noch mal dieses kleine Finale. Es ist, das ist auch echt fast Wortwitz, den er jetzt bringt, den man auf so einer Comedy Bühne bringen kann.
Durch einen neu entstehenden Klima Club gehen wir mit Freunden und Partnern weltweit voran, um das Pariser Klimaabkommen noch schneller und besser umzusetzen.
Europa und weltweit voran. Um das Pariser Klimaabkommen noch schneller und.
Solche Ansätze sind Pfeiler, die unsere internationale Ordnung stützen, weil sie Ergebnisse liefern, die den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in all unseren Ländern zugutekommen und die sie von den Vereinten Nationen erwarten.
Solche Ansätze.
Die Ergebnisse liefern. Den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern all dieser Länder zugutekommen.
We the peoples wir, die Völker! Lautet nicht umsonst die ersten drei Worte Unser Kater.
Wie The Peoples. Wir die Volker.
Paris noch schneller und besser umsetzen. Das war's.
Das ist die Pointe, glaube ich, die er bringen wollte. Da von den Vereinten Nationen. Es ist.
We the peoples. Wir sind gespannt.
Wie The Pipes.
Nein, wir sind nicht gespannt. Wir. Wir schauen uns das an und schütteln den Kopf und springen zu Aserbaidschan und machen eigentlich ein bisschen weiter in diesem Modus in Aserbaidschan.
Es ist ein großes Drama.
In der Nacht zum 13 September haben aserbaidschanische Truppen Armenien angegriffen.
Es gab 2020 schon den Angriff Aserbaidschans auf Bergkarabach,
und nun aber geht es um Armenien selbst 200 Menschen etwa wurden jetzt bislang getötet,
knapp 8000 Menschen sollen sich auf der Flucht befinden.
Wir hören jetzt erst mal einen Part aus der Bundespressekonferenz.
Tilo fragt mal da bei der Bundesregierung nach.
Das riecht ja irgendwie fast so nach einem Angriffskrieg, möchte man meinen.
Was sagen die denn dazu? Denn das ist ja, wie wir auch wissen, energetisch unser neuer wichtiger Partner.
Es gab ja da schöne Bilder mit Ursula von der Leyen und dem Chef des ganzen Alijew.
Noch mal zurück zu Armenien, Herr Wagner, weil Sie nicht ganz verstanden haben, kann die Bundesregierung einen Aggressor zwischen Aserbaidschan und Armenien erkennen.
Also die Angaben von beiden Seiten lassen sich mangels unabhängiger Beobachter vor Ort nicht unabhängig bestätigen und überprüfen.
Insofern kann ich dazu auch nicht weiter Stellung nehmen, mir also unabhängige Berichterstattung sagt, dass die aserbaidschanische Seite angegriffen hat.
Am Dienstag, als die Russen in der Ukraine angegriffen haben, haben Sie nicht beide Seiten aufgefordert, die Waffen ruhen zu lassen. Warum tun Sie das jetzt hier?
Also ich kann nur noch mal auf das verweisen, was ich eben gesagt habe Mangels fehlender unabhängiger und unabhängiger Berichterstatter nicht Berichterstatter, sondern Beobachter internationaler Beobachter vor Ort kann man das nicht unabhängig überprüfen.
Und ich glaube, es steht uns auch nicht gut, diesen Konflikt zu vergleichen mit dem, was dann der Ukraine passiert ist.
Aber genau das wollen wir natürlich in gewisser Weise jetzt tun. Wir werden jetzt,
nicht das die ganze Zeit vergleichen, aber wir wollen mal schauen, was ist da los und hören zum Beispiel in der Deutschen Welle Silvia Stöber, die das auch gefragt wird, die aber Journalistin ist und jetzt folgendermaßen antwortet.
Ich verstehe Sie richtig, dass in diesem Fall, die Angriffe belastbar einzuschätzen von Aserbeidschan ausgegangen sind.
War er einzuschätzen.
Wenn man sich das Ergebnis anschaut, auch in diesem Fall bei dieser Eskalation in der Nacht, dann sieht man ja, dass Ortschaften innerhalb von Armenien getroffen wurden.
Schaut doch in diesen Thread mal wieder.
Interessant, wie Videos.
Von dort gibt es Bilder, wo Splitter runtergegangen sind, wo Gebäude zerstört worden sind.
Darüber.
Aserbaidschan selbst hat gesagt, dass Infrastruktur, Militär, militärische Infrastruktur Armeniens zerstört worden sei, dass man strategisch wichtige Höhen eingenommen habe.
Die nötige Infrastruktur Armeniens wird zerstört worden sein. Strategisch wichtige Regionen.
Das weist eben deutlich darauf hin, dass es aus Griffe gewissermaßen Angriffe von Seiten Aserbaidschans auf Armenien gegeben hat.
Die Armenier werden wohl nicht ihre eigenen Häuser torpediert haben. Das geht natürlich so ein bisschen freier als eine Regierungsriege, die Sprecher schafft, da antworten kann. Aber sie hat ja doch ein paar Punkte aufgezählt.
Man hört dann immer die Journalisten, die natürlich so ein bisschen Freiheit, so eine Regierungsriege, also die Sprecher schafft, da antworten kann.
Aber sie hat ja doch ein paar Punkte aufgezählt, was man so sieht und dass die das Mantra der Bundesregierung da ist nichts wissen, nichts wissen.
Man sieht ja, dass die das Mantra der Bundesregierung da ist.
Also das halt. Ich kann mich immer noch erinnern an diese Szene mit Steffen Seibert, der dann einfach vorne sitzt. Seine Kollegen aus den Ministerien kriegen Fragen und er flüstert darüber ins Mikrofon Nichts wissen, nichts wissen.
Das wollen wir ja.
Steffen Seibert, der da vorne sitzt. Seine Kollegen aus den Ministerien kriegen Fragen, und er flüstert darüber ins Mikrofon.
Und so ist das dann hier auch wieder gewesen. Also wir wissen gar nichts. Keine Ahnung. Wir haben auch kein Radio, um hier mal die deutschen Journalisten zu hören.
Das ist ja auch gar nicht keine Art an deutsche Journalisten zu hören.
Ja, ja, da hat noch gar nicht in die Zeitungen geguckt.
Nun ganz kurz die stellvertretenden Außenminister geworden, Gian und Mama von Armenien.
Aserbaidschan not my not my only violette kiswahili a cross border, but it on targeted armenien positions and also civil infrastructure inside Armenien.
Natürlich bei. Am Flussufer war die Totalität Armeniens zu groß, was sie in den Verzweifelten zweigleisigen.
So it's a clear attack und covenant country, it is clear attack on un member state.
Inspiriert hat. Unseren Auftritt ist die Universität.
Armenier has been schelling as original military positions for a few we know.
Also wenn in der Folge die Theorie.
What Schelling has been intensiv fit over the last few days.
Oder vielleicht. Vielleicht eines Tages ein Abendessen im Parlament von Berlin, oder?
And over the same few days are we started a meeting heavy weapon and all my mind along the team border between Armenien und Aserbaidschan.
Wer ist aber überhaupt diese Regierung da in Aserbaidschan?
Wir hören da einen Beitrag aus Deutschlandfunk Kultur Weltzeit.
Birgit Wetzel klärt uns auf.
Und wir gehen jetzt mal gedanklich weiter zum Präsidentenpalast. Da wohnt oder sitzt drin Ilham Alijew.
Ging es mal gedanklich weiter zum Präsidentenpalast. Da wohnt oder sitzt mit Ilham Alijew, der seit 2003 im Amt. Und wofür steht er?
Der ist seit 2003 im Amt. Und wofür steht er?
Ja, Alijew ist die zentrale Figur in Aserbaidschan. Muss man wirklich sagen. Er hat einen Personenkult um sich und seine Familie aufgebaut. Und er ist der Sohn von Heydar Aliyev.
Ja. Alias ist eine zentrale Figur Aserbaidschans. Er hat einen Trunkenbold in sich und seine Familie aufgebaut. Und er ist der Sohn von General.
Heydar Aliyev ist derjenige, der diesen Jahrhundert Vertrag geschlossen hat, und man ist ihm bis heute ohne Ende dankbar dafür, dass dieser Vertrag zustande gekommen ist.
Jeder Handgriff ist Millimeter. Jahrhundert fast abgeschlossen hat und man ist ihm bis heute ohne Ende dankbar dafür, dass dieser Vertrag zustande gekommen ist durch diesen Vertrag, durch die Petrodollars, die dann ins Land gekommen sind.
Denn durch diesen Vertrag, durch die Petrodollars, die dann ins Land gekommen sind, konnte sich das ganze Land entwickeln und nicht nur Baku, sondern auch darüber hinaus.
Konnte sich das Ganze etwas entwickeln und nicht nur warten, sondern Mitte Oktober hinaus Ist hier Straßen gebaut worden, ist, sind Autobahnen gebaut.
Es sind Straßen gebaut worden, ist in Autobahnen gebaut worden, es sind viele neue Schulen entstanden.
Es sind viele neue Schulen entstanden. Durch diese Petrodollars hat sich das Land ganz gewaltig.
Durch diese Petrodollars hat sich das Land ganz gewaltig verändert.
Die Petrodollars haben das Land reich gemacht und vor allem die Familie Alijew und die dazugehörigen Clans haben sich daran sehr bereichert.
Ich will noch mal zu sprechen kommen auf den Vater. Und zwar Heydar Aliyev.
Der war vor ihm Präsident, bis er gestorben ist. Und der war auch vorher im höchsten Gremium der Sowjetunion, dem Politbüro der Kommunistischen Partei.
Ist das jetzt eine Familien Dynastie, die wir dort haben seit der Unabhängigkeit von Aserbaidschan Anfang der 90er Jahre? Wie ist seine Rolle einzuschätzen?
Natürlich, diese Familie dominiert das politische Geschehen in der Region.
Es ist aber auch überhaupt so, dass die Herrschaftsverhältnisse sehr andere sind als in Europa.
Es gibt eben doch sehr starke Clanstrukturen, und es gibt auch Oligarchen, die sehr viel das politische Geschehen bestimmen.
Für schon einiges Stirnrunzeln hat insbesondere gesorgt, dass Ilham Alijew auch seine Frau als Vizepräsidenten ernannt hat,
und auch für seinen Sohn schon Ambitionen hat, dass der die Amtsgeschäfte weiterführen wird.
Ja, das ist also so eine klassische Racket Struktur, wie wir sie aus vielen Ländern kennen.
Ehefrau, Vizepräsidentin das geht dann noch mal weiter als in anderen Staaten. Da sind es dann immer noch die Schwiegersöhne oder so, die man noch installiert.
Aber hier macht man es ganz eng. Und ja, das ist ein Land, das natürlich mit einer Demokratie nichts zu tun hat, während Armenien eine Demokratie ist. Auch das muss hier deutlich gemacht werden.
Und nun ist es so, dass der Westen eine Verbindung zu Aserbaidschan hat, was sich zum einen durch diese CDU Connection zeigt.
Ich habe da jetzt nichts zu mitgebracht, aber da haben ja viele investigative, gute journalistische Teams gearbeitet zu und das ist sehr erhellend, was da herausgefunden wurde.
Und es ist natürlich so, dass diese Ölfirmen, die westlichen, auch eine große Verbindung zu dieser Familie und diesem Land aufrechterhalten. Da.
Es ist klar, dass eine gute Verbindung nach Großbritannien besteht. Die BP ist entscheidend.
Eine gute Verbindung nach Großbritannien besteht. Die DP ist entscheidend. Die Firma.
Die Firma, die am meisten Anteile hat an den Firmen, die jetzt engagiert sind in Aserbaidschan. Mit dabei ist auch die norwegische Statoil.
Firmen, die. Engagiert sind in.
Auch die norwegische Statoil. In gewisser Weise. Auch eine russische Firma mit.
Da ist auch die italienische Eni mit dabei. Es ist auch eine russische Firma mit dabei. Aber die BP ist die entscheidende Firma.
Eigentlich, was die Westkontakte angeht.
Die Pressemitteilung der Europäischen Kommission zu diesem Gas Deal, den man mit Aserbaidschan hatte.
Die lautet ja. Die Vereinbarung enthält die Verpflichtung, die Kapazität des südlichen Gas Korridors zu verdoppeln, um der EU bis 2027 jährlich mindestens 20 Milliarden Kubikmeter zu liefern.
Das wird zu den Diversifizierung Zielen des Repower EU Plans beitragen und Europa dabei helfen, die Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas zu beenden.
Und diese angedachten 20 Milliarden Kubikmeter, die würden dann nur 12 % des gesamteuropäischen Gasimporte 21 decken.
Also in diesem Verhältnis sind wir da aber immerhin 12 %. Ist dann schon mal was. Wenn man sagt, jetzt war 40 %, komme ich von Russland und man hat das stark drosseln können, insgesamt jeder.
Also mittlerweile glaubt man ja, jeder einzelne Prozentpunkt senkt so ein bisschen das Stresslevel und man sollte froh sein, wenn man dann zweistellige Prozentwerte hört, die schon mal gesichert sind.
Schwester will ja froh sein, wenn jemand im zweistelligen Prozentbereich schon mal gesichert. Ja, eines der vielen.
Ist großes Aufatmen angesagt bei vielen, die das da regeln müssen. Und entsprechend versucht man sich da bedeckt zu halten, zum Beispiel von der Bundesregierung aus und will jetzt da nicht über diesen.
Und entsprechend versucht man sich da bedeckt zu halten, zum Beispiel von der Bundesregierung aus und will jetzt dann nicht über diesen Angriffskrieg sprechen.
Angriffskrieg sprechen kann man da so eine schöne Formulierung auch in dem Weltzeit Podcast zu den neuen Autokraten, mit dem wir jetzt paktieren.
Caroline Born hat da so eine schöne Formulierung auch in dem Weltzeit Podcast zu den neuen Autokraten, mit denen wir jetzt paktieren.
Spielen denn so etwas wie Menschenrechte und Demokratie dabei jetzt eine Rolle, wenn man auf Länder zugeht?
So etwas wie Menschenrechte und Demokratie dabei jetzt eine Rolle, wenn man auf Länder zugeht? Keine große.
Keine große im Moment. Wir hatten ja zum Beispiel auch den US Präsidenten Biden in Saudiarabien.
Bei den Saudis. Ich habe ihn zwar schon erwähnt.
Ich habe Habeck in Katar schon erwähnt.
Das habe ich in Katar schon erwähnt. Es gibt zwar die Kritik, dass man.
Es gibt zwar die Kritik, dass man jetzt einfach einen autokratischen Herrscher durch einen anderen ersetzt.
Es gibt zwar die Kritik, dass man jetzt einfach einen autokratischen Herrscher durch einen anderen ersetzt. Man will jetzt aber darauf achten, dass.
Man will jetzt aber darauf achten, dass man nicht zu stark auf nur ein autokratisches System vertraut.
Dann will es aber darauf achten.
Desto verrückter wegen ihr. Wir gehen ja nur auf die Länder zu, weil das für uns angeblich so eine große Rolle spielt.
Sondern auf mehrere Länder. Weil das für uns eine große Rolle spielt.
Ja, und dann spielt aber keine Rolle, dass eigentlich kriegt man es nicht so richtig erklärt. Ne, ne, ne.
Und dann spielt aber keine große Rolle, dass eigentlich kriegt man es nicht so richtig erklärt.
Wir hören jetzt in der Deutschen Welle Joshua ku Sera, der über diese Eskalation folgendes sagt, also über die, die jetzt da stattfindet zwischen Aserbaidschan und Armenien.
Signifikanz Of this is at it's the the targets aserbaidschans targets this time are in Armenier proper,
Previous sly the fighting has been most in around the corner karabach which is international used as aserbaidschans territory,
the attacks are along Armenien communities along the the border inside or media which with the present a signifikant Eskalation in in aserbaidschans targeting.
Er sagt es damit auch nochmal. Die sind jetzt da auf armenischen Boden.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt nicht mehr sagen, na da ist mal irgendwas rüber geflogen. Oder bei Bergkarabach.
Das war auch schon ein zu verurteilende Angriff. Aber da kann man sagen ja, das rechnen die sich ja noch zu.
Aber hier ist es ganz klar eine Grenzverletzung. Also auch ganz klar das, was jetzt Olaf Scholz immer sagt, das geht nicht.
Das ist meine rote Linie. Aber diese rote Linie existiert da nicht.
Es gab auch einen interessanten Artikel von Anna Marietta Njan, die für T Online schrieb.
Doch nicht nur die Regierungskoalition aus SPD, Grünen und FDP ist hier zu kritisieren. Aserbaidschanische Lobbyisten haben über Jahre hinweg Einfluss auf die Bundes Fraktion der Union genommen.
Die sogenannte Aserbaidschan Connection war die Grundlage für regime freundliche Aussagen von Unionspolitikern und Lobbyarbeit für den Autokraten Alijew.
Also der ist uns jetzt lieb. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage wie muss Russland oder wie will Russland darauf reagieren?
Es ist ganz interessant. Armenien ist ja eigentlich mit Russland.
Da in so einer Verbindung, dass Russland sich,
in der Regel für die für die armenische Seite stark macht, aber immer deeskalierend in diese Konflikte eingreift, aber jetzt ja selbst einen Konflikt angezettelt hat und damit ja auch allerhand zu tun hat, wie wir wissen.
Und jetzt sind die da sehr zurückhaltend. Das kann man zum Beispiel daran erleben, dass Armeniens Präsident sich.
Bei Putin natürlich sofort nach dem Angriff meldet. Das ist dann quasi die erste Adresse, die man anruft.
Aber direkt danach telefonierte er schon mit Macron und ich glaube auch mit Michel von der EU.
Mit Blinken hat er dann telefoniert. Also Armenien merkt jetzt Russland hat gar keine Zeit, keine Lust sich noch einen weiteren Konflikt drauf zu schaffen.
Zumal ja Aserbaidschan und Türkei und wiederum Türkei und Putin dann noch mal! Es ist sehr, sehr vertrackt.
Dadurch, dass und jetzt hat also Armenien Macron und Blinken auch mal noch kontaktiert, interessanterweise dann nicht Scholz Zumindest habe ich das dann nicht erfahren. Und.
Hier ist also ein Land, das eigentlich Hilfe schreit von denen, die eigentlich da sind, da ein bisschen Regeln einzugreifen. Nichts erwartet, sich jetzt eigentlich nach Westen wendet und man denen jetzt aber zu verstehen gibt.
Wisst ihr, wir bekommen da ja diese 12 % bald so an Gas.
Eine. Ja, es ist wirklich dieses, dieses Paradox, dass wir, weil wir diese ganzen Menschenrecht Sachen so wichtig nehmen.
Ja.
Wir, weil wir. Diese ganzen Menschenrechte waren so wichtig nicht. Hm.
Vielleicht ist es wirklich, das ist aber auch da, es ist ja, es ist ein Krieg, weshalb wir uns von Russland abwenden.
Aber auch da. Es ist ja, es ist ein Trick. Weshalb?
Und gleichzeitig diese Hinwendung, ob es am Ende wirklich nur die Aufmerksamkeit ist medial.
Und gleichzeitig diese Hinwendung.
Genau. Wo liegt eigentlich Aserbaidschan? Könnte man fragen. Genau das sind diese Fragen, die sich ja dann da stellen. Also.
Wir haben auch einen Dominoeffekt. Du hast es ja eben so schön beschrieben. Putin hätte das wohl nicht gemacht, wenn Merkel jetzt noch an der Regierung wäre.
Also er hat gewartet, bis Trump weg ist, bis Merkel weg ist.
Jetzt hat er dann in seinen Augen Schwächere mit Scholz und Biden und.
Was macht jetzt Alijew? Naja, der hat auch abgewartet, bis Russland sich jetzt um diesen Konflikt, weil die waren damals bei Bergkarabach dann doch schnell dabei und haben gesagt Hallo, hier müssen wir mal einschreiten.
Und die haben natürlich jetzt auch auf das Momentum gewartet.
So schätzt es zumindest Gesine Blöd ein in dem besagten Podcast.
Also, dass das Mutterland getroffen wurde, also armenisches Land innerhalb seiner international anerkannten Grenzen. Das ist ganz, ganz wesentlich ein wesentlicher Punkt.
Und zwar deshalb, weil Armenien Mitglied ist in einem östlichen Militärbündnis, das heißt OVKS oder auch OKW, abgekürzt Russisch.
Das ist die Organisation des Vertrags über kollektive Sicherheit. Da sind sechs Staaten drin.
Das Ganze wird von Russland dominiert und es gibt dort eine Beistandsklausel. Deswegen hat sich Armenien bereits an diese OVKS gewandt. Nicht zum Ersten Mal.
Aber die Organisation, Die hat jetzt zwar getagt, hat aber keine Eingreiftruppe entsandt, sondern erst mal eine Mission, die sich ein Bild machen soll von der Lage und die feststellen soll, ob da überhaupt armenisches Gebiet angegriffen wurde.
Und man beruft sich darauf, dass ja die Grenze nicht markiert sei.
Und das Ganze, das lässt schon darauf schließen, dass die Organisation eben nicht gerade sehr scharf darauf ist, da wirklich aktiv zu werden.
Und es liegt unter anderem daran, dass die anderen Mitgliedsstaaten sowie zum Beispiel Kasachstan engere Verbindungen unterhalten zu Aserbaidschan als zu Armenien. Und deswegen Ja, kann sein.
Aserbaidschan möchte testen, wie weit Russland geht, aber wie weit auch die anderen OVKS Mitgliedsstaaten gehen.
Hm, das ist ja interessant, dass da so Bündnisse noch gibt, weil du hast ja eben kurz angemerkt, Putin hat gewartet, bis Trump weg ist. Da könne man ja auch.
Es gibt ja auch diesen Gegenentwurf, dass Trump eigentlich bleiben sollte für Putin, um dann in der zweiten Amtszeit Amerika aus der NATO zu nehmen.
Und dann greift da in der Ukraine lauter solche Sachen, Dass hier noch ein zweites Bündnis eine Rolle spielt, für das Putin jetzt gerade keine Zeit hat, ist natürlich interessant.
Also dass da über Historie so eine formale Verpflichtung eigentlich gäbe.
Und ich meine, für die Familie Alijew ist das eine enorme Bereicherung, jetzt auch im ganz persönlichen Sinne. Und das ist nicht nur Wir haben unsere Wirtschaft gestärkt, sondern wir haben uns reich gemacht.
Die waren natürlich auch gut dabei bei den Panama Papers.
Die haben drei Kinder und diese sind als Shareholder in 44 Firmen registriert auf den British Virgin Islands.
Und es gibt ja auch so einen Korruptionsindex und da steht Aserbaidschan auf Platz 128. Da ist man dann so in einer Nähe mit Myanmar.
Das ist ganz beachtlich. Wir hören jetzt Jason Palmer vom The Economist Podcast zu Aserbaidschan und den Frieden und dem Friedensabkommen.
Mind that what end of the war into was not a peace agreement by the seas fire in posted by Russia and talks about a possible peace settlement between Aserbaidschan und Armenien.
Out of the North Peace Agreement for the Seas Fire in Posted by Russia and.
Schlüsselmoment between Aserbaidschan und Armenien I have been in London I think round to place and Brussels by the. Im August.
Have been on going to latest round place and Brussels on this talks to media by the eu in late August September.
Dezember. Janning, President. Gabalier Wenn schon, dann per Twitter from a peace agreement.
De aserbaidschanische President Ilham Alijew mention that the months away from a peace agreement,
but and this is very big but Aserbaidschan wants Armenier under such a peace agreement to know it's on konditional.
Aserbaidschan warnt armenier und peace Agreement to dance in. Und nicht mit im.
Over. Na, na Karabach Armenier is not so queen for that and Armenien.
Armenier is not. Sie haben mir unter Garantie das Ohr.
Also garantiert for the regions ethnic Armeniens.
Also dieser Bergkarabach Konflikt liegt da auch immer noch drunter. Natürlich, das ist ja nicht gelöst, sondern das ist nun mal so eingestellt und das ist eigentlich so ein Befriedung Vertrag, nicht ein wirklicher Friedensvertrag, der da stattgefunden hat.
Maria Tizian in der Deutschen Welle sagt jetzt, warum dieser Konflikt so brisant ist.
This is a conflict that we need to pay more attention to because is going of a out years through various deals, but it never seems to go away.
Ein Komplett Buy Leave. Ein Teilchen zu entwickeln, das als Entwicklung bezeichnet. Die.
So absolutely because this is not only between Armenien, Aserbaidschan.
Das ist nicht neu. Between. Daher sage ich jenseits von religiöser.
We have to understand that turkey, which is a very close ali as strategic partner, John, and we know that turkey has many problems with all about snickers has been supported Aserbaidschan.
Ein. Als mein Vater zur Abwechslung. Karlsfeld.
There are a larger regional players in the region. There is eran there's turkey as I need a Russia these are players and the region given Russian invasion of prey the shipping political.
Aber sollte.
Und.
Der in den international order of this particular conflict city center box for a much larger regional conflict on the doors of Europe.
So ein neuer Konflikt zeichnet sich da möglicherweise ab vor den Türen Europas, weshalb das sehr ernst zu nehmen ist.
Wir würden jetzt noch mal eine Einschätzung von Samuel Lowery West dabei bei Al Jazeera.
When you look at a map of the kokosnüsse enzyme out you very quickly understand that its and extreme your strategic region a connex Eastern west,
when one insiders that there sanctions in Russia the moment meaning that for example energy or transportation of various times of the gods can no longer pass,
simply wen one zählt of Aserbaidschan Armenier and the general van ins Iran, which is another country, that's facing sanctions and its a result very simply that sei a Geografie,
that the staat Kaukasus meaning.
Aserbaidschan Armenier are becoming a bottle legt enormes impact in how,
different countries are the using this and wo their support and of course or so the incentives for both Aserbaidschan und Armenien to get the way to ort on another.
Intrigante Verhältnisse. Und noch eine weitere Einschätzung vom Direktor der Armenischen des Armenischen Nationalen Komitees in Amerika.
Noch mal ganz deutlich macht, um was es hier jetzt eigentlich geht für die Armenier.
This is Fundamentalismus the battle for the survival of the army in,
this is and existenziell struggle for the people for a nation for a people of experience genocide he still a haunted by the legacy other genocide today in the aggression at a experience of us revision by turkey.
This is the battle for the life of the army nation, but beyond that it all of the battle for democracy and a region of the world democracy is prevent a save if the international community stand by,
and the forest dictator in Ilham Alijew two in what a democratic country like armenier within,
the river of the world over it would be incredible dangerous and right now the international community needs to understand that.
There is no way that you can container and autoritäre expansion is regime like Russia by einem building just another autoritäre regime like Aserbaidschan.
Wir stehen hier vor der Konstellation, die beiden ja in seinen Reden ständig wiederholt.
Autokratie gegen Demokratie.
Die Demokratie wird vertreten durch Armenien. Die kämpfen hier für die Demokratie.
Man könnte jetzt auch wieder sagen, die kämpfen dort auch für uns.
Die kämpfen für ihre Unabhängigkeit. Und wir ziehen uns daraus sagen Wir haben noch nichts Genaues gesehen, wir wissen nichts.
Die EU äußerst vorsichtig. Und einen Tag später hält dann Ursula von der Leyen eine Rede im EU Parlament. Und ich habe jetzt mal drei Clips mitgebracht, die nichts mit Armenien Aserbaidschan zu tun haben.
Denn es geht natürlich um den anderen Krieg und wir sollten das aber jetzt einfach mal übertragen.
This is not only aware only set by Russia against Ukraine. This is also warn our energie.
It's a wall, our economy.
It's the war on our values. IT is a war on our future.
IT is about autokratie against democracy.
And I stand here with the convention that with the necessary courage and with a necessary solidarity.
Putin will fail and you Ukraine and Europe will preval.
Das ist natürlich dieses Aserbaidschan, sind ja nur 2 Millionen Leute. Aber es kann schon passieren, es sind ja nur wenige. Da ist ja keine Schlagkraft dahinter wie bei Russland. Also nimmt man es einfach so hin.
Genau. Aserbaidschan ist natürlich jetzt nicht in einem großen Bündnis drin, das uns gefährlich werden kann.
Bzw. Die sind da so lose verbunden, aber wir können die jetzt an uns ja binden und das ist dann das Entscheidende.
Wir haben es nicht mit einer Bedrohung zu tun für die NATO, ganz im Gegenteil. Man kann sich da Aserbeidschan gefügig machen mit entsprechenden Zahlungen und diese Familie Alijew weiter unterstützen.
Von der Leyen sagt weiter.
And I want to make it very clear. The sanctions are here to stay.
This is time for us for resolve and not for appeasement. This has to be very clear.
Wenn man das aber so rigoros ausdrückt gegenüber Russland, dann bedeutet das natürlich Und da wir aber weiter Energie brauchen und da wir weiter wirtschaften werden.
Können wir nicht einfach das jetzt irgendwie mit Frankreich lösen, sondern wir brauchen ja dann andere dafür.
Und damit begeben wir uns natürlich.
Je härter man dass vorträgt, desto mehr geht man auch in die Hände. Dann der Familie Alijew und Konsorten und dies noch zum Schluss.
My own other members. Ohne Lesen From this world is we should have need to those who know Putin zu Anna Politkowskaja and all the Russian journalists.
Expose The Crimes and Paid The Ultimate Price.
To Afrins in Ukraine, Moldova, Georgia and the Opposition in Belarus.
In Senju Klein Moldova, Georgia an die.
We should have listen to the voices inside Union and Poland in the Baltic and all across central and Eastern Europe.
Listen to the voices.
They have been telling us for years that Putin would not stop.
So, und jetzt müssen wir bitte das so beherzigen und sagen Lass uns doch dann nicht noch wieder einmal mehr den Fehler machen,
dann sonst können wir in drei, vier, fünf Jahren da sitzen und auch Namen aus Armenien aufzählen, auf die wir hätten hören sollen.
Hm, ich korrigiere noch mal Aserbaidschaner. 10 Millionen Einwohner, 2 Millionen. Ein Leben in Baku. Und das kennen wir ja. Eurovision Song Contest und so wir.
Korrigieren wir mal Aserbaidschaner. 10 Millionen Einwohner, 2 Millionen erleben den. Baku. Hm.
Genau da war schon die Baku Connection da.
Ja, wir können ja eigentlich sagen, das ist ein uns nicht ganz unbekanntes Land. Ja.
Es ist ein uns nicht ganz unbekanntes Land. Ja, und wir haben natürlich die Autokraten, nicht nur dort in noch relativ weiter Ferne, sondern wir haben sie jetzt auch sehr nah an uns herangerückt mit Italien.
Italien und Schweden. Diese schwedische Wahl war natürlich.
Italien und Schweden und Schweden. Ja.
Georg Diez hat einen Text geschrieben. Über dem Boom Faschismus in Italien und Schweden zeigt sich das destruktive Verhältnis von Kapitalismus und Demokratie seit der Finanzkrise ein wichtiger Punkt.
Georg Diez hat einen Text geschrieben über den Boom am Faschismus.
In Italien und Schweden zeigt sich das destruktive Verhältnis von Kapitalismus und Demokratie seit der Finanzkrise nicht überwunden.
Es gewinnt, wer von ökonomischer Ungleichheit ablenkt. Das gilt insbesondere für Italien, wo Jugendarbeitslosigkeit immer noch bei 30 % liegt und krasse Verarmung mittlerweile Raum greift.
Es gewinnt, wer von ökonomischer Ungleichheit ablenkt.
Das gilt insbesondere für Italien, wo Jugendarbeitslosigkeit nur noch bei 30 % liegt und krasse Verarmung mittlerweile raumgreifend ist.
Ist allerdings über Überschrift und Vorspann, was ich gerade vorgelesen habe Ein Text, der exklusiv nur für Abonnenten ist.
Allerdings über Überschrift und Vorspann, was ich gerade vorgelesen habe einen Text, der exklusiv nur für Abonnenten ist.
Und wie gesagt, ich bin zwar Abonnent, aber kein digitaler und deswegen weiß ich auch nicht genau, was er jetzt hier schrieb.
Und wie gesagt, ich bin zwar Abonnent, aber kein digitaler.
Du kannst das dann gedruckt noch mal bald lesen.
Aber bei den Schweden, das ist ganz interessant, weil wir jetzt immer so der Rechtsruck und so bei Schweden kann man noch mal kurz in die Zahlen gehen.
Diese Schwedendemokraten gibt es seit 1988 und seit 2010 sitzen sie im Reichstag. Und ihr Standardprogramm ist dieses rechte, migrations und familienpolitische, was man so kennt.
Allerdings haben sie sich auf den Klimaschutz verpflichtet. Also Paris halten Sie hoch.
Irgendwie so eine neue Wendung. Wahrscheinlich braucht man nur eine Bevölkerung, die es einfordert. Und dann ist man da auch selbst da populistisch mit am Werke.
Als Sie 2014 zur Europawahl antreten, forderten Sie auch einen Austritt aus der Europäischen Union.
Und nun haben Sie, wie wir hörten, so ein bisschen mit gewonnen. Aber Sie fuhren jetzt mit 20,5 % im Ergebnis ein. Das bedeutet nur plus 3 %.
Also Sie haben so ein Niveau also ein bisschen ausgebaut, das ich schon hatten und sind jetzt mit 73/349 Sitzen die zweitstärkste Fraktion.
Insgesamt muss man aber zu dieser Wahl sagen Die Regierung, also der Regierungs Block 48,87 %, hat 0,41 % verloren.
Die Opposition hat auf 49,59 genau diese 0,41 % gewonnen und damit hat die Regierung gewechselt.
Und Magdalena Andersen trat also zurück, weil sie die Mehrheit verlor, obwohl ihre Sozialdemokraten als Wahlgewinner 2,07 % noch mal zulegen konnten auf über 30 %.
Also es ist nicht dieser mega harte Rechtsruck, sondern die Schweden haben genau gesehen Hm, ja, es war halt vorher schon auf der Kippe mit 49 zu 51 und jetzt ist es halt.
Wieder auf der Kippe. Aber es hat sich einmal gewendet. Und da finde ich doch, ist es von den Zahlen her eine erhebliche Stabilität, weil durch was sind die durchgegangen im Vergleich zur letzten Wahl?
Die hatten ja diesen Corona Sonderweg und den Russland Überfall auf die Ukraine, also NATO Beitritt und so.
Also die konnten sich mal richtig über sich verständigen und sind dann auch sehenden Auges in das ein oder andere Katastrophen Tal da gemeinsam durchgelaufen und irgendwie relativ stabil. Und das ist eben ganz anders in Italien.
In Italien gibt es sechs Parteien über 5 %, obwohl dort ist es eine 4 % Klausel. Aber für uns das deutsche Gefühl sechs Parteien und es ist ein Hin und Her, Es ist unglaublich.
Diese Fratelli d'Italia, also die Brüder Italiens, gewannen nun mit 26 % plus 21,6 im Vergleich zur letzten Wahl.
Das ist also für so eine wirklich Rechtsaußenpartei ein erheblicher und auch für die Italiener ein ganz neues Ding.
Also da wachen auch viele auf und denken so, so, da müssen wir erst mal gucken, was jetzt ist. Also die haben sich auch selber so ein bisschen verunsichert damit.
Sie Melanie in der faschistischen Jugend tätig. Also da ist jetzt nicht mehr, dass man sagen kann, da die, wie das jetzt so mitunter zu lesen war, bis hin zur FAZ, das ist so bürgerlich dann am Ende doch, oder was?
Oder sie will ja das Land verbinden. Natürlich sagen die immer, dass sie das Land verbinden wollen und dass sie das innen wollen.
Aber das ist jetzt hier nicht mehr zu sagen.
Sie versucht selber gerade den Schreck einzufangen, indem sie sich ein bisschen moderat äußert. Und wir wissen aber da steckt mehr dahinter.
Ihr an die Seite jetzt Salvini mit der Lega 9 % Berlusconi, Forza Italia 8 %.
Das Bündnis kommt also auf 44 %, hat eigentlich keine Mehrheit, aber obsiegte doch, weil es dieses interessante Graben Wahlrecht gibt.
1/3 der Parlamentssitze ergeben sich aus relativen Mehrheitsverhältnissen, 2/3 über die Wahlkreise. Und da weiß man dann Winner takes all.
Da kommt es drauf an, das Bündnis so zu schmieden, dass man in der Fläche.
Dann einfach Da siegt ein Sieger pro Wahlkreis. Deswegen diese hohe Relevanz dieser Bündnisse und deswegen auch die Möglichkeit über einen geringeren popular vote dann trotzdem diese Regierungs Parlamentsmehrheit zu erringen.
Und genau, Melone ist kein unbeschriebenes Blatt, sondern sie trat ja 2012 schon mal im Streit aus der Regierung aus, gründete daraufhin also mit Berlusconi,
gründete daraufhin die Fratelli d'Italia, die wieder in so Erbe und Tradition von diesen rechten Parteien gestellt wurde.
Ging 2013 schon wieder ein Bündnis mit Berlusconi ein und hat halt heute diese eigenartige Partei, deren Parteilogo Logo eine Flamme über einen schwarzen Strich zeigt.
Und dieser schwarze Strich ist Mussolinis Sarg.
Also das ist auch auf so vielen Ebenen so bescheuert.
Deutlicher geht's ja dann nicht mehr. Ja. Würde man jetzt immer wieder. Die Italiener haben das eben ein bisschen anders verarbeitet.
Auf der anderen Seite hört man jetzt immer wieder Ja, die Italiener haben das Erbe so ein bisschen anders verarbeitet.
Nämlich kaum. Ja, hier muss man immer wieder sagen Ja, und das ist auch anders als mit Mussolini kann man noch so ein bisschen punkten.
Ja, also da, hier muss man ja nur Hitler sagen und alle hungern und das ist dort anders. Also mit Mussolini kann man noch so ein bisschen punkten.
Und auf der anderen Seite, die haben jetzt diese krasse europäische Abhängigkeit, die müssen jetzt also wirklich gucken, wie sie sich nicht komplett verspielen mit Europa, weil das ihre Einkommensquelle ist.
Und auf der anderen Seite, die haben jetzt diese krasse europäische Abhängigkeit. Die müssen jetzt also wirklich gucken, wie sie sich nicht komplett verspielen mit Europa, weil das ihre Einkommensquelle ist. Ja.
Ja, es wird jetzt gerade, auch wenn man jetzt immer so hört.
Es wird jetzt gerade, auch wenn man jetzt immer so hört, die Italiener, die wenig wie wir Deutsche, einfach für vier Jahre eine Regierung, die von sich aus, sondern die von jedem Halt so ein bisschen Angst macht und sagen sich dann erholt.
Na ja, die Italiener, die wählen nicht wie wir Deutsche, einfach für vier Jahre eine Regierung und liefern sich aus, sondern die vergeben halt so ein bisschen abends Macht und sagen sich dann Na gut, gucken wir mal, wie es läuft. Wenn nicht, verjagen wir sie vom Hof.
Man mal diese Leute nicht, verjagen sie vom Hof.
Entsprechend auch diese elf Monate Durchschnitts Regierungszeit über alle Regierungen seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, also seit der Nachkriegszeit.
Also mal schauen, wie weit Melanie es da treiben kann. Dass sie eine Frau ist, hat ja noch mal eine Rolle gespielt, nachdem Hillary Clinton sich äußerte mit Ich kenne sie nicht, aber das ist eine Frau. Es zeigt das ist ein Schritt nach vorn.
Also mal schauen, wie weit Melanie es da treiben kann. Dass sie eine Frau ist, hat ja noch mal eine Rolle gespielt, nachdem Hillary Clinton sich äußerte mit der Ich kenne sie nicht, aber das ist eine Frau zeigte diesen Schritt nach vorn.
Also Hillary Clinton ist wirklich so was von durch das Twitter noch mal anmerkte. Ja, das ist die Vollendung der Emanzipation. Wenn wir in allen auch Bösewicht, rollen jetzt Frauen ein als Normalfall. Und ja.
Während Florian Schröder noch mal anmerkte Ja, das ist die Vollendung der Emanzipation. Wenn wir in allen auch Bösewicht rollen, jetzt Frauen als Normalfall und akzeptabel da plötzlich aufspielen sehen Ich.
Auf Bienen sehen, die aber nicht. Eine feministische Ordnung einführen wird.
Das ist ja immer die Sache, der bleibt der genau da bleibt er.
Die Partei heißt Brüder Italiens. Per Satellit erhalten wir nur von einer Frau geleitet.
Das Patriarchat bleibt erhalten, wird nur von einer Frau geleitet. Ja.
Ja, genau. Kennen wir also ein bisschen Thatcher und so? Die haben sich da auch nichts geschenkt, oder?
Genau. Ich habe ja so ein bisschen Thatcher und so, die haben sich ja auch nichts geschenkt. Oder Merkel hat ihn verramscht wie geschenkt.
Merkel hat den Frauen auch nicht viel geschenkt. Na ja, ist jedenfalls eine interessante Konstellation, bei der es jetzt sehr drauf auch drauf ankommt, wie die Italiener das selber erstmal finden.
Na ja, ist jedenfalls eine interessante politische Konstellation, bei der es jetzt sehr darauf ankommt, wie die Italiener das.
Sollen wir uns mal eine Rede anhören? Ich habe einen Clip mitgebracht. Und zwar habe ich das als Video mitgebracht. Für uns, damit wir.
Ja, stimmt. Du hast ja. Für uns, damit wir.
Wir hören nämlich jetzt einfach nur sehr Italienisch sprechen. Das ist ja ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir nicht alle Sprachen können und deswegen uns auch immer stark aufs Englische und natürlich aufs Deutsche konzentrieren.
Wir hören nämlich jetzt einfach nur sehr Italienisch sprechen. Das ist ja ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir nicht alle Sprachen können und deswegen uns auch immer.
Englische und. Durch das Deutsche konzentrieren. Wir lesen jetzt den Untertitel mit und übersetzen so ein bisschen.
Wir lesen also jetzt den Untertitel mit und übersetzen den dann so ein bisschen hier für alle, also zwei Minuten vier und zehn dauert dieser Clip.
Okay, also zwei Minuten 14 dauert die. Hm? Okay. Let's go.
Oder einfach,
am Berg La Familia und.
Was sie hier fragt, ist Warum wird die Familie als Feind angesehen?
Warum fürchten sich alle vor der Familie? Also, das ist jetzt Ihre Behauptung.
In der Familie,
aber.
Und da gibt es auf solche Fragen nur eine einzige Antwort.
Identität.
Denn wir müssen übersetzen, dass es jetzt immer noch mehr aus dem Englischen deswegen wer weiß, was am Ende rauskommt, was sie eigentlich gesagt hat. Aber weil die Familie uns definiert, uns in unserer Identität.
Quest to tempo one, no one identity.
Identität. Denn das wird als Gefahr angesehen, dass jeder, der noch eine Identität hat, als gefährlich angesehen wird.
Wenn das sind Leute, die, die wollen, dass wir nicht länger eine Identität haben, die wollen uns unsere Identität rauben.
Also wir haben in Italien das Problem Jugendarbeitslosigkeit 30 % und das Auszugs Alter aus dem Elternhaus liegt bei 30 Jahren.
Es sind katastrophale Werte, allerdings ökonomisch erzwungen und nicht aufgrund.
Wir lieben die Familie so sehr und jetzt findet so ein Krieg gegen die Familie statt.
Also eben nicht auf der Ebene. Das ist ein bisschen, wie Georg Diez andeutete in seinem Text, den wir jetzt nicht kennen,
dass die einen großen Bogen um die ökonomischen Argumente machen und stattdessen glauben, die Familie sei hier irgendwie unter so einem wogendes Beschuss, obwohl man eigentlich mal die finanzielle Diskussion führen müsste.
Das geht schief, Abi. Perfekt.
Und man will Menschen ohne Identität und will eigentlich die perfekten Konsum Sklaven haben.
Nationale Identität.
Jetzt geht das weiter von der Familie. Der holt sie also alle mal ab. Diejenige hat irgendwie eine Familie.
Jetzt geht es um die nationale Identität, die attackiert wird, die religiöse Identität, die Gender Identität und wieder die Familien Identität.
Religiöse Identität, die eigene Identität, familiäre. Nun definiere italiana Christen. Christiana.
Und jetzt sagt sie, dass sie nicht mehr als es ihr nicht mehr erlaubt, es sich länger als Italienerin, Christen, Frau und Mutter zu definieren.
No. You the x general adventure uno de numero.
Und man wird nur noch zur Nummer gemacht. Man sei dann Bürger X mit dem Gender X und ist Eltern eins und Eltern zwei.
Und numero uno un Identität quando non rosarot.
Denn wenn man keine Identität mehr hat, dann ist man nur noch eine Nummer und ist der perfekte Sklave dann für die Finanzspekulanten.
Hmmm. Ist ja auch die Hochfinanz. Wer die Übersetzung.
Man sieht ja auch die Hochfinanz, also da wird so eine genau die Hochfinanz, die richtige Übersetzung. Also man hat ja dann so so eine strukturell antisemitische Verschwörung noch.
Und Übersetzung. Von deren Gnade man abhinge.
Plusquamperfekt hier de la Grande Spekulation. Die Konsumation perfekt.
Die Kunst einer Nation.
Orgie,
Orgie.
Und deswegen würde das jetzt auch alle erst mal so in Furcht versetzen, was was jetzt von ihnen da ausgeht.
Und damit hat man Tabora.
Genau diese jungen Medienschaffenden.
Perdita.
Sie wollen nicht länger Nummern sein. Sie werden sich verteidigen. Ihre Werte als Menschen. Human being.
Von Humana Persona Humana UNO, Dino Concordia Genetic.
Und das ist jetzt auch so eine interessante Formulierung, dass sie also because each of us has a unique genetic code that is an repeat stable.
Also diese.
Es wird jetzt schon in die DNA eingeschrieben. Die Originalität.
Ja, ja, dieser Verweis auf Genetik war ja was. Thilo Sarrazin damals.
Es war ja irre. Er, der dieses Deutschland schafft sich ab. Buch hin geschrieben.
Und da gab es auch was zur Genetik, dass irgendwas so vorbestimmt ist. Und so weiter und so fort.
Und das fand sehr viel Resonanz, weil da jetzt natürlich ein Dagegen kann man nicht argumentieren Punkt ist, weil es steht in der DNA, es ist sozusagen Gott oder Natur gegeben, wie auch immer.
Und dann hat er als nächstes Jahr ein Buch geschrieben über diesen genetischen Punkt, weil er merkte Ah, da räsonieren die Leute.
Und Kaube meinte damals naja, eigentlich über den schwächsten, inhaltlich schwächsten Punkt, das ganze Buch aufgezogen. Und so ist es hier auch wieder.
Sie kommt einfach mit diesem Unique Genetic Code, einfach nur um das so als Signal Ding zu setzen und muss verschleiern, dass sie keine Ahnung davon hat, was sie da sagt und was sie überhaupt meinen kann damit, sondern es ist wirklich nur so ein Signal fing.
Adel sacro die.
Und sie werden Gott verteidigen. Das Land, die Familie.
Adriana famiglia que sky no defender de la nostra liberta.
Berge neun und zehn. Remo Mai.
Und dann natürlich wird es noch mal dazu, dass sie nicht, dass sie die Freiheit verteidigen werden, niemals Sklaven werden wollen oder einfache,
Konsumenten, wie es die Hochfinanz möchte.
Ja, wir Simple schickt uns zu Spekulationen finanzierte Missionen. Herr Draghi?
Es war Chesterton.
Das ist die Mission. Und jetzt ist es interessant. Sie zitiert Gilbert Keith Chesterton, einen sehr katholischen Autor, der konservativer war, aber sehr kontraintuitiv ist.
Man kennt Chesterton auch natürlich als Autor, der Father Brown Krimi Romane und der sehr viele Essays geschrieben hat und jetzt hier noch mal an so einen Katholizismus zurückgeht.
Im Übrigen wurde das auch angedeutet, schon bei der.
Bei den Rechten in Houellebecqs Unterwerfung.
Da wird auch schon auf Chesterton Bezug genommen.
Für uns war.
Wo?
Sie sucht das Zitat.
Forge verändert die Zahl die per App.
Schade für die Familie. So verdiene State.
Ja, also es ist jetzt so, quasi der Mut muss da sein, dass man wieder benennt, dass zwei und zwei vier ist. Und manchmal ist das der.
Also gibt es Zeiten, wo das den größten Mut verlangt, also zu sagen, wie es ist und das ja, also wo man die einfachen Wahrheiten wieder aussprechen muss.
Zwei plus zwei. Vier.
Und das wird am ärgsten bekämpft. Und diese Zeit sagt sie dann, nachdem sie ihnen zitiert hat, diese Zeit sei nun gekommen. Wir sind bereit.
Sein Bruder Ricardo. Signore. Sie haben Grazie.
Grazie. Da bekommt man es mit der Angst zu tun.
Und zugleich haben wir dann auch in Deutschland doch interessante Entwicklungen, wie zum Beispiel ein Friedrich Merz, der bei der Bildzeitung ist und folgendes sagt.
Wir erleben mittlerweile einen Sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland, zurück in die Ukraine, nach Deutschland, zurück in die Ukraine.
Mehr als 1,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge insgesamt bisher, denen mittlerweile eine größere Zahl sich dieses System zunutze machen.
Da haben wir ein Problem, das wird größer. Wir haben im Frühjahr darauf hingewiesen, dass dieses Problem entstehen konnte. Die Bundesregierung hat sich taub gestellt.
So Was ist das jetzt bei Friedrich Merz gewesen? Er hat sich dann danach entschuldigt, wenn sich jemand davon beleidigt haben sollte.
Es war natürlich eine nicht Entschuldigung, die er abgeliefert hat und er argumentiert ja hier.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass er sich verhaspelt und irgendeinen Begriff verwendet.
Er will eigentlich Flüchtling sagen und sagt Asylant oder so etwas, wo man sagt Na, da hat er sich wohl versprochen oder das hat er nicht so gemeint, sondern es ist ein ganz klarer Argumentations aufbauen, das ist sehr wohlüberlegt, dass er das da vorträgt, das passiert einem ja nicht, das unterläuft einem nicht.
Meine These ist Friedrich Merz hat jetzt mal getestet Wie ist die Stimmung?
Ab wann kann man dazu übergehen? Es gab ja dann auch doch so den einen oder anderen wirklich aus der allerletzten Reihe der CDU, der auch sagte Ja, ja, die bilden sich ja weiß Gott was ein, die aus der Ukraine kommen.
Also man versucht jetzt schon mal so langsam deutlich zu machen, ja, die sollen da mal die NATO unterstützen, sage ich mal, aber die sollen nicht hier erwarten, dass wir es allzu glimpflich mit ihnen angehen.
Und dann ist auch bald wir machen das alles nur für die Menschen wieder vorbei.
Und sicherlich war jetzt Merz noch zu früh, Da hat ihn jetzt das Gespür auch ein bisschen verlassen.
Das müsste man dann schon machen. Wenn der der Winter sehr kalt wird, dann glaube ich, kann das schon besser zünden wieder.
Aber er hat es schon mal probiert, kriegt dann noch aus der eigenen Partei so ein bisschen was mit.
Aber es haben auch schon Ich habe dann mal so drauf geachtet, ganz viele CDU Leute schon mal seine Entschuldigung retweetet, direkt um zu sagen ja, wir wollen es ja, aber wir müssen auch mal schon vorsichtig sein, dass da nicht allzu viel Schindluder getrieben wird.
Also ich fand Robin Alexanders Erklärung dazu ganz gut. Der fühlt ja doch noch mal rein in die Partei. Wie wird es da aufgegriffen?
Erklärung dazu ganz gut. Der fühlt ja doch noch mal rein in die Partei. Wie wirds da so aufgegriffen?
Er meinte, die Testballon These ist schwierig, denn Friedrich Merz hatte in diesem Moment eigentlich einen Elfmeter vor sich liegen, weil das war ja zeitgleich mit. Auch Christian Lindner sagt dann irgendwann die Gas Umlage muss eigentlich weg.
Meinte die Testballon These Ist schwierig, denn Friedrich Merz hatte in diesem Moment eigentlich einen Elfmeter vor sich liegen, weil das war ja zeitgleich mit. Auch Christian Lindner sagt dann irgendwann die Gasanlage muss eigentlich weg. Ja, so.
So, und in diesem, diesem Moment hätte man ja wirklich die Partei, also jede Partei für sich, aber auch die Bundesregierung an sich so ein bisschen drauf einschlagen können, dass sie das nicht geregelt kriegen, dass sie keinen Ersatz haben für die Gas Umlage.
Und in diesem, diesem Moment hätte man ja wirklich die Partei, also jede Partei für sich, aber auch die unsrigen an sich so ein bisschen drauf einschlagen können, dass sie das nicht geregelt kriegen, dass sie keinen Ersatz haben für die Kreisumlage. Ich würde ja sagen die These vom letzten.
Ich würde ja weiterhin sagen, die These vom letzten Monat Habeck hat sie boykottiert im Sinne von Wenn ihr das wollt, lieber FDP, machen wir das, am Ende werdet ihr es kassieren müssen.
Habeck hat sie boykottiert und von.
Wollte er das aber. Aber ich mach mal, ich mache die so schlecht, damit die ihr die dann.
Genau, ich mache die so schlecht und alternativlos, dass am Ende ihr dran kleben bleibt.
Aber in ihrem Leben bleibt ein Leben das genau in die Falle gelaufen. Und. Und Alexander meint das so?
Und Lindner ist genau in die Falle gelaufen und Robin Alexander meint dann so Ja, das ist so, als hätte man diesen Elfmeter genommen, ein Handspiel draus gemacht, ihn rüber ins andere Tor, ins eigener und dann nochmal über die Linie geschoben.
Das ist so, als hätte man diesen Elfmeter genommen, ein Handspiel daraus gemacht, ihn rüber ins andere Tor, ins eigene und dann noch mal über die Linie geschoben.
Also bescheuerter geht es eigentlich gar nicht.
Also bescheuert geht es eigentlich gar nicht.
Und die Erklärung dafür war dann ja Friedrich Merz war halt auch einfach 20 Jahre nicht im politischen System.
Und die Erklärung dafür war dann ja Friedrich Merz war halt auch einfach 20 Jahre nicht am politischen System. Der weiß nämlich nicht, dass 2013 oder so Sozialtourismus zum Unwort des Jahres erklärt wurde. Aber das muss er doch wissen.
Der weiß nämlich nicht, dass 2013 oder so Sozialtourismus zum Unwort des Jahres erklärt wurde.
Was er und und ich, ich dachte mir auch wir sind ja wir haben doch alle noch vor Augen, wie Markus Söder da so saß und vom Asyltourismus.
Und so weiter. Und dann alle Diskussionen danach, wie er dann feststellte Ach so, ich muss hier gegen die Grünen arbeiten.
Okay, mach ich meine grüne Wende. Und dann hat man jahrelang sich darüber amüsiert, wie er eigentlich von diesem Sozialtourismus Asyltourismus, Dinge hin zum ach nee, ich muss jetzt für die Rettet die Bienen usw dieses ganze grüne Ding und es war komplett ausgeblendet bei Friedrich Merz.
Also man hat das überhaupt nicht gespürt, dass er da so ein historisches Bewusstsein, Debatten, Gedächtnis irgendwie hat und saß einfach,
völlig Banane und hat da diesen Sozialtourismus in einer Situation, wo man ja echt sagt nee, wir sind gerade ganz solidarisch mit den Ukrainern, und zwar flächendeckend und wir räumen auch gerade keine Turnhallen für die frei.
Also wenn man auch gar keine sachlichen Gründe, uns dagegen zu wenden, weil das Problem gerade nirgendwo an landet und aufläuft.
Und in der Hinsicht würde ich sagen, wir haben es hier mit klassischer Dummheit einfach zu tun gehabt. Das totale Unterschätzung, Überschätzung der Situation.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich halte das eher für für wahrscheinlich, dass er schaut, dass man doch wieder.
Also ich glaube, die CDU. Man hat es ja auch bei diesem Parteitag gemerkt, möchte über Identitätspolitik, also so wie Melanie uns das jetzt gerade vorgemacht hat, Wähler bekommen.
Und das wird man am Ende auch schaffen, indem man quasi eine Gemeinschaft als Wir sind das Volk sieht. Und dann gehören Ukrainer am Ende auch nicht dazu.
Die müssen sich dann auch dem fügen und sollen sich mal ja nicht zu viel herausnehmen.
Ich glaube, dass man schon in dieser Logik ist, inwieweit das jetzt Testballon war oder nicht. Ich glaube aber, dass das aus tiefstem Herzen kam.
Nun ist es ja so, dass wir es mit einer nach wie vor steigenden Inflation zu tun haben, dass wir es mit enormen Belastungen zu tun haben, die auch durch die Entlastung Pakete nicht ausgeglichen werden.
Wir hatten ihn schon einmal und ich bringe das jetzt wieder.
Helmut Schneeweiß hat sich zu Wort gemeldet. Er ist der Präsident der Deutschen Sparkassen und des Deutschen Sparkassen und Giroverbandes. Am 13 neun.
Hat er eine Rede gehalten, die man überhaupt nicht findet im Internet. Man findet nur so ein dürres PDF. Und in dieser Rede heißt es.
Ein enorm wichtiger Faktor für den deutschen Mittelstand und insbesondere von Konsum für Konsum nahe Branchen wird in den nächsten Monaten die Einkommenssituation und die Konsum neigung der privaten Haushalte sein.
Die erheblichen Preissteigerungen der letzten Monate sind ein massiver Dämpfer.
Bei den aktuellen Preissprünge benötigen nach unseren Berechnungen 60 % der Haushalte ihre gesamten monatlichen Einkünfte und mehr, um die laufenden Ausgaben zu decken.
Haushalte mit monatlichen Nettoeinkommen unter 3.000 € 3.600 € werden am Monatsende kein Geld mehr übrig haben und Lücken teilweise durch eigene Ersparnisse ausgleichen müssen.
Für Gastgewerbe, Tourismus, Einzelhandel und andere persönlichen Dienstleiter bedeutet das, dass Sie sich auf massive Änderungen im Kundenverhalten einstellen müssen.
Mit anderen Worten die kommen nicht mehr. Ich halte es deshalb für richtig, dass die Bundesregierung und die Koalitionsfraktionen mit einem dritten Paket reagieren.
Wichtig scheint mir allerdings und wir reden jetzt hier vom Präsident des Sparkassenverband.
Wichtig scheint mir allerdings, die Entlastungen auf Haushalte mit einem Nettoeinkommen bis 3.600 € zu konzentrieren.
Denn höhere Einkommen können, so zeigen Berechnungen netto immer noch zusätzlich Rücklagen bilden.
Die niedrigsten Einkommen stehen dabei zu Recht im Fokus der politischen Aufmerksamkeit, die ich empfehle allerdings auch die Einkommen von rund 2000 bis 3000 600 € monatlich nicht zu vergessen.
Die Betroffenen werden dies in der jetzigen Phase nicht in Angriff nehmen. Also ach so, genau dann geht es noch darum, dass jetzt eigentlich Geld da sein müsste, um zum Beispiel das Wohneigentum energetischer zu sanieren.
Und dann sagt er auch hier, die Betroffenen werden dies in der jetzigen Phase nicht in Angriff nehmen, wenn es hierfür nicht spürbare staatliche Anreize gibt.
Also das ist jetzt der Sparkassenverband und.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie wenig das in der Politik, also in der Ampelkoalition, verstanden wird. Und?
Und Sie haben Angst davor. Wir haben Angst. Ja. Also, das wissen Sie, wo es klemmt. Aber Sie haben Angst davor.
Sie haben Angst davor, das zu verstehen, oder?
Ja. Den Bruch dann herzustellen.
Es überhaupt so zu thematisieren, dass Ansprüche überhaupt entstehen, dass so eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft sich bilden.
Man sieht ja jetzt schon, wie Sie vorbeugen, indem Sie das Wohngeld wirklich, also die Zugänge zum Wohngeld, wirklich krass verbreitern.
Ich war ganz überrascht, die Zahlen zu hören, dass sie da so ein bisschen vorbeugen und erst mal politische Realität schaffen und dann sagen Wir haben es schon so ein bisschen geregelt, also holt euch mal Wohngeld oder so, damit man den Leuten nicht sofort eine Adresse gibt, wenn es dann so thematisiert wird.
Aber ja, es wird natürlich heikel, gerade für uns Deutsche, wo wir immer dachten, wir können so mit Nothilfe, Paketen und hier noch mal Rettungsaktionen da irgendwie durch.
Nein, wir müssen jetzt jetzt wirklich ein bisschen strukturell umbauen. Und ich.
Na ja, und man kann ja sehen, was so passiert. Also ich bekam eine Nachricht von einem Hörer, der in der Oberstufe noch ist.
Und er hat gesagt, er würde mir jetzt mal ein Video schicken, das seine Klassenkameraden ganz toll finden und er sei da sehr erschrocken darüber. Und das war ein Tick Tock Video.
Mit Alice Weidel aber nicht von Alice Weidel hochgeladen, sondern von irgendeinem Account. Dieser Account hat ein paar andere Politiker Videos hochgeladen, hat damit zehn 20.000 Aufrufe.
Nicht der Rede wert. Also dieses Alice Weidel Video, das wir uns jetzt gleich anhören,
das hat 4 Millionen Aufrufe und 500.000 Likes und die Kommentare 13.000.
Ich habe nicht alle gelesen, aber einige. Da stand.
Ja, ich finde die AfD ja scheiße, aber hier hat sie wirklich recht, oder?
Eigentlich dachte ich immer, die AfD ist nicht meine Partei. Aber vielleicht jetzt doch.
Solche Kommentare waren da, oder Weidel ist einfach die richtige Politikerin. Sie spricht es aus.
Das waren die Reaktionen und wir hören uns jetzt mal an! Das ist so ein Video, in dem EIKE Weidel nicht wie viele andere Politiker herumtanzt oder sonst was, weil man glaubt, das muss man auch tun, sondern sie sagt folgendes.
Die Leute werden auf die Straße gehen. Den ganzen Winter lang.
Was fällt solchen Politikern eigentlich ein, die sich hier irgendwie durch die Gegend fahren lassen? Irgendwie den Leuten vorzuschreiben, wie viel sie verbrauchen, mit dem Waschlappen zu duschen, kalt zu duschen? Sollen sie irgendwas frieren und hier und da?
Das ist so unfassbar unseriös und unglaublich verblödet, dass es nur so kracht. Und natürlich werden die Leute dagegen auf die Straße gehen, weil sie nachher nichts mehr haben. Was glauben Sie denn, wie das hier weitergeht?
Die Menschen werden reihenweise ihre Jobs verlieren. Wer soll das denn alles noch bezahlen?
Was glauben Sie, was hier in Deutschland los ist? Wir haben nicht mal im Geringsten einen strategischen Lösungsansatz, um dem überhaupt zu begegnen.
Das ist unverantwortlich.
Darum habe ich auch gestern in meiner Rede gesagt Die Menschen haben alles Recht, auf die Straße zu gehen gegen diese Politik, gegen diese Regierung, die sie eiskalt auflaufen lassen. Die haben doch gar nichts mehr.
Wir haben eine sterbende Währung, die Leute.
Die Menschen können doch gar nicht mehr sparen. Das geht doch alles für die Lebenshaltungskosten drauf.
Wir sind mit diesem Sound darunter und das ist ein Video, das 4 Millionen Aufrufe hat. Und wir haben jetzt sehr viele über Facebook geredet und von der Boomer Generation, die da auf Fake News reinfällt und sich am Ende nicht impfen lässt.
Und das geht natürlich bei jungen Leuten viral, die plötzlich sagen na ja, die, die spricht ja eigentlich die Wahrheit aus.
Also ich würde sagen, da braut sich auf Think Tank einiges gerade zusammen, denn die AfD ist da sehr stark vertreten. Aus diesen ganzen Videos, aus den ganzen Auftritten im Bundestag werden solche Clips geschnitten.
Da gibt es dann diese Musik darunter. Und die Tatsache ist ja, dass wir von der Ampel du hast jetzt da Beispiel genannt, aber wir bekommen da eigentlich viel zu wenig, wenn man bedenkt, wie hart der Winter werden wird.
Und ich finde auch, dass die Berichterstattung da zum Teil vollkommen schief läuft, also man gar nicht das Leid der Menschen in den Mittelpunkt rückt und dann sagt, was politisch zu tun werde.
Auch bei diesem Funk Format wird ja nicht mal wirklich dann über Schuldenbremse oder so gesprochen oder wenn es um wirkliche Zahlungen geht.
Oder man hat dann hier so ein Format wie ZDF inside, so ein YouTube Format, wo dann eine Andrea Maurer sagt ja, rechts und links, die wollen ja beide demonstrieren.
Ach, die sind ja irgendwie dann auch ähnlich. Also wieder so eine Hufeisen Theorie Schmiede und der Beitrag endet dann mit solchen Worten.
Was meint ihr, wird sich das bei Protesten auseinanderhalten lassen, wer links und wer rechts ist? Wird dieser Herbst heiß oder bleibt das ein politischer Traum von Linken und Rechten?
Und was müsste die Regierung eurer Meinung nach tun, damit es nicht zu Massenprotesten oder Unruhen kommt?
Ja. Es ist ja nicht einfach nur ein Traum.
Also es wird ja so getan, als wäre das irgendwie die, die die Linken träumen einfach nur von irgendeinem Aufstand.
Es gibt ja einfach probate Gründe, warum man da auf die Straße gehen würde. Und ich fand es auch so toll, dass wir sofort dieses allgemeine Framing haben. Ja, dann sollen die.
Was ist, wenn da Leute demonstrieren und da aber noch irgendwo sich Rechte dazu gesellen?
Ich fand sehr schön da einen Tweet, weil ich ja in gewisser Weise auch Fan des Whataboutism bin von Ole bei einem lieben Podcast Kollegen.
Und zwar hatte Thilo da angekündigt Kanzler Scholz reist Ende der Woche unter anderem nach Saudi Arabien, um zum Beispiel mit dem Kronprinzen sich zu treffen.
Und dann hat Ole darüber geschrieben.
Aber gut, aufpassen. Also jetzt an unsere Demonstranten. Aber gut aufpassen, wer neben euch bei der heißen Herbst Demonstration steht.
Also da sagt man sofort ja, wenn da irgendjemand ist, der, der nicht links ist, dann ist das falsch.
Und ich sehe das auch als was Falsches an, aber wir müssen auch zugleich erkennen, dass die Bundesregierung die ganze Zeit neben irgendwelchen Leuten stehen kann, die nicht auf dem demokratischen, liberalen Boden stehen.
Und ich warne wirklich sehr davor, das einfach nur als so eine Geschichte da zu verkaufen, sondern es ist einfach reales Leid.
Das ist, wenn die Familie kein Geld mehr hat für die Kinder.
Wenn nicht mehr entsprechend geheizt werden kann, dann ist das ein reales.
Leider entsteht, was da entstanden ist und die gucken nicht vorher noch mal in YouTube Clip und lassen sich über irgendwelche Konstellationen und Querfront aufklären, sondern die haben dann einfach kein Geld.
Ja, vor allem, wenn jetzt Menschen auf die Straße gehen, dann wissen wir doch wirklich, warum.
Dann müssen wir die Frage Ist das jetzt rechts oder links oder beides gar nicht klären, weil ist ja egal.
Also das ist ja nur der Anlass. Der Grund ist ja dann trotzdem ein anderer.
Wir werden im Salon. Ich hatte es schon letzten Monat.
Es ist so eine interessante Textgrundlage. Es gibt einen Autor, Markus oder Martin Rückert,
der schreibt so für die Frankfurter Rundschau, Der hat immer so zusammengestellt, was es eigentlich bedeutete, die Kinder in Corona so ein bisschen sich selbst zu überlassen.
So 54 % plus diagnostizierte Essstörungen bei Mädchen, 15 bis 17 Jahre Adipositas plus im zweistelligen Prozentbereich. Und so weiter.
Und wir kommen jetzt in so eine Lage, wo wir bei den Familien sehen okay, die sparen jetzt und die werden aber nicht Hunger leiden, sondern die werden sich nur ungesund ernähren.
Und das führt ja dann auch wieder zu Folgen psychischer und körperlicher Natur.
Also wir haben es ja mit so einem wirklichen konstitutionellen Abwärtstrend sozusagen zu tun durch diesen Preisdruck, der da jetzt entsteht.
Und ich finde, wir sollten da viel mehr auf diese psychischen und physischen Konstellationen und Konstitution schauen als diese.
Was man halt typischerweise bei Funk dann nochmal. Ist es jetzt? Ist das jetzt die Vollendung des Hufe Eisens?
Und so weiter. So ein Halligalli aus solchen Argumentationen zu drehen, sondern sich wirklich mal jetzt diese materielle Grundlage anzuschauen, was passiert da eigentlich und in deren Sicht?
Ja, die schauen jetzt diesen Tick tack, dieses Tick tack Minütchen, sag ich mal so,
wir wissen bei aus dieser Facebook Diskussion gerade 2016 Wahl in Amerika Man kann mit ganz schön wenig Einfluss für ganz schön viele Wellen sorgen, gerade weil das Publikum ja zehn Stunden am Tag online ist.
In der Hinsicht ja, so ein Video 4 Millionen Views, aber diese 4 Millionen runtergebrochen auf eine Minute im Verhältnis zu wie viel tik tok Zeit, die so durchrauschen.
Also ich sehe da noch Potenzial, zum einen zu sagen ja, die sehen das und verhalten sich dazu.
Aber es könnte auch Anlass für ein Gespräch sein. Also dann heißt es zum Beispiel Wache Lehrerschaft, weil eine Minute ist nicht allzu viel Indoktrination dafür, dass da noch relativ mehr Abläufen eine.
Man kommt natürlich schnell weiter. Ich habe es mir dann zwei drei mal angesehen bekommen, natürlich entsprechendes dann sofort offeriert, was in eine ähnliche Richtung geht.
Genau. Die Rabbit Hole Gefahr ist groß. Dauert nicht lang.
Das dauert nicht lang. Ich würde noch mal einen kleinen Sprung machen zu einem Moderator, der im Tomorrow Podcast zu Gast war.
Ich wird noch mal einen kleinen Sprung machen zu.
Einem Moderator der im Tomorrow Podcast mit der Sound zwar nicht der.
Und zwar nicht der amerikanische Tomorrow Podcast, sondern der deutsche Marketing Podcast von Tom Junkers Dorf.
Deutsche. Ja doch. Und zwar. Kennst du Ricardo Vasile? Nein.
Und zwar kennst du Ricardo Basile?
Ich auch, kAnnte ihn natürlich auch nicht. Das ist ein Sky Moderator, der ganz, ganz populär wohl bei den Fußballern ist, also bei den Fußballern. Ich weiß. Mir sagte man, bei den Fußballfans sei der nicht populär.
Da war der ganz, ganz. Populär wohl bei. Fußballern. Hm.
Populär. Familien. Das ist. Also, das war immer dieses.
Das hat mir dann Freunde, die Fußball gucken, sofort gesagt. Das glaube ich sofort.
Bela Rethy moderiert wieder. Oh, Scheiße. Aber dabei fanden alle Bela Rethy super geil, wenn er die Spiele moderiert hat. Es ist immer so ein bisschen.
Aber hier, glaube ich, ist das nicht so! Also hier ist es. So sagte man mir das zumindest. Mir ist es auch egal, denn ich werde ja niemals Fußball gucken.
Nur greife ich das raus, weil ich es so kurios Fantasy es mitbringen wollte.
Wir haben jetzt schon über Identität gesprochen und irgendwie ist das ja so etwas, was alle umtreibt.
Und statt über Ökonomisches zu sprechen, möchte man dann lieber sagen Ja,
lasst uns noch mal über Äpfel reden, die schönen englischen Äpfel, wie Ellis Trust sagt, oder hier Melonen, die noch mal von der Kirche und der Familie und ich zitiere ist Chesterton.
Und zugleich haben wir es aber ja immer mit Figuren auch zu tun. Alice Weidel wäre ja auch so ein Beispiel dafür, die.
Ein modernes Leben führen. Das ist eigentlich mit dieser Identität, die sie darauf beschwören, gar nicht viel zu tun hat.
Und dennoch gibt es aber diese Suche und die Sehnsucht danach. Jeder Disney Film befriedigt sie inzwischen.
Das heißt, ich würde generell so einen aufkommenden Tribalismus wahrnehmen wollen, und zwar global. Und dann findet man das manchmal so in der Schwundstufe.
Und da wird es dann so besonders kurios, aber vielleicht auch fassbar.
Und deswegen aus diesem Tomorrow Podcast hören wir jetzt Ricardo Basile, der da von seiner Karriere erzählt und der jetzt aber erst einmal erläutert, dass er ein Jahr im Hotel gewohnt hat.
Es gibt eigentlich nichts, was ich jetzt in der Hotel Zeit vermisst habe. Weil ich eh viel unterwegs bin, habe ich da dann auch mal ein, zwei Leute getroffen.
Es war eine schöne Zeit. Es gibt nichts, was ich tatsächlich, als ich im Hotel gelebt habe, an einer normalen Wohnung vermisst habe.
Jetzt bin ich erst in der Wohnung, seit. Als wir uns getroffen haben, war die erste Nacht.
Da war ich zwischenzeitlich drei Nächte wieder weg, habe jetzt glaube ich, insgesamt vier Nächte da geschlafen.
Es ist schön. Ich könnte jederzeit wieder ins Hotel ziehen.
Ein Leben im Hotel. Ein ganzes Jahr. Wir kennen das sonst nur von Udo Lindenberg, der das einfach jetzt zu seiner Heimat gemacht hat, an einem Ort, der eigentlich für den Durchgangsverkehr ist, dann zu bleiben. Aber er kommt damit zurecht.
Der hat doch keine Bindung eigentlich an Möbel oder so, und deswegen war das kein Problem für ihn.
Noch was betont er hier?
Ich liebe Flughäfen. Ich liebe Flughäfen. So unglaublich. Ich liebe Hotels. Deswegen habe ich da gewohnt.
Unglaublich. Ich liebe Hotels. Sein. Nun.
Ich liebe auch dieses Schnelllebige. Wenn ich auch dann im Flug am Flughafen bin und die Leute beobachte und sehe, die kommen von dort oder von dort, wenn ich den Flughafen betrete und diese großen Anzeigetafeln sehe.
Ich liebe auch dieses Schnelllebige. Wenn ich auch dann im Flieger am Flughafen bin und die Leute beobachte und sehe von dorther von dort, wenn ich den Flughafen betrete, diese großen Anzeigetafeln der.
Das gibt mir schon ein Gefühl der Freiheit.
Das geht nicht. Freiheit so, wir haben. Ja, aber ich dachte, das nutzt sich relativ zügig ab.
Ich dachte, ich weiß, was er meint, aber ich dachte, das nutzt sich relativ zügig ab. Aber anscheinend nicht.
Offenbar nicht. Man würde ja jetzt sagen so ein Mensch, der ein Jahr im Hotel leben kann, der eigentlich nur an Flughäfen unterwegs ist, der braucht jetzt ja nicht noch irgendeine Identität.
Aber vielleicht gerade das produziert ja noch mal besonders stark diese Sehnsucht nach irgendeiner merkwürdigen Identität, auch nach einer Pseudo Theorie.
Denn bevor wir zum Thema Identität kommen, gehen wir jetzt erst mal zur Bändchen Theorie über.
Hast du schon mal von der Bändchen Theorie gehört, Stefan?
Na ja, jetzt macht es ja auch was gefasst. Was? Jetzt wird's richtig kompliziert, mein Lieber.
Was der Kommunikationswissenschaften, Politikwissenschaften und Romanistik studiert. Da ist ja ist alles cool, aber da ist ja kein Fashion Bezug. Das stimmt.
Der Studierte ist. Ja, ist alles gut. Aber er ist ja kein Fachmann dazu. Das stimmt. Ich berate die Berufe.
Ich verrate dir, warum ich das studiert habe Weil Marcel Reif, mein Ziehvater, mir gesagt hat, ich solle das studieren.
Bei Maserati. Mein Ziehvater, der nie gesagt hat, ich solle das studieren.
Er hat das ähnlich studiert, nur nicht Romanistik, sondern Amerikanistik.
Er hat das Englische studiert, nicht als ich, sondern Amerikanistik.
Stattdessen noch zu Politik und Journalismus. Und ich habe ein Praktikum gemacht bei Sky und dann wollte ich gerne länger bei Sky bleiben.
Noch zur Politik. Junge Journalisten und ich habe ein Praktikum gemacht.
Und dann wollte ich gerne länger bei.
Und dann hatte Marcel Reif mir aber gesagt Junge, pass auf, es gibt die Bändchen Theorie und von der Bändchen Theorie bin ich nach wie vor überzeugt.
Doris Augustin die Bändchen der.
Jetzt lassen wir mal die Katze aus dem Sack.
Und die Bändchen Theorie besagt, man soll so viele Bändchen sammeln wie eben möglich.
Man soll so viele Bändchen sammeln wie möglich. Abitur ist ein Bändchen. Das berechtigt nicht.
Abitur ist ein Bändchen, das berechtigt dich die nächste Tür zu öffnen und sie auch zu durchschreiten. Das war dann mein Studium, was ich eigentlich nicht machen wollte, weil ich gedacht habe, ich bleibe direkt bei Sky.
Erste Tür zu öffnen und sie auf. Zu beschreiben. Das war dann mein Studium.
Ich bleibe direkt bei Sky. Nein, ich mache erst das Studium.
Nein, mach erst das Studium, da sammelst du das nächste Bändchen.
Da sammelst du das nächste Bändchen und du gehst zum Leben. Warum immer weitere Menschen zusammen? Dass man immer die Möglichkeit hat.
Und so geht es im Leben darum, immer weitere Bändchen zu sammeln. Dass man immer die Möglichkeit hat, wenn irgendwann mal ein Türsteher vor der Tür steht und sagt Du kommst ja nicht rein, deine Hand zu heben und zu sagen Du, ich habe aber das Bändchen, ich bin berechtigt, hier reinzugehen.
Wenn ihn war mal ein Türsteher vor der. Steht und sagt Du kommst nicht rein. Dann hat sie. Die Terroristin.
Genial, oder? Ja, in der Regel helfen schon mal höhere Schulabschlüsse.
In der Regel ist es gut, wenn man mehrere Sachen kann. Viele Sprachen ist auch oft hilfreich. Es ist sehr merkwürdig.
Es ist sehr merkwürdig, weil auf der einen Seite ist er dieses Ich bin Kosmopolit oder wie wir sagen würden Lost, wenn der egal in welchem Hotel wohnst.
Auf der einen Seite dieses Ich bin Kosmopolit oder wie wir sagen würden Du hast ja in der egal in welchem Hotel wohnst.
Weil ich würde ja mal sagen, es ist egal in welcher Wohnung man wohnt, solange die Nachbarschaft hinhaut und man weiß wer steht. Ja, wir waren zur Verfügung und für was?
Weil ich würde ja mal sagen, es ist egal, in welcher Wohnung man wohnt, solange die Nachbarschaft hinhaut und man weiß, wer steht dir zur Verfügung und für was.
Also diese soziale Dimension einfach zu klären, wenn man einfach ins Hotel geht oder sich im Flughafen wohlfühlt, da weiß man, da kann man dann irgendwo hin.
Aber der Ort selber ist sozusagen Transit.
Aber der Ort selber ist sozusagen Transit, ist Transit.
So dass man dann anfängt mit so einer Bändchen Theorie, also sich zu verorten, indem man seine Persönlichkeit ganz an die Erwartungen der Umwelt bindet und sagt wir müssen ja gar kein Wort wechseln, ich zeige dir einfach meinen Abschluss.
Das ist natürlich total Banane, denn ich habe auch so eine Art Bändchen Theorie, die jetzt gerade in meinem Leben so ein bisschen greift, dass ich mir denke Warum werde ich nicht, also warum engagiere ich mich nicht mehr so?
Dann ist der Förderverein der Schule und der Schwimmverein und plötzlich ist man halt nicht nur Mitglied, sondern so zweiter Vorsitzender und so was.
Und das ist aber ganz anders gemeint als bei ihm, denn ich gehe ja nicht da hin und sage Guck mal, wer ich bin!
Zu zweite Vorsitzender des Soundso, sondern nein, ich bin natürlich der zweite Vorsitzende. Und damit wir alle, die schon da sind und mich kennen, der Ansprechpartner für die alltäglichen Probleme.
Also ich bin gerade da. Für diese Gespräche, die er vermeiden möchte, ist also eine genau umgedrehte Bändchen Theorie, nämlich eine, die sozusagen mit sozialem Gehalt gefüllt ist und nicht mit als Shortcut gemeint ist.
Und das finde ich natürlich unter dieser, da es bei mir jetzt auch relativ neu ist, wirklich so ein paar Monate.
Also die Erfahrung, die so langsam aufbaut, einfach auch mal so ein bisschen eine Rolle zu spielen.
Und so ist das natürlich ganz schade zu hören, dass er das als diese Art Abkürzung benutzt und nicht als Enabler, weil das er das Türsteher Ding, das heißt ja, da geht es mir nur um mich und den Abend.
Und am nächsten Tag bin ich schon wieder im Flughafen und dann schon wieder in irgendeinem Hotel und tauche dann eben nicht wieder auf, wo mich der Türsteher auch schon mal kennenlernen kann, sondern nein, ich brauche mein Bändchen.
Man kommt rein. Und absurd ist es ja auch, dass man das noch mit dem Begriff Theorie belegt.
Da sieht er auch, dass man das. Mit dem Begriff Theorie belegt?
Das zeigt ja, es gibt so eine große Orientierungslosigkeit. Ich würde sagen, diese Orientierungslosigkeit ist immens, wenn du dir Instagram Kacheln ansiehst. Und das hier ist ja einfach die geschlossene Instagram Kachel, die wir, die ich euch jetzt hier vorführe. Und es kommt noch mehr.
Ja, es gibt so eine große Orientierungslosigkeit. Absolut Orientierungslosigkeit. Ist immens, wenn du dir instagram.
Na ja, die gesprochene Instagram. Das stimmt.
Aber das ist ja eh da. Wenn man einmal hier Luhmann Soziologie studiert und dann kommt irgendwer mit irgendeiner Theorie, sagt man Nein, das ist eine Idee, über die kann man jetzt ne halbe Stunde reden, aber das war's. Und das ist hier eben auch.
Ja.
Ja, es ist keine Theorie. Ist es keine Theorie. Und nun? Er sammelt auch uhren.
Er sammelt auch Frauen. Wer hätte es? Ja, es. Bändchen. Es ist ein Bändchen.
Wer hätte es gedacht? Es ist ja auch so etwas. Ganz ist es auch ein Mensch.
Und das hat er ja auch gemein mit all den wunderbaren Fußballern vom FC Bayern.
Denn was gibt es Schöneres, als uhren irgendwo hinzulegen? Und er hat eine.
Oder Mappe und beschreibt jetzt mal da seine fast identitäre Verbindung zu.
Ich Mag an der Royal Oak, Ehrlich. Aber ich. Ich. Ich liebe Blau. Diese blauen Zifferblatt. Dann diese uhr, die hat. Die hat was.
Diese uhr.
Ehrlicherweise, finde ich zumindest, hat sie was Mystisches. Ich bin früher sehr oft mit meinen Eltern am Meer gewesen und oft waren wir segeln, weil mein Vater unter anderem Kapitän war.
Was ist?
Bin früher.
Und immer, wenn ich in diese uhr blicke. Ehrlicherweise kommt es mir so vor, als ob ich auf das Meer blicke und deswegen habe ich die uhr wirklich sehr, sehr oft mittlerweile an!
Münchens public.
Die beruhigt mich unheimlich. Dieser dieser Blauton des Ziffernblatt ist.
Sie beruhigt mich unheimlich.
Der braucht ganz dringend einen Therapeuten, denn diese uhr zeichnet sich nur dadurch aus, dass sie relativ viel Wert auf ganz wenig Volumen und Gewicht vereinigt. Das heißt, es klappt zu seinem mobilen Lebensstil. Die kann er immer bei sich tragen, ohne sie als Gepäck noch mit verrechnet werden muss.
Der braucht, dann trinken Therapeuten oder zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass sie relativ viel Wert auf ganz wenig Volumen und Gewicht vereinigt.
Das heißt zu seinem mobilen Lebensstil kann er bei sich tragen, ohne sie als Gepäck noch mitgerechnet werden muss.
Und diese Art von materieller Abhängigkeit ist ja wirklich grotesk.
Aber das ist die Denkweise. So wird eine materielle Abhängigkeit hergestellt, dass man das jetzt auflädt mit eigener Geschichte oder die Unternehmen dann mit ihrer Geschichte es quer und Boltanski sprechen ja von der Bereicherung der Ökonomie.
In eigener Geschichte. Die Unternehmen,
Esquire und Boltanski sprechen hier von der Bereicherung der Ökonomie. Absolutes Opfer der Typ bereichern das Produkt.
Und das ist jetzt wirklich dieses Ich bereichert das Produkt auch noch mal selbst.
Das ist nämlich nur die Geschichte des mit dem Herstellen, dass der Schon vor 200 Jahren haben wir na, ich sage Ihnen noch selbst. Das erinnert mich an das Meer, wo ich unlängst wurde. Ja, dann.
Also ich nehme nicht nur die Geschichte des uhrenhersteller, der sagt schon vor 200 Jahren haben wir, sondern ich sage auch noch mal selbst Das erinnert mich an das Meer, wo ich dann denken würde Ja, dann verkauft doch die uhr und fahr für das Geld ans Meer. Das wäre doch eigentlich das Schönere.
Tastatur und brauche das Geld also mehr, dass er sich hier allen Ernstes als Vorbild sieht und deswegen auch so redet statt als Opfer, finde ich grotesk, denn es ist ganz schlimm zu hören.
Ja.
Ja, aber an dem Punkt sind wir ja angekommen. An dem Punkt sind wir ja leider angekommen.
Menschen werden zu Instagram kacheln und verkaufen das dann als Vorbild. Und er hat natürlich auch, wie sich das gehört, ein Modelabel. Und dieses Modelabel heißt Polzer. Woran erinnert dich das?
Selbstverständlich an den Bolzplatz. Und auch hier haben wir eine schöne Geschichte.
Bolzplatz meets Street Style.
Warum hast du dich dafür entschieden und nicht gesagt Hi, ich mache Prada Gucci 3.0.
Ich liebe ja den Fußball und alle anderen Sportarten auch. Und da war die Idee damals dahinter. Die ist dann in Bamberg, da habe ich studiert.
Entstanden ist auch eine ganz kleine, süße Stadt, Kopfsteinpflaster sehr oft.
Und da kam dann aufgrund dieses Kopfsteinpflaster und,
meine Affinität auch zum Fußball die Idee Wir machen Street Style Street selber ein bisschen cool aussehen, ein bisschen overseas, die die Tshirts, dann Hoodies, die viele Leute tragen.
Viele meiner Freunde lieben Hoodies oder ich glaube fast alle.
Das ist natürlich eine ganz groteske Herausforderung, der sie sich stellt.
Nämlich zum einen Ich bin der Mann ohne Persönlichkeit, der Mann ohne Eigenschaften. Mir ist alles recht. Ich brauche nur meine kleine uhr, die fällt nicht weiter auf. Und dann? Die Orte sollen möglichst genau, die Orte sollen möglichst neutral, trocken. Da soll immer Sicherheitspersonal sein, denn ich brauche immer was zu kaufen.
Bezahlbar mit Geld?
Ja, genau. Er ist investiert. In eine Sicherheitsfirma übrigens noch.
Und gleichzeitig dieses Bemühen, diese nicht mehr vorhandenen Reste von Persönlichkeiten noch mal zu exportieren in irgendein Produkt, damit andere das attraktiv finden ist.
Und gleichzeitig dieses Bemühen, diese nicht mehr vorhandenen Reste von Persönlichkeiten noch mal zu exportieren in irgendein Produkt, damit andere das attraktiv finden. Ist es das wirklich?
Also es ist wirklich grotesk.
Ist das genial? Es ist. Jetzt geht es noch weiter.
Jetzt geht es noch weiter und das ist unser Plan, den du dahinter hast Ein Bäumchen zeig der Welt, wo du herkommst.
Und was ich total magst. So dieser Claim, den du dahinter hast.
Da ist unser Claim, den du dahinter hast. Ein Böser zeigt der Welt, wo du herkommen.
Polzer zeigt der Welt, wo du herkommst. Ich finde, das ist irgendwie. Das hat so eine Romantik.
Ich bitte um Platz für Romantik.
Ja, das liegt ehrlicherweise daran, dass auch wenn du mal den Bolzplatz jetzt nimmst, da ist es total egal, welche Religion du hast, welche Hautfarbe.
Mitte der 70er Jahre bis. Aber nimm mal den Bolzplatz mit.
Ja.
Wenn man den Felsblock jetzt. Da ist es. Total egal. Welche Religion macht euch?
Da ist es. Total egal.
Welche Religion war's? Welche Hautfarbe? Dann sind wir alle gleich.
Da sind wir alle gleich.
Da sind wir alle gleich. Es geht ums Gewinnen.
Es geht ums Gewinnen. Und dann bist du mit deinem Teamkameraden eins.
Zehn Kameraden eins. Das widerspricht allem, was wir auf anderen Instagram Kacheln sehen. Es ist egal, wo du herkommst. Wichtiges Umfeld?
Das widerspricht allem, was wir auf anderen Instagram Kacheln sehen, Nämlich Es ist egal, wo du herkommst, wichtig ist, wo du hin willst.
Also das ist also wirklich jetzt auch wieder rum.
Ganz genau. Ja, und jetzt dreht das aber auch wieder rum. Wir hören uns den letzten Clip an ich entschuldige mich fast dafür, dass ich das ausgesucht habe, aber ich finde, es ist so symptomatisch für unsere Zeit. Denn Patriotismus geht natürlich auch noch dazu.
Wir hören uns den letzten Schliff an mich entschuldigen, dass ich das ausgesucht habe, aber das ist so symptomatisch für unsere Zeit. Denn.
Patriotismus geht natürlich auch noch dazu. Aber ich finde, man sollte dennoch nie vergessen, wo man herkommt. Ich würde das Ganze nicht hinter dem deutschen Image.
Aber ich finde, man sollte dennoch nie vergessen, wo man herkommt. Ich finde das ganz wichtig. Finde in Deutschland haben wir.
Nie vergessen. Wo man herkommt, spürt das Ganze. Ich finde, in Deutschland haben.
Historisch bedingt ein Problem mit Patrioten. Das finde ich.
Ist Thorsten Probleme zu.
Das wäre komisch. Das ist ja echt so eine Störung in der Geschichte gewesen, dass wir jetzt ein Problem mit Patrioten haben.
Ja komisch. Das ist irgendwie, dass wir das noch nicht ablehnen konnten. So ganz. Ja.
Wie schade, weil ich finde, man sollte schon stolz sein oder man kann stolz sein, wo man herkommt und meine Mutter ist.
Ich finde, man soll sinnvoll sein. Man kann stolz sein.
Ich finde, man soll schon stolz sein. Man kann stolz sein. Hier kommt unser.
Wo man herkommt. Und man ist dann stolz auf den Ort. Bonus Ja, ja, ja. Das.
Also man ist dann stolz ja auf den Bonus. Dann kann ich sagen Ja, ich hatte richtig Glück, ich bin richtig viel besser ausgestattet als irgendjemand aus einem nordafrikanischen Land.
Er. Ja, das ist auch das, was wir bei der Queen so vermisst haben, dass sie noch mal stolz ist, dass sie zur royalen Familie. Und da. Und so weiter. Das ist genau das, was gefehlt hat.
Berlinerin. Mein Papa ist deutsch, ich bin in Deutschland geboren. Ich bin da total stolz drauf.
Ich bin in Deutschland geboren. Super glücklich in Deutschland zu leben. Das macht die.
Ich bin super glücklich, in Deutschland zu leben. Das Land bietet einem unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten.
Unglaublich viele möglich. Man hat hier viele, viele Sicherheit, die man auf der Welt und.
Man hat hier viele, viele Sicherheiten, die man auf der Welt sonst wirklich vermisst.
Und deswegen, egal wo man herkommt, sollte man glaube ich nie vergessen. Und wenn man das nicht vergisst, sollte man es auch allen Menschen zeigen. Das finde ich ganz, ganz wichtig, dass man nicht vergisst, wo man herkommt und auch dazu steht und den Leuten dann zeigt was ist denn vielleicht aus deinem Land das Besondere?
Flughäfen, Hotels.
Wenn es sinnvoll ist, sollte man doch allen Menschen zeigen. Das finde ich ganz genau richtig, wenn man weiß, wo man herkommt und auch dazu steht und.
Ja, das wäre doch das Allerschlimmste, Blödeste, wenn wir irgendwann eine Welt haben, in der wir nicht mehr fragen Und wo kommst du eigentlich wirklich her?
Wir wir müssen unbedingt die ganze Zeit den Identitäts diskurs und wenn da jemand perfekt Deutsch kann, der Taxifahrer von Elke Heidenreich aber, der nicht weiß ist, dann müssen wir unbedingt noch mal nachfragen, was er.
Wir müssen unbedingt die ganze Zeit eine Identität erforschen. Und wenn da jemand perfekt Deutsch kann und ergreifen, wenn er nicht weiß, dass.
Hier denn eigentlich zu suchen hat oder woher er kommt.
Ja, das ist ja für mich so diese Arbeitsauftrag. Ich habe mir in Bielefeld meinen ostdeutschen Tonfall abgelegt und versuche auch hier einfach, einen modernen Lebensstil für die Kinder und so weiter zu leben.
Frage. Ich habe mir in Bielefeld meinen ostdeutschen Tonfall abgelegt und versuche auch hier einfach einen modernen Lebensstil für die Kinder und so weiter zu leben.
Nein, ich muss jeden Morgen aufstehen und mich daran erinnern, dass ich aus Thüringen komme.
Nein, ich muss jeden Morgen aufstehen und mich daran erinnern, dass ich aus Thüringen komme. Und ich muss ganz stolz auf diese Bratwurst Herkunft sein, wenn ich das jemals vergesse, dass wir hier komplett meinen.
Und ich muss ganz stolz auf diese Bratwurst Herkunft sein. Wenn ich das jemals vergesse, dann verliere ich ja komplett mein dann fühle ich mich auf Flughäfen nicht mehr wohl, weil okay, Flughäfen sind so geil, weil sie nicht Thüringen sind. Aber nie vergessen, dass du aus Thüringen kommst. Jeden Morgen.
Ich fühle mich auf Flughäfen nicht wohl dabei. Okay, Flughäfen sind okay, weil sie nicht Thüringen sind, aber nie vergessen das aus Thüringen kommt.
Ich Mein Erfolgsrezept ist ja auch seit vielen Jahren, den fröhlichen Rheinländer zu spielen.
Es ist entsetzlich, aber ich glaube, hier sind wir mal an den Kern der Ideologie vorgedrungen, der Identitäts Ideologie, aus der man wunderbar Produkte generieren kann.
Luxusuhren, die einen an Sommerurlaub mit der Familie erinnern, oder dann auch irgendwelche Modelabels, die irgendwo produziert werden, die aber dann ein Identitätsgefühl herstellen sollen.
Und der Bolzplatz ist zum einen dann der Ort, an dem alles egal ist, wo du herkommst. Aber zugleich ist Patriotismus auch toll, das man zeigt woher man kommt.
Also man packt alles zusammen und das ist ja das interessante eigentlich.
Na, packt alles zusammen. Und das ist ja das Interessante eigentlich, wenn man es mit.
Wenn man es mit diesen neuen vorwiegend rechten Identitäts Strömungen zu tun hat, dann ist er immer so, dass da.
Diese neuen vorwiegend rechten Identitäts Strömungen zu tun hat.
Dann ist ja immer so, dass da man auf 1000 Widersprüche stößt.
Man auf 1000 Widersprüche stößt und hier, das ist ja ein hoch widersprüchliches System, das ist ja voller.
Ja, das ist ja ein hoch widersprüchliches System, das ist ja voller Eklektizismus und dennoch funktioniert es.
Eklektizismus und,
dennoch funktioniert es.
Und das zeigt, wie chaotisch unsere Tage sind, wie unübersichtlich die Gegenwart ist und wie dann versucht wird, mit der Bändchen Theorie noch ein wenig Ordnung ins Ganze zu bringen.
Und das zeigt, wie chaotisch unsere Tage sind, wie unübersichtlich die Gegenwart ist und wie dann versucht wird mit der ganzen Theorie.
Naja, ich habe jetzt rausgehört, das war dein letztes Thema.
Immer? Ja.
Gut, dann schließe ich mit einem zweiminütigen kleinen Listing, Du weißt, was ein lustig halt ist für Leute, die keine Lust haben zu lesen.
Die kriegen einfach eine Liste. 0.1 bis 10 bietet sich in dem Fall an, denn wir haben ja gerade gehört, man solle nie vergessen, wo man herkommt und stolz drauf sein.
Wir interessieren uns also für das 2022 Ranking the best countries.
Erhoben von US News Dotcom.
Nach einer Methodologie, die ja in einem ganz großen Text ganz raffiniert aufgeschlüsselt ist Quality of Life, Entrepreneurship, Agility oder Agility Social Purpose spielt eine Rolle.
Movies Cultural Influence, Open for Business, Adventure, Power Heritage alles spielt eine Rolle in verschiedenen Gewichtungen von interessanterweise vier und 10,52 % für Quality of Life bis 3,09 % für Heritage.
Und jetzt kleine Rätsel Frage Welches Land ist auf Platz eins das beste Land der Welt?
Ist es am Ende Japan oder so, weil man da. Ah ja, natürlich.
Nein, es ist die Schweiz, Es ist die Schweiz. Wer hätte es gedacht. Aber Platz zwei Deutschland.
Wer hätte es gedacht. Aber Platz zwei, Deutschland. Hach. Also wenn ihr euch fragt, warum ich noch mal stolz sein kann.
Also wenn ihr euch fragt, warum soll ich noch mal stolz sein? Ihr seid auf Platz zwei, dann kommt Kanada, dann kommt Amerika, dann Schweden, Japan, Australien, UK, Frankreich, Dänemark.
Dann kommt Kanada, dann kommt Amerika, dann Schweden, Japan, Australien, UK, Frankreich, Dänemark.
Ich finde die Liste abenteuerlich, denn egal welche Kriterien man nimmt, Japan ist gerade kein lebenswertes Land.
Ich find die Liste abenteuerlich, denn egal welche Kriterien man nennt, Japan ist gerade kein lebenswertes Land.
Das ist macht keinen Spaß da zu leben. Also alle Texte die man bekommt Sinn, ist aber ganz begehrt, wenn es um Staatsbürgerschaften geht. Deswegen habe ich es gleich genannt.
Das ist macht kein Spaß da zu leben. Also alle Texte die man bekommt, sind begehrt, wenn es um Staatsbürgerschaften geht. Deswegen habe ich es gleich gemacht.
Ja, es ist von außen betrachtet ein reiches Land. Letztens flog auch wieder so ein Thread durch Twitter mit Kanada, wie es in Kanada wirklich ist. Kein frisches Gemüse im Supermarkt, alle Autos auf Lautstärke getrimmt, niemand kümmert sich um irgendwen und alles, was man so hört ist Legende.
Gerade was Nachbarschaftshilfe und so angeht, sondern nein, es ist einfach genau so der gleiche westliche Scheiß wie überall sonst.
Plus keine eigene Kultur wie wir auch. Alles muss importiert werden aus Amerika und sonst woher. Also da ist man unter ferner liefen.
UK Auf Platz acht hat man sich mal umgeguckt in UK und mal von den Londoner Tourismus Hotspots abgesehen.
Also das ist wirklich kein Land, in dem man das wo man gerade gerne ist, denn sich es wird hier wieder ein Müll im Internet zusammengetragen. Es ist wirklich grotesk. Die ganzen skandinavischen Länder spielen hier gar keine Rolle.
Dänemark auf Platz zehn, da würde ich sagen nein. Also Dänemark muss da höher gerankt werden in der Hinsicht.
Es geht drunter und drüber. Und wer auf seine Herkunft stolz ist, ich weiß auch nicht, wie so was ermessen und bemessen und nach welchen Maßstäben und überhaupt und wer sich auf seine uhr zurückziehen kann und daraus Lebensqualität schöpft.
Also wohl. Dem würde ich sagen. Beneidenswert.
Ja, und wir empfehlen eher so etwas wie Geselligkeit.
Und das machen wir ja auch. Wir gehen ja auch in diesem Monat noch mal wieder in die Oper.
Und auch noch mal hier mein Aufruf, nicht nur in die Oper zu gehen, sondern auch generell gesellig zu sein, Dinge wahrzunehmen, ins Kino zu gehen, verschiedene Veranstaltungen zu besuchen.
Und dann blicken wir mit Freude auf den nächsten Salon.
Wir werden also sprechen über das Buch von Harald Welzer und Richard David Precht.
Hast du schon was vorbereitet? Ich kann bislang nur eins ankündigen, weil ich noch nicht weiß, wie umfangreich dann diese Arbeit daran wird, nämlich Nick Land.
Das ist ja ein Akzelerationismus, der sich dann ganz nach rechts bewegt hat.
Da ist jetzt bei Matthes und Seitz ein Buch erschienen mit Texten von ihm, okkultes Denken und einer Korrespondenz, die interessanterweise Dietmar Dath mit diesem Nick Land geführt hat. Und dieses Buch will ich mir mal genauer ansehen.
Dietmar Dath Ich bin ein super Fan. Ich werde, wie schon angekündigt, zur demographischen Lage Russlands. Das ist wirklich super interessant, Das ist da in Grund und Boden klar. Ich sage jetzt, das ist eh die wichtigste Dimension, aber wie sehr es ausgeblendet wird, ist doch erstaunlich.
Stephen King wird 75, er hat 75 Bücher geschrieben und weil auf Twitter eine Ein Geburtstags Artikel empfohlen wurde von Matthias Kalle in der Zeit, werde ich suchen, ob ich ihn vielleicht auf Papier irgendwo finde, in den Tiefen des Stapels, der sich mittlerweile ansammelt.
Ansonsten lesen wir die Online Version, die steht nämlich frei zur Verfügung.
Ja, dem in Horst hat Kunst verbrannt. Es scheint da wohl irgendwie keine Ahnung, ob sich der Text dazu lohnt.
Und ansonsten ja, mal schauen.
Ich glaube, ich werde noch mal einen Blick nach Afrika werfen, weil diese ganze,
Desertec wir brauchen Energie von denen und zwar nicht, weil wir Öl Löcher bohren, sondern dann wirklich mal kooperativ statt kolonialistisch mit ihnen so Energie Partnerschaften schließen. Da gibt es wohl auch interessante Texte.
Also so brand eins und so, da verspricht man sich ja einiges. Der in Sicht wird es ein interessanter Salon. Aber ich freue mich natürlich auf das Buch.
Wunderbar. Dann einen schönen Monat und bis zum Salon.
Ich glaube, das wird ein Spektakel dann.
Zum Salon. Haut rein!